WELCOME TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES ON
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AND
HEALTH TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF VAPING TOBACCO CANNABIS
PRODUCTS HEALTH EFFECTS AND
DEFICIENCIES IN REGULATION
CURRENT LAW. LIKE TO BEGIN BY
WELCOMING THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND THANKING THEM FOR BEING
HERE OUR WITNESSES AND
CERTAINLY THE GENERAL PUBLIC
FOR YOUR TENNIS TODAY. I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE STAFF FROM THE
RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES FOR
PUTTING TOGETHER AN INDEPTH
AGENDA ON THIS IMPORTANT AND
TIMELY TOPIC. THIS JOINT
INFORMATION HERE WILL BE THE
FIRST OF TWO HEARINGS ON THE
SUBJECT OF YOU CIGARETTES AND
VAPING. TODAY'S HEARING WILL
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
ISSUES RELATED TO VAPING
INCLUDING THE HEALTH OF FACTS
AND REGULATORY LANDSCAPE WITH
TESTIMONY PROVIDED BY MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TO BACK ON VAPING
EXPERTS AND STATE GOVERNMENT
REGULATORS. THE HEARING WILL
ALSO LOOK INTO THE GROWING
POPULARITY BE CIGARETTES IN
VAPING EXAMINE THE OVERALL.
IMPACT ON USE AND GENERAL
CONSUMERS. E. CIGARETTES OR
VAPING DEVICES WITH SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL SALES
OF BECOME PART OF THE DAILY
LIFE FOR MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
VAPING IS RISEN DRAMATICALLY IN
POPULARITY AROUND THE WORLD
FROM SEVEN MILLION USERS IN
TWENTY ELEVEN TO OVER THIRTY
FIVE MILLION USERS TODAY. AS
THIS HAPPENS TRADITIONAL
TOBACCO SMOKING RATES CONTINUE
TO DECLINE. HOWEVER RECENT
STUDIES HAVE FOUND THAT MORE
THAN HALF OF AMERICAN ADULTS E.
CIGARETTE USERS ARE UNDER
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE
FUELING CONCERN ABOUT THE
POPULARITY OF VAPING AMONG
YOUNG PEOPLE. YOUTH ACCESS AND
USES SKYROCKETED WITH THE
PREPARATION OF FLAVORS
ATTRACTED TO THE TEENAGERS SUCH
AS BAZOOKA JOE BUBBLE GUM
COTTON CANDY AND GUMMY BEARS.
FEDERAL STATISTICS SHOW A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN VAPING
AMONG TEENS BETWEEN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. MORE
THAN ONE IN FOUR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS REPORTED VAPING IN THE
PAST MONTH. UP FROM ONE IN FIVE
STUDENTS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THE SERVER YOU SOMEONE MIDDLE
STUDENTS HAS ALSO MIDDLE SCHOOL
STUDENTS HAS ALSO INCREASED.
FEDERAL HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE
CALLING THIS TROUBLING TREND AN
EPIDEMIC IN FEAR THAT TEENAGERS
WHO VAPE WILL EVENTUALLY START
SMOKING. BUT NOW AS A
LEGISLATURE WE'RE NOT ONLY
FACED WITH THE ISSUES OF RAPID
RISE IN TEEN E. CIGARETTE USE
BUT A NATIONAL OUTBREAK OF
MYSTERIOUS LONG INJURY CASES.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE USE OF
VAPING PRODUCTS. THE CDC NOW
REPORTS SERVING THIRTEEN
HUNDRED VAPING ELLIS'S AT LEAST
TWENTY SIX NATION WIDE LINKED
TO THE USE OF THE CIGARETTES.
AND RAPING. THERE ARE NO MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED. NEW CASES
REPORTED JUST LAST WEEK AND THE
CDC TOLD CONGRESS THIS MORNING
THAT THE STATISTICS ARE
UNFORTUNATE EXPECTED TO
INCREASE CONSIDERABLY IN THE
NEAR FUTURE. THE MEDIAN AGE OF
DC'S TO PATIENTS WAS FORTY NINE
YEARS OLD. THE RANGE WAS FROM
SEVENTEEN TO SEVENTY FIVE YEARS
OLD. ACCORDING TO RECENT
FINDINGS BY THE CDC MOST OF THE
PATIENTS IMPACTED BY THESE
ILLNESSES REPORTED USING T. H.
C. CONTAINING PRODUCTS
SUGGESTING THG PRODUCTS ARE
PLAYING A ROLE IN THESE
ELLIPSES. THAT SAID SOME
PATIENTS HAVE REPORTED USING
BOTH THC PRODUCTS AND NICOTINE
PRODUCTS AS WELL AS A SMALLER
NUMBER REPORTING USING ONLY
NICOTINE PRODUCTS. SIMILAR
TESTING ON THE SAMPLES
COLLECTED OR RECEIVED BY THE
FDA SHOWS A VARIETY OF PRODUCTS
OR PRODUCT COMPONENTS WITH
DIFFERENT INGREDIENTS OR
DELIVERY SYSTEMS MAKING THIS
INVESTIGATION ESPECIALLY
CHALLENGING. AUTHORITIES ARE
STILL GATHERING INFORMATION BUT
ACCORDING TO RECENT REPORTS
PATIENTS WITH THE CONDITION
SEEM TO BE OVERWHELMINGLY MALE
AROUND 70% WITH 80% OF PATIENTS
UNDER AGE THIRTY FIVE.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC THERE THE
INVESTIGATION IS ONGOING AND NO
SINGLE BRAND PRODUCT SUBSTANCE
OR ADDITIVE HAS BEEN LINKED TO
ALL CASES. WHILE THE CAUSE OF
THE OUTBREAK REMAINS UNKNOWN
THE CDC WARNS AGAINST THE USE
OF ANY CIGARETTE OR ANY PAPER
PRODUCT. ASIDE FROM THE RECENT
WIRELESS'S OUTBREAK THE LONG
TERM HEALTH EFFECTS OF
CONTINUED EAST CIGARETTE VAPING
USE REMAIN ON NO ONE IS A
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNICANT IN USED
TO STUDY THE HEALTH HAZARDS.
POSED BY THIS TECHNOLOGY.
BOTTOM LINE WE STILL DO NOT
HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS BUT AS A
LEGISLATURE MUST GET A GRASP ON
THE MULTIPLE CASES SURROUNDING
THE CIGARETTES PEIPING. WE MUST
CONSIDER THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONCERNS IMPACTS ON YOUTH BLACK
MARKET ENFORCEMENT ISSUES AND
THERE IS AN ADEQUATE STATE
REGULATION OVERSIGHT. WE NEED
TO IDENTIFY WHERE EXISTING
EFFORTS HAVE FAILED AND DISCUSS
EXPERT RECOMMENDATIONS TO
REVERSE THE DEEPLY CONCERNING
EPIDEMIC OF BEAUTY CIGARETTE
USE A BABY NEWS. IN CHILDREN'S
AND FAMILIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THEY WILL SERVICE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ESTABLISH A
CONSISTENT SET OF FACTS SO
THERE WERE ALL OPERATING OFF
THE SAME SET OF FACTS AND
HIGHLIGHT THE BEST AVAILABLE
INFORMATION WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
I WOULD NOW ASK CHAIRMAN LOW
FOR HIS OPENING REMARKS. THANK
YOU VERY. MUCH I MISTER CHAIR
AND AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO THE COLLECTIVE WORK OF OUR
RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES AND
FORMING THIS IMPRINT THIS AGAIN
I KNOW THAT THIS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING OF THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE HAVE TO BE. AS
RESPONSIVE TO CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND THE
CONSTITUENCIES THAT WE
REPRESENTS A SIMILE WITHIN THE
RESPECT OF A BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS YOU HIT ON THE HEAD
MISTER CHAIR BUT- OUR IN
REGARDS TO THE- THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND CANNABIS. AND
I'M PART OF THE CRISIS ON
VAPING IS WITH RESPECT TO THE
FAILURE OF THE REGULATORY
SYSTEM AND TO WHICH THE LEGAL
ACCESS TO QUALITY REGULATED
CANNABIS. PRODUCTS ARE THE
STATE IS RELATIVELY LIMITED IN
FACT AS WE WELL KNOW ROUGHLY
THREE QUARTERS OF CITIES AND
COUNTIES. HAVE BEEN LICENSE
CANNABIS RETAILERS SITTING
THOSE AREAS TO UNLICENSED
UNREGULATED UNTAXED AND
UNTESTED ILLICIT MARKET
OPERATORS. ASSEMBLY WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THE IDENTIFY ROOT
CAUSES AND IMPACTS OF THESE
ILLNESS. WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THOSE RESPONSIBLE ACTORS WITHIN
THE LEGAL AND THE ILLICIT
MARKET AND WE NEED TO HOLD THEM
RESPECTFULLY TO ACCOUNT THAT
BEING SAID. WE ARE LOOKING AT
WHAT TO DO ON TO PROTECT
INDIVIDUALS IN THE MARKET PLACE
AND AVERAGE CALIFORNIANS. IT
MAY ALSO BE OF CONSIDERATION
THAT WE EXPLORE A MORATORIUM ON
ADDITIVES WHICH APPEARS TO
REFLECT. INDUSTRY'S BEST
PRACTICES WE AS A STATE OUR
PORT OF ENTRY FOR A LOT OF
BEEPING SUPPLIES IT THE UNITED
STATES. AND I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
AND PARTICULAR IMPORTANT ROLE.
YEAH WITH RESPECT TO THE
INDUSTRY AS A LARGE STATE AND
THE NATION'S SUPPLY CHAIN OF
THE ILLICIT MARKET PLACE. IN
BOTH CANNABIS AND NICOTINE
BEATING PRODUCTS SO I VERY MUCH
LOOK FORWARD TO THE TESTIMONY
FROM OUR PUBLIC OF
REPRESENTATIVES. AND LOOK FOR
TO THEN CONTINUED CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO. THE
CHAIRS HERE AND I THINK A
CHAIRMAN GRAY ACTUALLY FRAME
THIS DISCUSSION VERY VERY WELL
AS A STAR AS A STARTING POINT
SO. I JUST WHAT I'LL BE BRIEF I
REALLY WANT TO HEAR FROM OUR
EXPERTS THIS AFTERNOON. BUT YOU
HAVE SOME COMMENTS I THINK THE
EXPLOSION OF POPULARITY OF THE
CIGARETTES HERE AT THE
CIGARETTE USE HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM FOR SOME TIME. WAS
STAGGERING NUMBERS OF YOUTH
BECOMING ADDICTED TO NICOTINE.
IN THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS HAS
BECOME ALL TOO CLEAR THAT WE
HAVE A MUCH BIGGER PROBLEM ON
OUR HANDS WITH THE OUTBREAK. OF
LONG ILLNESS AND INJURIES AND
DEATH AND THE QUESTIONS AROUND
EXACTLY WHAT'S CAUSING THIS. MY
COLLEAGUES AND I ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING ON ALL ASPECTS OF
THIS ISSUE AND BUYS AS YOU'VE
HEARD THIS HEARING IS JUST A
FIRST STEP. I BREAK THIS INTO
TWO DIFFERENT IN MY MIND THE
WAY I LOOK AT THIS AND THERE
ARE MANY ASPECTS TO THIS I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT ONE. THE NUMBER
OF YOUNG PEOPLE THAT ARE
STARTING TODAY. PERIOD WHETHER
IT'S- NICOTINE OR THC. NUMBER
TWO. THE ILLNESS THAT WERE
FACING THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
THAT WE'RE FACING THERE AND SO
I THINK. AS WE START HEARING
ABOUT THIS. I THINK THOSE ARE
SEPARATE ISSUES IN MANY WAYS
THERE IS SOME CROSS OVER BUT-
THAT'S HOW MY- MY- WEIRD
COMPARTMENTALIZED MIND WORKS.
SO WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
INTRODUCE OUR FIRST PANEL. SO I
ASKED HIM TO PLEASE COME UP.%
DOCTOR ALISA TONG. AND KIMBERLY
BACK TO DORI. WHO WILL GIVE US
AN OVERVIEW OF THE VAPING E.
CIGARETTE INDUSTRY. AND DISCUSS
THE PREVALENCE OF PRODUCTS USE.
THANK YOU IN ADVANCE. THANK YOU
I THEIR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ELISA TONG AND I'M
SPEAKING TODAY AS A PRACTICING
PHYSICIAN AND TOBACCO RESEARCH
EXPERT FOR IDENTIFICATION
PURPOSES BOB I WORKED AT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS.
TODAY MY SUMMER BACK TO DORI
FROM THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
ADVOCACY NETWORK AND I WILL
SHARE SOME BRIEF BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ABOUT UNDERSTANDING
THE NEW VAPING EPIDEMIC FOR
CALIFORNIA. THE WORD EPIDEMIC
HAS BEEN USED FOR YEARS TO
DESCRIBE HOW TOBACCO IS THE
LEADING PREVENTABLE CAUSE OF
DEATH NOW THE WORD EPIDEMIC IS
BEING USED FOR VAPING WITH THE
SHARP RISE IN YOUTH RATES THE
MASSIVE PROLIFERATION OF
PRODUCTS AND SHOCKING NEW CASES
OF AVIAN ASSOCIATED PULMONARY
INJURY AND DEATHS FIRST I'LL
HIGHLIGHT SOME KEY POINTS FOR
THE REGULATORY HELP LANDSCAPE
NEXT MISS HOMER BACKDOOR WILL
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPACT AND-
YOUTH. AND YOUNG ADULTS. AT
THIS IS WHAT I CALL MY GREATEST
HITS LIKE. BUT LOOKING BACK
LESSONS FROM THE PAST ABOUT
MARKETING AND SCIENCE ARE
IMPORTANT FOR UNDERSTANDING
WHAT IS GOING ON TODAY. SO IN
THE FIFTIES AND SIXTIES WHEN
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES THAT FIRST
STARTED LINKING SMOKING
CIGARETTES TO LUNG CANCER
EMERGED THE TOBACCO COMPANIES
STARTED RUNNING. THESE HISTORIC
ADVERTORIALS CALLED A FRANK
STATEMENT TO CIGARETTE SMOKERS
TO CREATE DOUBT BY DISPUTING
THE STUDY FINDINGS. SAYING
EXPERIMENTS WITH MICE WERE NOT
REGARDED AS CONCLUSIVE FOR LUNG
CANCER THEY ALSO RAN ADS
SHOWING DOCTORS HERE PROMOTING
PRODUCTS. THEY ALSO STATED THEY
BELIEVE THEIR PRODUCTS WERE NOT
INJURIOUS TO HEALTH AND THAT
THEY WOULD COOPERATE FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND THEN GROWING OVER
TIME ALL THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE TEN YEARS LATER IT
TOOK THE FIRST SEARCH LANDMARK
CERTAIN GENERAL'S REPORT IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR TO
SYMPATHIZE ALL THAT BIOLOGICAL.
AND DEPUTY A LOGICAL EVIDENCE.
CONCLUDING THAT SMOKING DOES
INDEED CAUSE LUNG CANCER.
SUBSEQUENTLY THE U. S. CONGRESS
ADOPTED LAWS FOR HEALTH
WARNINGS ON CIGARETTE PACKAGES
IN ADVERTISING BANS IN THE
BROADCAST MEDIA. HOWEVER
TOBACCO CONTROL WORK CONTINUES
TODAY AT THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL STATES DUE TO
THE QUOTE THE ADDICTIVE NATURE
OF TOBACCO. AND POWERFUL
ECONOMIC FORCES PROMOTING ITS
USE. NOW IN THE SEVENTIES
EIGHTIES THE NEXT COUPLE
DECADES THE INDUSTRY STARTED
TRYING TO DEVELOP AND MARKET
NEW PRODUCTS AS LESS HARMFUL TO
SMOKERS. BUT IT WAS ACTUALLY
THE EVIDENCE THAT NON SMOKERS
COULD ALSO BE HARMED THAT HAD
THE MOST IMPACT SAMPLES IN THE
ROOM MAY NOT HAVE BEEN ALIVE
DURING THIS TIME BUT- THAT
ADVERTISEMENT ON THE LEFT HAND
SIDE WITH THE DISCO LADY. SHOWS
THAT THE INDUSTRY SOLD LOW TAR
CIGARETTES MILD LIGHT ULTRA
LIGHT CIGARETTES ARE LESS
HARMFUL BECAUSE WE KNEW THAT
TARA CAUSE CANCER WHEN IT WAS
PAINTED ON THE BACKS OF MICE
MAYBE THIS WAS A WAY TO GET
LESS CANCER. HOWEVER THESE
CIGARETTES WERE ALSO MACHINE
TESTED FOR LOWER LEVELS OF TAR
BUT THAT'S NOT REALLY WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN PEOPLE ACTUALLY
USE THESE PRODUCTS. SO IT DID
NOT ACTUALLY REDUCE THE HEALTH
RISKS OF SMOKING AND IT TOOK US
YEARS TO FIGURE THAT OUT. SO IN
REAL LIFE SMOKERS COULD CHANGE
THE WAY THEY SMOKE BECAUSE THEY
WERE TRYING TO GET A LOT MORE
NICOTINE AND THEY COULD
ACTUALLY GET THE SAME AMOUNT OF
CHEMICALS OR EVEN MORE. THAN
THE MACHINE BASED NUMBER
SUGGESTED. SO AS- TIME WENT ON
IN THE MID NINETEEN EIGHTIES
THE SURGEON GENERAL CAME OUT
WITH A REPORT ON. THE GROWING
AGAIN THE GROWING SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE THAT SECONDHAND SMOKE
EXPOSURE CAUSED HARM TO
NONSMOKERS AND IN FACT BECAUSE
LIKE CANCER. THIS EVIDENCE HELP
STIMULATE ABROAD RATE OF CHANGE
FROM. SOME OF YOU IN THE ROOM
MAY REMEMBER NO SMOKING
SECTIONS WHICH PEOPLE JOKINGLY
SAY IT'S LIKE HAVING A NO
PEEING SECTION IN A POOL.
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T REALLY WORK.
TO NOW WHAT WE HAVE FOR SMOKE
FREE POLICIES THAT PROTECT
NONSMOKERS SO. IN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE VERY FORTUNATE THAT
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WITH OUR
FOR OUR FIRST TOBACCO TAXED.
THAT WE CREATED A COMPREHENSIVE
TOBACCO CONTROL PROGRAM TO
CHANGE SOCIAL NORMS AROUND
SMOKING. REDUCE PRODUCT
AVAILABILITY AND PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH. INSTEAD OF ONLY
FOCUSING ON TREATING INDIVIDUAL
SMOKERS ON THIS APPROACH HAS
BEEN WIDELY RECOGNIZED
INTERNATIONALLY. AS ONE OF THE
GREATEST PUBLIC HEALTH SUCCESS
IS TO THIS DAY. NOW THE
NINETIES TO THE TWO THOUSAND
WERE MARKED BY LAWSUITS. UP
WHISTLE BLOWERS HELPED BRING
INTERNAL TOBACCO INDUSTRY
DOCUMENTS TO LIGHT THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY PROTECTED THROUGH
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
THESE INTERNAL DOCUMENTS
DOCUMENTS WHEN STARK CONTRAST
TO THE PICTURE IN THE UPPER
RIGHT OF WHERE THE TOBACCO
INDUSTRY CEOS AT THE TIME
TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF CONGRESS
I BELIEVE NICOTINE IS NOT
ADDICTIVE. SUBSEQUENTLY THE
STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S UP
SUIT FOR MEDICAID COSTS FOR
TOBACCO RELATED DISEASE LEADING
TO WHAT IS CALLED AS THE MASTER
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX THE US DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE RULED THAT THE INDUSTRY
VIOLATED THE RACKETEERING AND
CORRUPT INFLUENCE ORGANIZATIONS
LAW CONCLUDING THAT INDUSTRY
QUOTE. CONTINUES TO ENGAGE IN
AND EXECUTE A FIFTY YEAR SCHEME
TO DEFRAUD THE PUBLIC ON HEALTH
EFFECTS AND MARKETING TO
CHILDREN. AND THEN FOR YEARS
AFTERWARDS THE INDUSTRY ARGUED
AGAINST FEDERAL PENALTIES AND
IT TOOK OVER A DECADE LATER IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEENTH FOR
THEM TO FINALLY ERIC QUOTE. OF
CONSTRUCTIVE COURT ORDERED
STATEMENTS WHICH SOME OF WHICH
ARE SEEN ON THE LOWER RIGHT.
AND SO THESE RAN KIND OF IN
LIKE MIKE TV'S BLACK AND WHITE
THERE'S YOU CAN STILL SEE SOME
OF THEM ON YOUTUBE. HOWEVER
STUDY SHOWED THAT ONLY 40% OF
US. ADULTS WERE ACTUALLY AWARE
OF THESE CORRECTIVE STATEMENTS
ABOUT THE RANGE OF WHAT THEY
HAD THE STATE INCLUDED IT
KNOWLEDGE MENTION THAT.
NICOTINE WAS INDEED ADDICTIVE
LOW TAR LIGHT ULTRALIGHT MILE
THE NATURAL CIGARETTES ACTUALLY
LACKED HEALTH BENEFITS AND WERE
DECEPTIVELY MARKETED AS LESS
HARMFUL. THE CIGARETTES FROM
MANIPULATED TO MAXIMIZE
NICOTINE DELIVERY. AND THAT
THERE IS NO SAFE LEVEL OF
EXPOSURE TO SECONDHAND SMOKE.
SO NOW WE COME TO THE FOOD AND
DRUG ADMINISTRATION IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE THEY WERE GIVEN
AUTHORITY TO REGULATE TOBACCO
PRODUCTS. THIS INCLUDED THE
MANUFACTURE DISTRIBUTION AND
MARKETING OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
THE FDA IS SUPPOSED TO APPROVE
THAT NEW PRODUCTS ARE NOT WORSE
THAN CIGARETTES BEFORE THEY GO
TO MARKET. THERE ALSO SUPPOSED
TO APPROVE ANY MARK PRODUCTS
MAKING CESSATION OR REDUCED
HARM CLAIMS. ARE GO THROUGH
THEIR OFFICE AS WELL AND
PRODUCTS LIKE JEWEL HAVE NOT
DONE FOR EXAMPLE. FLAVORS AND
CIGARETTES HAVE ALREADY BEEN
BANNED THROUGH THIS REGULATION
EXCEPT FOR MENTAL CIGARETTES
DUE TO INDUSTRY PRESSURE.
HOWEVER THIS LED TO THE RISE OF
NEW PRODUCTS THAT WERE NOT
QUOTE CIGARETTES SOME YOU CAN
SEE ON THE FAR UPPER RIGHT THAT
DID NOT HAVE TO FOLLOW RULES
MADE FOR CIGARETTES. UP WITH
THE BROWN PAPER WRAPPING. YOU
COULD SUDDENLY HAVE A CIGARETTE
YOU OR LITTLE CIGAR AND YOU
DON'T HAVE TO FOLLOW THE FLAVOR
PACKAGING RULES THAT WERE MADE
FOR CIGARETTES. ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES FROM THE RISE AS
WELL BUT IT TOOK YEARS FOR THE
FDA TO FINALIZE WHAT'S CALLED
THE QUOTE DEEMING ROLL. UP TO
BEGIN REGULATION THAT WAS IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND THE
FDA DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION OF
THAT FOR. UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
TWO FOR MANUFACTURERS TO SUBMIT
INFORMATION AND IMPROVE THEIR
PRODUCTS BUT NOW WITH PUBLIC
PRESSURE AS YOU ALL MAY WELL
KNOW. THIS HAS BEEN MOVED UP TO
NEXT YEAR. THIS COMPLICATED BUT
LET ME WALK YOU THROUGH THIS
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS CALIFORNIA
SUCCESS STORY IS THAT CIGARETTE
SMOKING PREVALENCE RATES HAVE
DECLINED FASTER THAN THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY. BUT THE NEWS
NOW IS THAT BEEPING AND
MARIJUANA USE RATES. ARE RISING
ESPECIALLY IN YOUNG ADULTS. SO
THIS DATA FOCUSES ON THE
GENERAL ADULT POPULATION IT'S
MISS SUMMER BAGUETTE OR HE'S
GOING TO DESCRIBE YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULTS. SINCE CALIFORNIA
HAS A TOBACCO TWENTY ONE LAW
NOT TO SELL TO PERSONS UNDER
TWENTY ONE. SO THE BAR CHART
SHOWS ON THE FAR RIGHT THAT IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ARE
CALIFORNIA PROBLEMS FOR ANY
TOBACCO USE. WAS ALMOST FIFTEEN
PERCENT. ON THE FAR LEFT YOU'LL
SEE CIGARETTES THAT'S TEN
PERCENT. AND ONLY 3% FOR
BEEPING THAT LITTLE BAR THE
SECOND BAR FROM THE LEFT.
HOWEVER AT YOUNGER PEOPLE WHO
ARE AGE TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
NINE YEARS OLD THEY BAIT THAT
MUCH HIGHER RATES WITH 11% IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND 13%
AND- TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. AND
USERS MAY USE OUR SWITCH ACROSS
MULTIPLE TOBACCO PRODUCTS. AND
IN THE U. S. OVER HALF OF THE
CIGARETTE USERS ARE CURRENT
SMOKERS. MARIJUANA USE ON THE-
RIGHT IN ADULTS ESPECIALLY
YOUNG PEOPLE IS ALSO RISING.
WITH OVER ONE AND FOR YOUNG
ADULTS OVER TWENTY ONE.
SIMILARLY CO USE OF MARIJUANA
AND TOBACCO IS RISING NOW WITH
ONE EIGHT YOUNG ADULTS OVER
TWENTY ONE. SO WHAT THE SLOW
FEDERAL REGULATORY LANDSCAPE
FOR VAPING IT'S DIFFICULT TO
KNOW WHAT'S ACTUALLY IN THESE
THE CIGARETTE PRODUCTS AND
THEIR AIR ASSAULT AT DESPITE
WHAT THEY'RE LABELED HOUSE THIS
IS A GRAPHIC FROM THE CDC WHERE
THEY NOTE THAT PRODUCTS THAT
ARE MARKETED AS EVEN HAVING NO
NICOTINE. HAVE BEEN FOUND TO
CONTAIN NICOTINE SO STUDIES TO
DATE SHOW THAT THIS AEROSOL IS
NOT WATER VAPOR WHICH IS WHAT
MANY PEOPLE THINK AND THE
PUBLIC INSTEAD THIS AEROSOL AS
A CHEMICAL MIXTURE THAT CAN
CONTAIN PROPYLENE GLYCOL
VOLATILE ORGANIC COMPOUNDS
CARCINOGENS HEAVY METALS
FLAVORS. AND CULTURE FINE
PARTICLES ULTRA FINE PARTICLES
FOR EXAMPLE CAN ARE JUST SOME
OF THE SUBSTANCES THAT CAN HAVE
IMMEDIATE HARMFUL EFFECTS SO
ALL OF US WHO EXPERIENCE THE
CALIFORNIA SMOKY FIRES FOR
EXAMPLE OR FREEWAY AIR
POLLUTION. THERE THOSE THINGS
ARE ALL OF THE ULTRA FINE
PARTICLES ARE KNOWN TO CAUSE
INFLAMMATION THAT'S IMPORTANT
FOR HEART AND LUNG FUNCTION IN
PARTICULAR. EVEN IF SOME
PRODUCTS CONTAIN LESS OF THESE
HARMFUL INGREDIENTS THE CDC HAS
UNDERSCORED. THIS DOES NOT MEAN
IT IS A SAFE PRODUCT. THERE
ISN'T IN FACT NO SAFE TOBACCO
PRODUCT WE ALREADY LEARNED THAT
LOW TAR CIGARETTES AS DEFINED
BY MACHINE DOESN'T MEAN IT'S A
SAFER PRODUCT WE ARE STILL
LEARNING HOW HEATING AND
INHALING CHEMICALS IN THESE
PRODUCTS. AFFECT THE HUMAN BODY.
SO DESPITE HAVING BEEN BANNED
IN CIGARETTES FLAVORS AND THEIR
MARKETING OF FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS ARE CONCERNING FOR THE
RISE AND USE AND THEY'RE
HARMFUL HEALTH EFFECTS. SO JUST
A COUPLE EXAMPLES HERE SOME
MENTHOL. HAS BEEN MOST NOTABLY
BEEN TARGETED TOWARDS THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY. ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO A TOBACCO
RELATED HEALTH DISPARITIES.
JOHN BEING JUST A FLAVOR
PREFERENCE THE GROWING EVIDENCE
ABOUT MENTHOL IS THAT ITS
NUMBING PROPERTIES MAKE IT
EASIER EASIER TO AND INITIATE
AND HAIL. ITS CHEMICAL
PROPERTIES MAKE IT HARDER TO
QUIT BECAUSE IT'S ACTUALLY
WORKING ON THE NICOTINE
RECEPTORS AND IT AND THERE'S AN
ASSOCIATE A CARCINOGEN WITH
THESE OILS COUPLE GUNS AND
THERE THERE'S A RECENT JAM
ARTICLE THAT SAYS. THERE ARE
LEVELS THAT ARE HIGHER WAY
HIRING E. CIGARETTES THAT
ACTUALLY WHAT'S IN REGULAR
CIGARETTES OR ALSO FTA LEVELS
FOR FOOD AND IT'S BEEN BANNED
AS A FOOD ADDITIVE AS A
SYNTHETIC. CHEMICAL. OTHER
FLAVORS THAT ARE APPEALING TO
CHILDREN INCLUDE FRUIT CANDY OR
SWEET FLAVORS THAT HAS BEEN
NOTED. BUT THESE HAVE SAFETY
STANDARDS THAT ARE MEANT FOR
EATING NOT FOR AN HAILING.
GROWING EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
THESE FLAVORS BY THEMSELVES AND
IN COMBINATION CAN HARM HEALTH.
SUCH AS WITH LUNG FUNCTION
BLOOD VESSEL CELLS AND WHITE
BLOOD CELLS WHICH IS IMPORTANT
FOR AT YOUR- IMMUNITY. I ALSO
FEEL WHICH IS FOUND IN THREE
QUARTERS OF E. LIQUIDS IS
ASSOCIATED WITH BRONCHIOLITIS
OBLITERANS AN IRREVERSIBLE LUNG
DISEASE DESCRIBE AND WORKERS
FROM BUTTER POPCORN FACTOR
FACTORIES. SO THE HIGH POTENCY
OF NICOTINE. LEVELS AND
MARIJUANA'S PSYCHOACTIVE
COMPONENT THC AND THESE BACKING
PRODUCTS IS REALLY ALARMING.
IMPACT THE SURGEON GENERAL HAS
RELEASED WARNINGS TO YOUNG
ADULTS FOR BOTH OF THESE
COMPONENTS BECAUSE THE
DEVELOPING BRAIN IS ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE THROUGH AGE TWENTY
FIVE. NICOTINE ITSELF IS NOT
HARMLESS WITH POTENTIAL FOR
CARDIOVASCULAR EFFECTS BOB
SEIZURES AND EVEN POISONINGS
IT'S USED IN PESTICIDES. WITH
BABY NEW NICOTINE SALTS AND
LIQUIDS HAVE HIGH BIO
AVAILABILITY AND ARE MORE
EASILY ABSORBED WITH LESS
AEROSOL THAN REGULAR CIGARETTES
AND REGULAR CIGARETTES. THE
INDUSTRY HAD USED AMMONIA TO
BASICALLY FREE BASE HIGHER
LEVELS OF NICOTINE I'M TO BE
ABSORBED IN YOUR BODY. IN FACT
THAT DIAGRAM ON THE RIGHT IT
SURE IS FROM THE CDC AND IT
SHOWS ONE SMALL JEWEL POD AT E.
JUICE CONTAINS AT LEAST AS MUCH
NICOTINE AS ONE PACK OF
CIGARETTES BUT AGAIN AS NOTED
IN MAYBE EVEN HIGHER DEPENDING
ON HOW YOU USE IT. NEWER
PRODUCTS. AT THAT YOU HAVE EVEN
HIGHER E. LIQUID CONCENTRATIONS
OF NICOTINE MAYBE FROM
REFILLABLE. AND AS MORE PEOPLE
BAIT MARIJUANA THE SURGEON
GENERAL HAS PUT OUT A WARNING
THAT THC CONCENTRATIONS OF
INCREASED THREE FOLD OVER THE
PAST COUPLE DECADES. SO THIS
HEALTH EFFECTS OF VAPING THESE
HIGH POTENCY NICOTINE AND
MARIJUANA PRODUCTS. INCLUDING
IN COMBINATION AND HOW HEATING
MIGHT BE DIFFERENT THAN
BURNING. THIS IS ALL LEARNING
FOR EVERYONE AND PUTTING THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION AND THIS IS
AN ONGOING NATURAL EXPERIMENT
IN HUMANS. SO AND AS MENTIONED
NOW THIS PAST SUMMER WITH THE
VAPING ASSOCIATED PULMONARY
INJURY ALL THIS COMBINATION OF
ON THE RISE IN VAPING NICOTINE
AND MARIJUANA. AT HAS BROUGHT
US TO THIS STATE UP SO EVERY
WEEK THE CBC'S REPORTING MORE
CASES SO AS MENTIONED EARLIER
UP THIRTEEN HUNDRED CASES OVER
A HUNDRED. CASES IN CALIFORNIA
TWENTY SIX DEATHS INCLUDING
THREE IN CALIFORNIA KING COUNTY
TULARE COUNTY IN LA COUNTY. AND
THIS ISN'T JUST A YOUTH PROBLEM
BECAUSE THE MEDIAN AGE OF DEATH
IS FORTY NINE YEARS OLD AND THE
RANGE IS SEVENTEEN TO SOMEBODY
FIVE. AND AGAIN THE CDC STATES
NO SINGLE PRODUCT OR SUBSTANCE
HAS BEEN LINKED TO ALL CASES
ALTHOUGH MOST REPORTED BEEPING
TEACH SEE A IT'S ONLY ABOUT A
THIRD EXCLUSIVELY. AND WELL
OVER HALF REPORTED BEEPING
NICOTINE SO THE CDC HAVE COME
OUT TO SAY TO THE PUBLIC PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT USE VAPING PRODUCTS
WITH THC CONSIDER THAT AS WELL
FOR NICOTINE PRODUCTS ALSO.
OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS ARE NOT
TO BUY BEEPING PRODUCTS OFF THE
STREET OR MODIFY OR ADD
SUBSTANCES HOWEVER MANY PEOPLE
GET THEIR PRODUCTS SOCIALLY
FROM OTHERS SO IT'S HARD TO
TELL. REGARDLESS OF THE
INVESTIGATION THE CDC
EMPHASIZES THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
PREGNANT WOMEN AND NEVER USERS
SHOULD NOT VAPE THERE IS NO
SAFE TOBACCO PRODUCT USE AND T.
H. C. IS ASSOCIATED WITH A WIDE
RANGE OF HEALTH EFFECTS
ESPECIALLY AMONGST HEAVY USERS.
AND WE'RE STILL LEARNING ABOUT
THAT. ON TO THE STATE. IT'S
WORTH NOTING ALSO THAT
SECONDHAND SMOKE EXPOSURE
NONSMOKERS HAS BECOME. THAT
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT ISSUE SO
THE CDC IMAGE ON THE LEFT
DESCRIBES HOW THE SURGEON
GENERAL HAS CONCLUDED THAT
AEROSOL FROM PEIPING CAN
CONTAIN HARMFUL SUBSTANCES. AND
USE IN PUBLIC PLACES UNDERMINES
EXISTING PROTECTIONS FOR NON
USERS. BACK IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
THERE IS A CERTAIN GENERAL'S
REPORT THAT CONCLUDED THERE IS
NO RISK FREE LEVEL OF EXPOSURE
TO SECONDHAND SMOKE AND NON
USERS. THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR HEART AND LUNG
HEALTH. AND ON THE RIGHT HAND
SIDE IS THE IMAGE FROM
CALIFORNIA'S A TOBACCO CONTROL
PROGRAMS NEW SECONDHAND DANGERS
CAMPAIGN. THEM WHERE THEY
DESCRIBE OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS SECONDHAND MARIJUANA
EXPOSURE THINKING INCREASED BY
86% SECOND HAND DEEP EXPOSURES
INCREASED. BY 67% AND IT'S
WORTH NOTING ALSO THAT 30% OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ALSO REPORT
EXPOSURE TO SECONDHAND SMOKE.
VAPOR AND MARIJUANA SO THE
SMOKE AND TOBACCO FREE POLICIES
THAT PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH NOW
NEED TO CONSIDER VAPING
INCLUDING MARIJUANA. SO
WRAPPING UP SMOKING CESSATION
HAS A STRONG EVIDENCE BASE THAT
IT WORKS COUNSELING SUPPORT AND
MEDICATIONS CAN HELP PEOPLE
QUIT FOR GOOD. HOWEVER IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE HIGHLY ADDICTIVE
NATURE OF NICOTINE IT CAN TAKE
AT LEAST EIGHT TO TWELVE REALLY
GOOD AT TIMES FOR SOMEONE TO
QUIT FOR GOOD. AND PROVIDERS
ARE TOLD THEY SHOULD ASK ABOUT
TOBACCO USE EXPOSURE ADVISED TO
QUIT AND ADVISE ABOUT HEALTH
HARMS. AND REFER TO COUNSELING
SUPPORT AN OFFER MEDICATIONS WE
ARE STILL TRYING TO LEARN WHAT
TO DO ABOUT THE THING. IT'S NOT
EVEN A REQUIREMENT FOR US TO
ASK ABOUT THE THING. BUT OUR
STATE QUITE LINE NOW THE
CALIFORNIA SMOKERS HELPLINE AT
UC SAN DIEGO THEY HAVE NOW
STEPPED UP AS OUR FREE
STATEWIDE RESOURCE TO HELP NOT
ONLY. HELP PEOPLE QUIT SMOKING
BUT ALSO WITH A BANG AND THIS
INCLUDES FOR TEENS. THERE ARE
SEVEN FDA APPROVED TOBACCO
CESSATION AIDS TO ASSIST WITH
NICOTINE WITHDRAWAL SYMPTOMS
OVER TWO TO THREE MONTHS AND
MOST PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THE NICOTINE PATCH LAWCENTER
Gí
FASTER ACTING MODALITIES LIKE
THE NASAL SPRAY IN AN INHALER
NONE OF WHICH ARE MEANT TO GO
INTO YOUR LUNGS. THIS IS LIKE
THE BACK OF YOUR THROAT AND
SHE'D ABSORPTION. AND NONE OF
THESE ARE MEANT TO BE FOR LONG
TERM EITHER. SO IN THE U. S. U.
CIGARETTES ARE NOT APPROVED AS
A SMOKING CESSATION AID AS
CONCLUDED BY THE U. S.
PREVENTIVE SERVICES TASK FORCE
WHICH REVIEWS ALL THE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE. BUT NOW
ARE HEALTH SYSTEMS AND
PROVIDERS ARE NOW CHALLENGED UP
WITH FIGURING OUT HOW TO ASK
ADVISE AND TREAT. PEOPLE WHO
BAKED AND TO HELP PEOPLE QUIT
BAKING FOR GOOD. SO WITH THAT
I'LL TRANSITION TO. SUMMER BY
THE DORY. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
MY NAME IS KIM HOMER BAGUETTE
OR AND I'M WITH AN ORGANIZATION
THAT WORKS STATEWIDE ON TOBACCO
CONTROL ISSUES WITH YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULTS AND WE ALSO WORK
WITH ALL OF OUR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE ON
SMOKING TOBACCO FREE POLICY
INITIATIVES TODAY I'M GOING TO
HIGHLIGHT AND SUMMARIES FOR YOU
THE NATIONAL AND STATE DATA WE
HAVE ON YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULT
USE. I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS IS TOBACCO HAVE YOU
BECAUSE THAT'S MY AREA OF
EXPERTISE BUT IT'S ALSO WHAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF RESEARCH ON. SO
LOOKING AT CURRENT USE WE NOW
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL THAT WE
SAW OUR PEAK. IN U. FATE BEING
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND WE
STARTED TO GO DOWN. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN WITH A SLIGHT UPTICK IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. MUCH OF THIS
IS DUE TO THE TYPES OF DEVICES
THAT WERE AVAILABLE ON THE
MARKET. PRIOR TO THE NEW
DEVICES THAT WE HAVE WE LIKE TO
SAY THERE ARE THREE TYPES OF
PRODUCTS. WEEK SICK LIKE SIR
THE FIRST THEY LOOK JUST LIKE
LITTLE CIGARETTES. THE SECOND
ARE THE V. PENS WHICH NOW WE'RE
HEARING FROM YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
REALLY ONLY BEING USED AS WAX
PENS TO BE. TEACH SHE
SOLUTIONS. AND THEN THE THIRD
FOR THE MONTH AND THE TANKS.
AND PART OF THE CHALLENGES WITH
THESE PRODUCTS WERE THEY WERE
NOT VERY GOOD AT DELIVERING
NICOTINE SUSPICION. AND SO
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT GETTING
SATIATED WHEN USING THEM IN
TRYING TO. USE THEM OTHER THAN.
OTHER TOBACCO PRODUCTS. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE ALL CHANGED WITH
THE INTRODUCTION OF THE NEW POD
BASED PRODUCTS. THERE ARE TWO
THINGS THAT CHANGE WITH THESE
PRODUCTS THE FIRST WAS THE SIZE
OF THE DEVICE WHICH IS VERY
PROBLEMATIC FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY'RE EASY TO HIDE.
AND BECAUSE ARE ALSO SMALLER
THE BATTERIES ARE SMALLER
THERE'S LESS AEROSOL THAT IS
OMITTED FROM THEM AND SO THERE
IS. VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO TAX.
THE SECOND WAS THE TYPE OF
SOLUTIONS THAT'S IN THESE
PRODUCTS SO IT'S A NICOTINE
SALT SOLUTION IT'S EASIER TO
CONSUME AND SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER AND NICOTINE SOLUTIONS.
THAN THE OTHER PRODUCTS BEFORE
THESE. THESE ARE THE PRODUCTS
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
USING IN THESE ARE THE PRODUCTS
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
EPIDEMIC THAT WE ARE NOW
RECOGNIZING AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL. SO WITHIN A ONE YEAR
PERIOD. WE SAW AN INCREASE OF
ONE AND A HALF MILLION STUDENTS
USE STUDENTS. WHO INCREASE
THEIR USE OF THESE PRODUCTS
WITH FREE SHIPPING. AND THE
GREATEST INCREASE WAS SEEN
AMONG HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. I'M
LOOKING AT THE RECENT DATA THAT
WAS RELEASED FROM THE NATIONAL
GOVERNMENT. THIS IS PRELIMINARY
DATA AND MORE WILL BE COMING
SOON BUT IT'S SHOWING THAT WE
ARE CONTINUING TO SEE AN
INCREASE IN THE FADING OF
TOBACCO PRODUCTS. AND SO IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN THE ALARMS
WENT OFF WE SIGN INCREASE UP TO
ALMOST 21% THAT HAS JUMPED
AGAINST NEARLY 28% AND THIS IS
PASTA THIRTY DAY YOU SAID THIS
IS NOT EVER USE THIS IS.
REGULAR THIRTY DAY USE. WHAT'S
ALSO TROUBLING IS THE TYPES OF
PRODUCTS THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
USING SO WE KNOW IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THERE OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND UNIQUE FLAVORS OF EVEN
DEVICES ON THE MARKET. AND WE
KNOW THAT YOUNG PEOPLE WERE
MOST LIKELY TO USE CANDY
FLAVORED OR FRUIT FLAVORED. BUT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE SEEN A
JUMP OF YOUNG PEOPLE USING
MINTS AND THEN SLATED PRODUCTS.
SO WE HAVE A LOT TO CELEBRATE
WITH OUR CIGARETTE SMOKING
WE'VE DONE SOME PHENOMENAL
GROUP WORK TO GET US DOWN 22%
AT THE HISTORIC LOW. BUT THAT
IS NOT THE SAME WITH ALL
TOBACCO PRODUCTS AND SO
SPECIFICALLY LOOKING IN
CALIFORNIA. THE DATE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHICH WE SAW AS MUCH
AS TIME WE'RE DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW. DATA A YEAR AGO CAN
BE ARCHAIC WHEN WE'RE DEALING
WITH THIS PROBLEM. BUT WHAT WE
HAVE IS NEARLY 11% OF TEENS
REPORTED TO PASS THIRTY DAY USE
OF VAPING DEVICES. AND YOU CAN
SEE WITH THE YELLOW IN THIS
CHART THE MAJORITY OF THE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE BEING USED
REGARDLESS OF ITS VAPING OR
ANOTHER TOBACCO PRODUCT. IS A
FLAVORED. PRODUCT. I'M DATA
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
TOBACCO SURVEY ALSO SHOWS THAT
YOU USE OF MARIJUANA IS HIGH.
SO THERE WAS NOT ANY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES FROM TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
USE BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT MARIJUANA USE AMONG TEENS
IS STILL HIGHER THAN TOBACCO
USE. AND ALSO HIGHER THAN E.
CIGARETTE USE. I'M THE SURVEYS
THAT THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
ASKED ON THE SURVEY ASK
STUDENTS WHO REPORTED VAPING
WHAT TYPES OF PRODUCTS A. B.
TEN THEY DID ASK OF THE BATES
TEACH SEE SOLUTION. AND 21%
CLOSE 222% OF TEENS DID REPORT
VAPING TEACH SHE PRODUCTS IN
CALIFORNIA. NOW LOOKING AT
YOUNG ADULTS WE SEE A SIMILAR
TREND AND THAT CIGARETTE
SMOKING IS GOING DOWN. THE
CIGARETTE USE IS GOING UP AND
MARIJUANA USE HAS GONE UP
SIGNIFICANTLY. I'M WE AGAIN I
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN TRYING
TO REDUCE COMBUSTIBLE PRODUCTS
BUT THE SAME CAN'T BE SAID FOR
BEEPING DEVICES. WHAT'S
INTERESTING AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES FOR OVER EIGHTEEN
YEARS. IS IT FOR A LONG TIME
WE'VE BEEN SEEING THE USE OF
TOBACCO USE RATES GO DOWN WITH
COLLEGE STUDENTS SO WE CAN
PREDICT THAT IF SOMEBODY DOES
NOT GO TO COLLEGE. THAT THEIR
LIKELIHOOD OF SMOKING
CIGARETTES HIGHER THAN SOMEBODY
WHO IS IN COLLEGE. NOW THAT HAS
BEEN COMPLETELY REVERSED BY
THIS TREND BEEPING. AND SO
COLLEGE STUDENTS NOW HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER RATES OF
BEEPING NICOTINE SOLUTIONS AND
VAPING MARIJUANA PRODUCTS THAN
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO NOT GO TO
COLLEGE. ONE CHALLENGE WITH
THIS SPECIFICALLY IN TWO AS OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES MANY
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH ARE NOW
SMOKING TOBACCO FREE. HAVE AN
INFLUX OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
ADDICTED TO THESE PRODUCTS
WE'RE NOW GOING TO THEIR
CAMPUSES. AND ARE IN NEED OF
SUPPORT TO HELP THEM QUIT. AND
THEY'RE GOING TO SMOKING
TOBACCO FREE CAMPUSES BUT OUR
K. THROUGH TWELVE CAMPUSES ARE
SMOKING TOBACCO FREE IN YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE STILL USING THESE
PRODUCTS. SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
LITERATURE SPECIFIC TO WHY
YOUNG PEOPLE USE TOBACCO
PRODUCTS AND SPECIFICALLY VAPE.
WE HAVE EVIDENCE THAT SHOWS
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE OF IT BECAUSE
IT'S THEIR NORM SERVE THEIR
FRIENDS ARE USING THESE
PRODUCTS OR THEY HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO USE THEM THEY'RE
MORE LIKELY TO USE THEM. WHAT'S
INTERESTING IS IF YOU TALK TO A
YOUNG PERSON IF YOU TALK TO
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO USE THEIR
PERCEPTION OF WHAT THE USE IS
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN WHAT
IT ACTUALLY IS. AND SO THAT
MAKES THEM BELIEVE THAT IT'S
COMPLETELY NORMALIZED TO USE
THESE PRODUCTS WHAT'S
INTERESTING MANY OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT WE WORK WITH HAVE
NOT BEEN EXPOSED TO SECONDHAND
SMOKE INDOORS THEY'VE GROWN UP
IN A SMOKE FREE CALIFORNIANS
THE NORM OF CIGARETTE SMOKING.
IS NOT THERE. WE'VE COMPLETELY
REVERSED THAT WITH KEEPING
BECAUSE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE SAYING
AT AND THEY THINK EVERYBODY
DOES IF YOU EVER TALK TO
EIGHTEEN YOU ASK THEM HOW. DO
YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT BE IF THEY
SAY YES EVERYBODY IS VAPING.
I'M ALSO WITH FLAVORS SO
FLAVORS WAS A HIGH INDICATOR OF
WHY PEOPLE ARE USING THESE
PRODUCTS TO EXPERIMENT WITH
FLAVOURS. AND IT WHEN WE ASKED
WE DO FOCUS GROUPS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE AND WE ASKED THEM ABOUT
THE PRODUCTS THAT THEY USE. AND
ALL OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE WE
TALKED TO SAY THEY USE PRODUCTS
BECAUSE OF THE FLAVORS AND THEY
TASTE GOOD. AND FLAVORS IN THE
VAPING DEVICES WERE AWESOME
COMBUSTIBLE PRODUCTS AT MASS
THE HARSHNESS OF. THE SMOKE AND
IT MAKES THEM BELIEVE THAT IT'S
NOT AS BAD. WE'VE HAD AND
FLAVORED CIGARETTE PRODUCTS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF MONTHLY THE
PRODUCT. AND SO THERE'S A LOT
OF MISPERCEPTIONS ROUND THE
HARMS OF MANY OF THESE
PRODUCTS. AND E. CIGARETTES ARE
ALSO INCLUDED IN THAT. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW AS WELL THAT
WHEN WE DID OUR FOCUS GROUPS
WITH YOU OF WHAT WE TALK
PRIMARILY ABOUT TOBACCO. THE
CONVERSATION WE HAVE THE IN
PERSON WRAPS BACK INTO
MARIJUANA. AND WHILE YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE MIXED FEELINGS ON
THE SAFETY OF E. CIGARETTES THE
MAJORITY OFYOUNG PEOPLE WE
TALKED TO BELIEVE THAT
MARIJUANA WAS COMPLETELY SAFE.
SO ANOTHER REASON FOR THIS IS
THE ACCESS TO TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
SO WHEN JULIA STARTED TO BECOME
POPULAR IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THE TRUTH
INITIATIVE THAT NATIONAL STUDY
SPECIFIC TO INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD
REPORTED TOOL USE TO FIND OUT
WHERE THEY WERE READING THESE
PRODUCTS AND AS YOU CAN SEE THE
MAJORITY OF YOUNG PEOPLE
REPORTED THAT THEY WERE GETTING
THEM IN THE RETAIL ENVIRONMENT.
AND GETTING THEM LOCALLY. AND
SO WHEN WE LOOK HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OUR BIGGEST
OFFENDERS OF RETAILERS ARE
SELLING TOBACCO PRODUCTS ARE
ACTUALLY THE TOBACCO IN THE
SHOPS WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
NOT ALLOWED IN. AND YET THEY
ARE SELLING AT RATES HIGHER
THAN. LEVELS OF ANY OTHER
RETAILER. SO SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE. FOR AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE. THE FIRST IS WE
HAVE EXTENSIVE DATA TO SHOW
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
EXPERIMENT WITH VAPING OR YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO DO VAPE. ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE LIKELY TO
BECOME TOBACCO USERS USE A
COMBUSTIBLE PRODUCTS THAT THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN USING BUT STIL
WILL START USING. OR USE
MARIJUANA PRODUCTS. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT THE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE LEAVING TODAY WOULD NOT
HAVE CONSIDERED SMOKING A
CIGARETTE. THEY WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN AT HIGH RISK FOR TOBACCO
USE AND NOW THEY ARE BECAUSE OF
THEIR BEEPING BEHAVIOR. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT YOU CIGARETTE RATES
ARE CONTINUING TO GROW. AND USE
OF COMBUSTIBLE CIGARETTES IS
DECREASING OR STAYING THE SAME
IN SOME POPULATIONS. IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO KNOW AS DOCTORS
HUNG IT SAID THAT THE LAW THE
PRODUCTS THAT YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
USING TODAY HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER LEVELS. OF NICOTINE THAN
THE PRODUCTS OF THE PAST WHAT'S
HARD ABOUT THESE PRODUCTS WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE USING. SO I'M LIKE A
CIGARETTE THAT YOU WOULD BUY
YOU WOULD SMOKE IT AND THEN IT
WOULD BE EXTINGUISHED AND WOULD
BE DONE THESE PRODUCTS ARE USED
AND SH STUDENTS ARE SHARING
THEM. WHEN WE TALK TO TEENS
ABOUT THEIR USE AND WE ASKED
THEM IF THEY ON THE PRODUCTS
THEY SAY NO WHAT HAPPENS IS
THEY LEAVE CLASS THEIR FRIEND
DOES A PUFF PUFF AND THEN
PASSES THE PRODUCT TO THEM. AND
THEN THEY PUFF PUFF AND PASS IT
BACK AND SO THEY ARE SHARING
DEVICES AND SHARING DIFFERENT
SOLUTIONS AND OFTEN TIMES THEY
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY BEEPING. WHAT'S ALSO
INTERESTING IS IN NINETEEN
NINETY AFTER THE MASTER
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT WAS SIGNED
WE SAW A CHANGE IN FACT THESE
BEHAVIOR AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE
WHERE YOUNG PEOPLE WOULD
EXPERIMENT WITH TOBACCO BEFORE
THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN AND IF THEY
BECAME ADDICTED THEY WOULD DO
SO IN THEIR YOUNG ADULT YEARS.
AND THAT HAS SHIFTED IN MY TIME
IN TOBACCO CONTROL THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THAT WE HAVE YOUNG
ADULTS OR YOUTH THAT ARE
ACTUALLY SELF IDENTIFYING AS
BEING ADDICTED TO TOBACCO AND
SEEKING HELP IN QUITTING. AND
WE'RE TRYING DESPERATELY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THEM THAT
HELP. OFTENTIMES THEY MAY NOT
BE READY TO QUIT BUT AT LEAST
MOTIVATING. FOR THOSE QUITE
ATTEMPTS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY ARE DEAD.
LOVE THE DICTION. ARE VERY
DIFFERENT AS WELL AND AGAIN WE
DON'T FULLY UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH
NICOTINE INDIVIDUALS ARE
GETTING IT'S BASED ON THE
PRODUCTS ARE USING THE BY
AVAILABILITY OF THOSE PRODUCTS.
THE FREQUENCY OF USE AND THAT
IS STILL NOT PERFECT SCIENCE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT. THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES ARE RESPONDING.
THIS DATE IS ALREADY OUTDATED
THAT'S ANOTHER ORDINANCES
PASSED EARLIER THIS WEEK BUT AS
OF FRIDAY THERE WERE FORTY FOUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT HAD
ORDINANCES. THAT SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO FLAVORED PRODUCTS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
MUCH OF THIS WORK WAS STARTED
EARLY ON IN RESPONSE TO FTA NOT
INCLUDING MENTHOL. IN THE BAN
ON CIGARETTES SO MUCH OF THIS
WORK STARTED TO TRY TO
ELIMINATE INFLATED PRODUCTS
FROM THE MARKET. AND HAS SINCE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE ALL OF
VAPING PRODUCTS I'M OTHER
PRODUCTS SUCH AS WHO GOT THE
MAJORITY OF HOOKAH BARS IN OUR
STATE ACTUALLY WITHIN A MILE OF
A COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY CAMPUS
SO IT'S NOT SURPRISING THE
COLLEGES. COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE
THE HIGHEST RATES OF WHO CAN
USE IN OUR STATE. SO WHEN WE
LOOK AT THIS MORE MORE
COMMUNITIES ARE STARTING TO
AMEND THEIR TO FACTORY TELL
LICENSE OR DOCKED ORDINANCES
SPECIFICALLY BANNING THE SALE
OF ALL FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS ALTHOUGH SOME DO HAVE
EXEMPTIONS. WE DO HAVE RIGHT
NOW IT'S FOUR ORDINANCES BUT
PREVIOUSLY THREE ORDINANCES
THAT BANNED THE SALE ELECTRONIC
SMOKING DEVICES. I'M SAN
FRANCISCO AND RICHMOND HAVE
LIMITATIONS ON THEIRS IF FTA
WERE TO APPROVE THESE PRODUCTS
LIVERMORE SPAN IS A COMPLETE
BAN WITH NO END DATE. AND THEN
OF COURSE THE BEVERLY HILLS TO
PASS AN ORDINANCE THAT BANNED
THE SALE F ALL TOBACCO
PRODUCTS IN THEIR COMMUNITY
WITH THE EXCEPTION. OF THREE
CIGAR BARS THAT WERE LEFT IS AN
EXEMPTION TO ALLOW USE AND SALE
WITHIN THOSE BARS. SO IN
SUMMARY WE DO HAVE AN EPIDEMIC
AND WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
HISTORY OF WORKING WITH AN
INDUSTRY THAT HAS UTILIZED
TACTICS TO TRY TO DISSUADE THE
CONVERSATION ON PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE NEW E. CIGARETTE COMPANIES
HAVE EMPLOYED MANY OF THE SAME
STRATEGIES AND THEY'RE UNDER
FEDERAL NGHE SHOULDN'T. INTO
GRIFFIN FEDERAL LITIGATION FOR
THAT RIGHT NOW. THERE ARE
NUMEROUS HEALTH CONCERNS WITH
ALL OF THESE PRODUCTS IS DR TOM
HAD MENTIONED THE HIGH POTENCY
OF THESE NEW POPPIES PRODUCTS
BOTH WITH NICOTINE BUT ALSO
TEACH SHE IS VERY ALARMING. WE
SEE SOME OF THE PRODUCTS WE HAD
OUR TEAM'S BEEN DOING FOCUS
GROUPS FOR YEARS AND ANNUALLY
WE ASK THEM ABOUT THE PRODUCTS
THAT THEY SEE WHAT PRODUCTS
THEY USE. DEPENDS. FULL AS WAX
KINDS AND THEY KNOW EXACTLY
WHERE TO GET THE CARTRIDGES AND
HOW TO GET THEM. WE KNOW THAT
YOU THINKING ABOUT THE BEING
HAS CONTINUED TO INCREASE AND
AS NEW DATA FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOWS. IT IS
CONTINUING. AND WE KNOW THAT
THE BURDEN OF THIS PROBLEM IS
CURRENTLY EXISTING OTHER K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS IN OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES WHERE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE USING THESE
PRODUCTS. AND HEALTH SYSTEMS
ARE ALSO TRYING TO IDENTIFY HOW
DO WE HELP THESE PEOPLE QUIT
USING THEM. BUT THERE IS A
RESPONSE FOR A LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA TO
RESPOND. AND THERE ARE NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT ARE GOING TO TRY TO
REDUCE THESE RATES AND THE
SUPPORT A TOBACCO FREE.
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE YOUR
PRESENTATION IT'S BOTH VERY
INFORMATIVE AND PRETTY ALARMING
QUITE FRANKLY. I'D LIKE TO OPEN
THIS UP TO THE- TO THE MEMBERS
FOR QUESTIONS. QUESTIONS FROM.
OKAY MR GRAMM. THANK YOU ARE.
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. I'M
CURIOUS. ABOUT THE ATTENTION
YOU WENT OVER THE LOCAL
ORDINANCES. AT THE CITY AND
COUNTY LEVEL TRUCK CALIFORNIANS
I NOTICED EVERYONE OF THEM JUST
FLAVORED TOBACCO IN ANY SICK
YEARS RIGHT YET DURING THE
PRESENTATION UNLESS I READ
THERE ARE IT COULD BE THAT THE
HIGHEST UC'S TO BE MARIJUANA.
EXCEPT OR VAPING AMONGST
TEENAGERS WHICH SEEMS
CONSISTENT SINCE THE- OUTBREAK
OF THIS PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AT
LEAST WITH ILLNESSES AND THE-
YES I'VE HAD NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS WITH SCHOOL
OFFICIALS IN MY DISTRICT.
EVERYONE OF THEM HAS SUGGESTED
THAT THE GREAT MAJORITY OF
PRODUCTS THAT THEY CONFISCATE
FROM YOUNG PEOPLE AT THE HIGH
SCHOOLS EVERYONE. AND IS
CURIOUS THAT THE PUBLIC POLICY
RESPONSE STARTING WITH THE
PRESIDENT ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL IS RUNNING
PRESENTATION. IS EXCLUSIVELY
FOCUSED ON EAST SIX. WHEN
THAT'S NOT APPARENTLY THE
NUMBER ONE DRIVER CERTAINLY A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTOR WHICH
ALSO WAS NOT IN YOUR
PRESENTATION WHY DO YOU THINK
THAT IS. SO IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE OUR TOBACCO TAX DOLLARS
ARE USED TO FIND A
COMPREHENSIVE TOBACCO CONTROL
PROGRAM TO ADDRESS TOBACCO
CONTROL ORDINANCES A SIMILAR
PROGRAM FOR MARIJUANA DOES NOT
EXIST. IN THE STATE. TO HAVE A
PROGRAM THAT EXIST. THAT MY TO.
DRIVE MORE OF THESE LOCAL
ORDINANCES EFFORTS MAYBE CALLS
FOR THE BANNING OF FLAVORED
MARIJUANA FOR EXAMPLE. I CAN'T
COMMENT ON THAT SPECIFICALLY
BUT I A CAN KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE ONE OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL TOBACCO CONTROL
PROGRAMS IN THE WORLD AND IT'S
BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY SUCCESSFUL
AND REDUCING TOBACCO USE IN OUR
STATE AS WELL AS CHANGING NORMS
AROUND TOBACCO USE AND STATE.
SORRY I RAN INTO SEVERAL YOUNG
PEOPLE THEY BEGIN MY DISTRICT
OVER THE PAST. THIRTY DAYS AND
TOOK THE TIME TO KIND OF CHAT
WITH THEM ABOUT. WHAT THEY WERE
DOING AND WHAT PRODUCT THEY
WERE USING AND- FOR THINGS I
FROM KIND OF SHOCKING AND- AND
MAYBE SOMETHING WE COULD COME
TO EXPECT GIVEN THE PUBLICITY
AND THE PRESS REPORTING IN SOME
OF THE INFORMATION OUT THERE.
IS THAT THEY WERE ALL UNDER THE
IMPRESSION. THAT MARIJUANA
VAPING. WAS SAFE FROM THE
TOBACCO VAPING COULD KILL YOU.
I STILL THEY GOT THAT
IMPRESSION FROM THE NEWS
REPORTS OF SOME OF THE
INFORMATION PUT OUT THERE BY
ADVOCACY GROUPS AND OTHERS
COMICS CLOSELY FOCUSED ON
TOBACCO BUT IT SEEMS LIKE A
DANGER WHEN CLEARLY WE DON'T
QUITE KNOW WHAT'S CAUSING IT
AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH WARNINGS
TO. NOT PAY PERIOD UNTIL WE
HAVE A BETTER IDEA OR PERHAPS.
WE DON'T GET A BETTER IDEA
PEOPLE SHOULD BE BABY AT ALL.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY AN UNSAFE. OR
CRITICALLY UNSAFE PRODUCT BY IT
STRIKES ME THAT THAT'S A
DANGEROUS PUBLIC HEALTH
OUTCOME. WHEN YOU HAVE YOUNG
PEOPLE NOT INFORMED. ABOUT THE
REAL DANGERS WOULD YOU AGREE.
CORRECT YES AND AGAIN I AM I
GET I'M I'M NOT IN CHARGE OF
FUNDING DECISIONS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT- DO YOU WANT
TO THAT WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
TOBACCO CONTROL PROGRAM WHO
HAS. OBVIOUSLY WHEN WE TALK TO
YOUNG PEOPLE I WANT TO NOTE
THAT EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE SEEN
INCREASES AND BEEPING AMONG
YOUNG PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S LOWER THAN THE NATIONAL
LEVEL SO THE WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE. TO ADDRESS TOBACCO
CONTROL. AND WE ARE OUR MAKING
GOOD SUCCESSES BUT I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THE MARIJUANA
PREVENTION AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ASPECT OF THAT. MISTER COOPER.
IS FOR THE SECOND LAURIE OF
THAT PROMOTION A RIGHT TO THE
NONPROFIT RIGHT SO YOU GUYS GET
MONEY IN BLUE THE BIG ISSUE IS
I AGREE WITH WHAT MR GRAY SAID
OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
TOBACCO TAX REVENUE IS BROUGHT
IN BY THE STATE AND YET LESS
THAN 3% IS USED FOR ENFORCEMENT
SO WHY PUT YOURSELF ON THE BACK
PORCH BECAUSE IT DOES. IT'S A
DIFFERENT MODEL NOW THINGS HAVE
CHANGED WITH THE BABY SO A LOT
OF THAT MOVIE AND READING THE
INFORMATION HERE ABOUT SOME
PAPERWORK WERE MOST THAT WHEN
THEY GO TO THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES GOALS EDUCATION OR
TRAINING BUT NOT AND FOR SOME
THAT'S REALLY THE BIG ISSUE
WITH THAT IN THIS LEGISLATURE
WILL DO WITH THIS ISSUE BECAUSE
THE BLACK MARKET THEY'RE THERE
TO MAKE MONEY AND MAKE PROFITS
FOR THE PEOPLE AND THAT WILL
TALK ABOUT LATER ON BUT- WE'VE
GOT CHANGE THAT MODEL IT WITH
THIS WE ALSO HAVE A GIMMICK
THING THIS. BUT YET. TO PROCESS
SUFFICIENT UNDER THE AG. OKAY
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION THIS YEAR
FOR CITY PH IN THE OJ. BUT ONCE
AGAIN YOU KNOW AS FAR AS OLD
OPERATIONAL. OPERATIONS THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES. DOES NOT
GETTING DONE THAT MUCH. SO
THERE ARE A WHOLE HOST OF
ISSUES WITH THIS BUT I PUT THE
BLAME ON THE STATE FOR A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES THAT COME UP FOR A
LONG TIME. FOR IMMEDIATE ISSUES
BUT HOW DO YOU. I GUESS RECTIFY
THAT USING MORE MONEY SHOULD BE
GIVEN TOWARDS A FORCE MAKERS
THING THE RATES ARE LOW. BUT
NOW OBVIOUSLY IF THE KEEPING
WITH VAPING SO. IN MY OPINION
ON THE ENFORCEMENT IN MORE TO
BE ALLOCATED BECAUSE- OBVIOUSLY
THIS EDUCATION PART IS WORKING
WITH SO MUCH. IN THE TRAINING
WE WORKING SO MUCH BECAUSE- YOU
GO TO A- A BUNCH OPERATE
WITHOUT PASHA BUT A- GOOD. PET
SHOP WHERE YOU WANT TO CALL IT
BUT- THE BLACK MARKET IS OUT
THERE SO THESE KIDS CAN GO
ANYWHERE THE BLACK MARKET AND
GET IT. THEY'RE GONNA SELL SO
DO YOU FAVOR OR SUPPORT MORE
FUNDING FOR THE ENFORCEMENT. SO
I AM I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT AND
I CAN'T TAKE A POSITION ON IT
BUT I CAN'T SAY THAT I KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS HERE
AND THAT BILL SHARE THE WORK
THAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING WITH
THE GRANTS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
GIVEN OUT. THE GOOD THING
THAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
FUNDING FROM PROP FIFTY SIX
WITH THE COMBINATION OF FUNDING
FOR DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH.
THERE'S A LOT OF NEW
PARTNERSHIPS TO TRY TO BRING
ALLIES AND ENFORCEMENT. FROM
THE SCHOOLS AND THEN ALSO FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND COMMUNITY TOGETHER TO
IDENTIFY HOW TO COMBAT THAT BUT
I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON THE
ENFORCEMENT SIDE NOR CAN I
SPEAK TO THAT. WHAT THE END OF
THE DAY. THE ENFORCEMENT STILL
HAPPENS AND LOCAL LEVEL. A
COVER. FOR A LONG TIME. DOT
PASSES THE MONEY SOLDIER LOCAL
SHERIFFS AND POLICE
DEPARTMENTS. THAT DO ALL THESE
OPERATIONS SO. LIKE I SAID THE
FUNDING IS INADEQUATE AND HAS
BEEN FOR QUITE SOMETIME. THANK
YOU. IT MIGHT BE JUST THAT ALSO
IT DEPENDS ON THE SOCIAL NORM
OF THE WHOLE SOCIETY SO WE KNOW
THAT KIDS ARE NOT. ALWAYS JUST
GOING TO THE STORES TO BUY IT
THEY'RE GETTING IT. MAYBE FROM
THEIR PARENTS WERE AT LEAST
SOME OF THE- CONFISCATED
PRODUCTS HAVE BEEN. EVEN
AMONGST FRIENDS OR FAMILY SO.
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THE WHOLE
SOCIETY AND NOT JUST. TARGET
AND PUNISHED THE PEOPLE BUT
THINK ABOUT. THE WHOLE OF
SOCIETY AND ALSO THE HEALTH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH GOOD THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. IF MY BAG RESTING
THIRTY YEARS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IN THEIR THOUSANDS OF SHOPS IN
LA THEIR BLACK MARKET SHOPS. SO
IT'S RELATIVELY EASY FOR YOU A
YOUNG PERSON TO GO TO BLACK
MARKET SHOP. IN BY. LIKE THESE
COACHES PRISON CHINA BUT-
THEY'RE FILLED UP HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. BE A CANNABIS OR-
THE NICOTINE SO IT HAPPENS
HERE. IN THE GOOD OLD USA. SO
LIKE I SAID ISSUE IS YOU CAN'T
JUST BRING YOU HAD THE GROUND.
TO THOSE LISTA SHOPS THAT ARE
OUT THERE IN THE THOUSANDS. MR
MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF IT YOU KNOW THIS IS SO
OVERWHELMING ON EVEN KNOW WHERE
TO START FOR SO MANY PIECES AND
I APPRECIATE WELL FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU TO THE THREE CHAIRS
FOR BRING US TOGETHER ONE CAME
UP I THINK IT WAS LATE AUGUST
EARLY SEPTEMBER BEFORE WE SAW A
LOT OF THIS MOVEMENT SO.
CERTAINLY IS VERY TIMELY AND
THE ISSUES AND FRANKLY THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE RISING COME
BY THE BY THE DAY IF NOT BY THE
HOUR. I DO THINK THAT IS THE
OVER ARCHING TOPIC IS IMPORTANT
AS YOU SAID DR I THINK THAT'S
KIND OF HOW I SET UP THE
ARTICULATED VERY WISELY THAT
THIS THE YOUTH EPIDEMIC AND WE
SEE THE ROMANTICISM WITH THE
FLAVORS WHICH I'LL GET TO IN A
SECOND FOR THIS OTHER QUESTION
THAT THAT IS GREAT DOT IS THIS
WHOLE ISSUE THE ALL THE BABY IS
IT SAFE IN THE FIRST PLACE SB
PERMITTING AND I'M SO THERE'S I
KNOW THAT THERE'S LEGAL. MEANS
OF IT SOME SAY THE LEGAL PIECES
BUT HOW DO YOU DIFFERENTIATE
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS A REAL
QUESTION WE HAVE TO OFFER ASK
OURSELVES SO I WANT TO START
WITH THE FIRST AS FAR AS THE
OVER THE PRODUCT AS A WHOLE SAW
THAT YOUR GREAT POWER POINT IN
THE. IN THE DECLINE IN SMOKE
IT'S- CROSS. IN ONE OF. THE
DESERVE THE STREET THIS IS. AN
ALTERNATIVE. AND HAVE BEEN
THERE THEY HAVE SAID THAT IT'S
A SAFE ALTERNATIVE IN THE FDA
OF COURSE. CAME AT THEM AND
SAID YOU CAN'T SAY THAT. BUT
NOW MY UNDERSTANDING I JUST SAW
THIS ADVERTISEMENT CAME UP ON.
SOMEONE'S EMAIL YESTERDAY AND
THEY SAID TO ME AND IT SAYS
IT'S A SATISFYING. ALTERNATIVE
SO I GUESS THEY'RE CHANGING
THEIR LANGUAGE IT'S NOT A- SAFE
ALTERNATIVE TO SATISFYING I
GUESS THAT'S NECESSARY. ILLEGAL
SO. AS FAR AS THE ALTERNATIVE
WHAT WHAT IS THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
WORLD SAY ABOUT THAT IS FAR AS
HELL TO RICHARD TO STANDARD.
TOBACCO SMOKE YES RIGHT SO I
THINK THAT'S FIVE UNDERSCORING
WHAT THE CDC. HAS EMPHASIZED
THERE'S NO STATE TOBACCO
PRODUCT AND RELEARNING. ABOUT
THE WHAT RANGE OF HEALTH EXCEPT
TO SEE AS WELL. WHAT I TELL MY
PATIENTS IS. YOUR PLANS ARE
MEANT TO BE CLEAN AIR AND SO
MICHAEL AS A PROVIDER WILL BE
TO HELP YOU QUIT FOR GOOD. SO
IT AS AN ALTERNATIVE I WOULD
PROBABLY SAY LET'S TRY TO GET
YOU TO ZERO. AND HAVE CLEAN
LINES. YES IT'S SOMEWHAT
SIMILAR TO YEARS AGO THEY CAME
OUT WITH FILTERS THEY SAID
FILTERED CIGARETTES ARE SAFER
AND POTENTIALLY MARGINALLY
SAFER BUT BUT ARE THEY SAFE SO
MY NURSING WHEN THEY FIRST CAME
OUT WITH. THE PATCHES AND THE
GUM THERE WERE THERE WERE
PRESCRIPTIONS TO GET THEM YOU
CAN MY OVER THE COUNTER. HAS
THAT EVER BEEN THAT TALKED
ABOUT AS HAVING IF THERE IF
THERE IS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
HAVING IT. UTILIZED BY.
MEDICINE LIKE THANK YOU. RIGHT
PHARMACY AS OPPOSED TO. HIS
LITTLE SHOPS THAT WE SEE AROUND
TOWN RIGHT SO HOW TO QUIT
ESPECIALLY WHEN NICOTINE IS SO
ADDICTIVE THESE MEDICATIONS
THOSE FIVE NICOTINE.
REPLACEMENT MEDICATIONS ARE
MEANT TO HELP PEOPLE WITH ALL
SYMPTOMS IS WHICH ARE SPECIALLY
WORSE IN THE FIRST COUPLE WEEKS
ANXIETY IRRITABILITY. YOU KNOW
I'VE SEEN PEOPLE WANT TO LEAVE
THE HOSPITAL AGAINST MEDICAL
ADVICE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GO
OUT FOR A CIGARETTE BUT- THAT
IT CAN REALLY LEAD TO A LOT OF
AGITATION SO THOSE MEDICATIONS
ARE MEANT OVER TWO TO THREE.
MONTHS TO HELP YOU ON HELP YOUR
BRAIN LEARN THE NICOTINE
ADDICTION AND TO LEARN NEW
BEHAVIORS TO REPLACE THE
PRODUCT THAT YOU WERE USING. SO
YOU KNOW I'VE HEARD IN THE NEWS
MEDIA WELL MAYBE PEOPLE TRYING
TO QUIT PEIPING SHOULD GO BACK
TO CIGARETTES NOTE WE HAVE
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE TIME
TESTED. UT WHAT WE'RE FACING
HERE IS A NEW HIGH POTENCY
NICOTINE THAT EVEN. BETTER I
DON'T EVEN QUITE HOW DOES
PEOPLE I CAN ONLY JUST HOPE TO
TRY TO TIE TRIP. TO THEIR NEEDS
AND TOLD THEIR OWN SYMPTOMS ARE
ABATED. OKAY AND THEN. TO THE
PEACE AND ARE YOU TALKED ABOUT
THIS KIMBERLY SO. IT'S AB ICING
IS A IS A BIG BED AND LITERALLY
LAST NIGHT WAS DRIVING THROUGH
MY DISTRICT AND WE SEE THE
SHOPS ALL OVER THERE. AND WE
KNOW THAT THEY THERE IS THE
YOUTH ELEMENT WITH THE FLAVOR.
HAVE YOU SEEN THE REPORT SAID
LGBT COMMUNITY IS HAVE HIGHER
NUMBERS FOR THIS LITTLE I SAW
SHOP WITH. THE WITH THE PRIDE
COLORS I'M SURE YOU CAN SEE IT.
IT'S A BLUEBERRY VAPE SHOP.
VERY VAGUE AND SMOKE ON WHAT
HAPPENED. AND JUST UNBELIEVABLE
THAT'S EXACTLY HAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE POPULATION
AND IT'S TARGETING. THE
COMMUNITY COME TO COME RIGHT IN
KNOWING THAT THERE'S THIS
ROMANTICISM I KNOW THAT I HAVE.
ELEVEN YEAR OLD GIRLS AND
THEY'RE SELLING GIRL SCOUT
COOKIES RIGHT OVER HERE IT'S A
FLAT. AND ONE OF MY DAUGHTERS
SAW SOMEBODY COMING OUT IN
VAPING THE SENTIMENTS LIKE DAY
THAT THAT. DILUTES IT SMELLS
REALLY GOOD IT SMELLS LIKE IT
TASTES REALLY GOOD TOO. ELEVEN
YEAR OLD. YES SO YOU KNOW THESE
KIDS HAVE EVERYTHING AROUND
THEM THE STATE SCHOOL THAT THEY
HAVE THE ADVERTISING IN CELL
THIS IS A CRAZY CRAZY EPIDEMIC
AND IT'S COMING FROM ALL
DIFFERENT ANGLES AND YOU KNOW
IT'S PART OF ITS OF COMING UPON
US TO REALLY ACT AND I KNOW
THERE'S NO ONE SOLUTION. I GET
THAT IS NOT ONE BILL ONE THING
I KNOW TALK ABOUT LESTER'S OF A
PACKAGE OF THINGS ON THE MENU
TO DO TO TACKLE THIS AND I
THINK THAT THE WORK WE WERE
DOING THIS TODAY THE
CONVERSATION HOPEFULLY GET BE
PUSHING SOME POLICY IN THE NEAR
FUTURE CITIES ARE STEPPING UP
AND DOING IT TOO BUT- I DON'T
THINK THAT ONE. FLAVOR BANNER
POLICY IS GOING TO YOU KNOW.
EVEN IF YOU GO AFTER THE SHOPS
AND MISTER GRAY AND I HAD SOME
AMAZING. EXHORTATIONS THIS PAST
YEAR TALKING ABOUT THE SHOPS
THAT ARE GETTING SICK THE
STINGS IT'S NOT THE GROCERY
STORES IT'S THE LITTLE MON POSH
SHOPS AND THEY'RE THE ONES ARE
HAVING THE HUGE HUGE NUMBERS
AND SO HAVING MORE ENFORCEMENT
THERE LIKE MISTER COOPER SO I
THINK IS PART OF THE SOLUTION.
BUT EVEN IF WE SHUT DOWN THAT
YOU KNOW KIDS ARE SMART. THEY
FIGURE OUT MOM'S HOUSE WHERE TO
AMAZON AND BUY STUFF ONLINE AND
SO IT'S GONNA TAKE A MULTITUDE
OF WAYS TO GO AFTER THIS SO AT
THE LAST TOPIC I WANTED
DISCUSSES. I UNDERSTAND THAT
IT'S A NEW WANTS TO ISSUE WITH
THAT WITH THE NON TOBACCO.
VAPING AND FIRST ONE EVEN KNOW
HOW MANY. IF THERE IS IT IS IT
PREVALENT FOR THAT CANNABIS
VAPING AND FLAVORS. DO DO WE
KNOW THAT. SO I TRIED TO GET
DATA ON THE BEEPING
SPECIFICALLY I HAVE TEACH SEE
AND FLAVOR TEACH SEE AND I DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT THAT EXISTS.
OKAY SO IF IT HAS MISTER GRACE
SUGGEST IF WE DID HAVE A ACROSS
THE BOARD NO FLAVOR FOR TOBACCO
AND CANNABIS REALLY KNOW HOW
MUCH THAT WOULD IMPACT THAT.
CANNABIS VAPING PRODUCTS.
POTENTIALLY IT'S YET CORRECT MY
EXPERTISE IS NOT IN TEACH
SEASIDE SO I'M NOT AWARE OF
WHAT PERCENT OF VAPING DEVICES
ARE SOLD IN FLAVORS AND WHAT
PERCENT OF YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
BEEPING FLAVORED WAX PENS OKAY
WORD PEACHY DEVICES AND IN THE
LAST ISSUE IN THIS THE QUESTION
WHICH I THINK IS THE QUESTION
WE'RE ASKING ABOUT THE ILLNESS
IS AND IT'S MAINLY FROM. THE
THC PRODUCTS AND THE INDUSTRY
SAYING HEY THAT'S NOT OUR
PRODUCT THAT'S THE ILLEGAL
BLACK MARKET PRODUCT IS COMING
OVER AND THEY'RE NOT HAVING THE
SAME METALS IN THERE THAT WE
HAVE BEEN TESTED AND SO FOR I
DON'T KNOW THE SCIENCE. I MAY
BE MESSING THAT UP. BUT I WOULD
ASSUME THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE. WHO
USE THIS PRODUCT THEY USE IT
ALL RIGHT THEY DON'T THEY'RE
NOT. THEY DON'T TO JUST DO ONE
OR THE OTHER SO IT'S HARD TO
TELL WHICH ONE. WAS THE CULPRIT.
AND SO IS THERE A WAY TO HAVE
AND- THEY FONG NUANCED WAY FOR
THE CANNABIS PRODUCTS. AND GO
AFTER. THE DEVICES THAT ARE
REALLY CAUSING HARM CAN WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. IT ALMOST
GETTING AT YES BUT I THINK
THAT'S WHY THE CDC HAS COME OUT
SAYING OUT OF ALL THE FIVE
HUNDRED AND SO. THINGS THEY
COULD GET FROM THE CASES THAT
WERE SICK. AND THEY COULDN'T
FIND ONE SUBSTANCE OR ONE
PRODUCT TO. CALL UPON THAT'S
WHY THEY'RE STILL MAKING THAT
VERY STRONG STATEMENT EVERYONE
PLEASE JUST STOP THE DENTAL
WILL TRY TO FIGURE THIS OUT. I
DON'T THINK WE REALLY KNOW AND
I. SO FAR THERE'S NO SUGGEST TO
SAY AS A SAFE DEVICE. OR WAY OF
VAPING OR WHAT CHEMICAL SO THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY IS WITH THE
CDC AND SAME. WITH THE ALL THE
QUESTIONS AND NOT ENOUGH
ANSWERS WE SHOULD JUST DO IT
TIME OUT ON ALL THE STUFF. I
THINK THAT WOULD BE. THE SAME
THING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH. AND IT
IS THEIR ONGOING RESEARCH THAT
THE LABELS YOU TO SEE IF THEY-
THEIR DEVICES THAT ARE. LEGALLY
SOLD. DO YOU HAVE SOME SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS IN THEM. THAT SO
THIS IS WHERE THE FTA
REGULATION IS SUPPOSED TO COME
INTO PLAY WHERE THE
MANUFACTURERS ARE SUPPOSED TO
SUBMIT. INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
PRODUCTS AND THE EFFECT ON
HEALTH. SO THAT'S WHY THAT
DEADLINE THAT MORATORIUM IS
NOW. BEING UP TO NEXT YEAR OKAY
THANK YOU AND I KNOW OUR LATER
PANEL HAS. THE COUNCIL THAT
POTENTIALLY THESE ISSUES WILL
BE ADDRESSED. THANK YOU THE
KINGS CHAIR THANK YOU SO WE
HAVE MISTER MISS LOAN MISTER
LOW AND THEN MISTER COOPER
AGAIN. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION I THINK FOR ME
I FIRST STARTED THINKING ABOUT
THIS IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
TWELVE WHEN I WAS A SCHOOL
BOARD AND WE DID NOT KNOW IF
OUR TOBACCO POLICY FOR STUDENT
CONDUCT ACTUALLY COVERED
MEETING IT WAS VERY CONFUSING
THEN WE DIDN'T KNOW IF THE LAW.
ALLOWED FOR THAT AND I THINK
SINCE THEN THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE EVOLVED IN THE THINKING
AND I KNOW SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE TOUCHED UPON.
ISSUES OF ENFORCEMENT OR IMPACT.
ONE OF THE CITY I HEARD IN THIS
PRESENTATION REPEAT. THE LACK
OF UNDERSTANDING AND EDUCATION
WHICH I FIND TO BE ONE OF THE
HARDER THINGS TO DO TO EDUCATE
THE PUBLIC. AND SO I JUST
WONDERED IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO
WHAT YOU'RE SEEN IN TERMS OF
BEST PRACTICES EDUCATING. THE
USE WORK OUR PUBLIC ABOUT THIS
CERTAINLY THERE HAVE BEEN
ARTICLES. CLEARLY THE ARTICLES
HAVE NOT HAD AN IMPACT ON NO
MASS NUMBER OF MINERS. I
DECREASING THEIR USE AT LEAST
NOT WITH THE DAY THAT YOU
PRESENTED SO WHAT ARE THE BEST
PRACTICES WHAT WHAT IS
CALIFORNIA DOING WELL TO TRY TO
EDUCATE MINORS. AND ADULTS
ABOUT THE IMPACT. THANK
QUESTION AGAIN REFER BACK TO
THE TRACK CONTROL PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA SO THE FOR THE FOCUS
OF THAT PROGRAM PROGRAM IS TO
DE NORMALIZE THE USE OF TOBACCO
CONTROL AND PART OF THAT IS BY
ENGAGING COMMUNITIES TO CHANGE
THE NORMS OF. ACCESS TO TOBACCO
THE EXPOSURE TO THE ADVERTISING
AND MARKETING TO VARIOUS
TOBACCO PRODUCTS AND RETAIL
ENVIRONMENTS I'M ALSO THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK HAPPENING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO CHANGE THE
NUMBER THE DENSITY OF RETAILERS
AND COMMUNITIES THE LOCATION OF
THOSE RETAILERS AND MOVING THEM
AWAY FROM SCHOOLS SO THAT'S
PART OF IT THE SECOND SIDE IS
TO DO THE MEDIA CAMPAIGN. AND
TO TRY TO ENGAGE. AND WHAT'S
ANYA. AROUND NOT JUST THE
DANGERS OF THE PRODUCTS BUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITHIN
COMMUNITIES AND TOBACCO
INDUSTRY TACTICS AND SO THAT
WORK IS CONTINUING. SO THAT'S
JUST A SIDE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH PASSED. THE
PART OF EDUCATION WHO'S ALSO
PARTNER IN THIS WORK THEN DOES
THE SCHOOL WORK SPECIFICALLY
AND SO THERE FUNDING THROUGH
THEIR TOBACCO USE PREVENTION
EDUCATION PROGRAM. BINGO
OPPOSED TO TRY TO TRAIN
TEACHERS. AND EDUCATE PARENTS
AND ADMINISTRATORS ON THE
PROBLEM OF THESE PRODUCTS WHAT
HI THIS OFF GUARD WAS HOW
QUICKLY IS PRESS ROOM. AND AS
ASSEMBLY FOR GREAT DEAD THAT
OFTENTIMES WE GO. TO SCHOOLS
AND WE ASK WHAT PRODUCT YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE USING. I'VE I
REMEMBER I WAS ACTUALLY AND I'M
MADERA COUNTY AND TALK TO SOME.
WORKING WITH HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND LEARN THE ALL OF
THE PRODUCTS THEY CONFISCATED
WERE WAX PEN AND I WAS
SURPRISED BY THAT BUT WHEN WE
TALK TO STUDENTS WE FIND OUT
THAT THEY ARE CONSTANTLY TRYING
TO BE AHEAD OF THE GAME SO WHEN
WE FOCUS JUST ON JUL. PARENTS
KNOW WHAT TOOLS ARE SO THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR JEWEL AND SO THEN
KIDS GO TO SOARING OR THEY GO
TO NOVA OR ANY OF THE OTHER NEW
PRODUCTS AND SO IS TRYING TO
GET THE BIGGER PICTURE NOT JUST
FOCUS ON A PRODUCT BUT TRYING
TO CREATE HEALTHIER COMMUNITIES
BY. REMOVING PRODUCTS AND THEN
BY HAVING MEDIA CAN. TO MAKE
PEOPLE. AS WAS ALSO NOTED A LOT
OF THE COMPREHENSIVE POLICIES
AT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
CREATING NOT SO MUCH ON THE
SALES ON THE USE OF THESE
PRODUCTS. I KNOW THAT THE
MAJORITY OF OUR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATES
HAVE. COMPREHENSIVE POLICIES
THAT COVER THE INHALATION OR
YOU HAVE ANY COMBUSTIBLE OR V.
BRACE PRODUCT ON THEIR CAMPUS.
AND THE IDEA THAT IF WE CAN
REMOVE THE DISRUPTING VISIBLE
THAT CHANGE THE NORM THEN THAT
WILL THEN. CHANGE PEOPLE'S USE
BECAUSE IT'S NOT WANTS TO USE
THAT. IT'S A REALLY
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM THAT
COMMUNITIES ARE WORKING ON
COMMITTEE COLLECTIONS ARE. THE
STATE. DEPARTMENT PUBLIC OF HAS
A REALLY ROBUST VERY SICK.
IMMEDIATE AND THEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS
WORKING WITH IN SCHOOLS TO TRY
TO DRAW FROM APPROACH. BOB
PARENTS TO MAKE THEM AWARE OF
THESE AND THEN REALLY HELPING
TO A QUICK STOP TO EQUIP
TRUSTED ADULTS TO BE ABLE TO
ASK THE QUESTION ABOUT USE TO
ADVISED ENCOURAGE QUITE A TIMES
AND THEN TO REFER THEM TO
SERVICES THAT CAN HELP THEM
QUIT. IT'S CLEAR YOU SOUNDS IT
IS NO DOUBT THAT IT'S COPPER.
MY CONCERN IS THAT DESPITE HOW
COMPREHENSIVE IT IS THE PROBLEM.
IN THE POTENTIAL SOLUTION AND
SO I'M JUST WONDERING IF OUR
DEFINITION OR UNDERSTANDING OF
COMPREHENSIVE IS GOING TO HAVE
TO ADAPT TO A PROBLEM THAT THE
VAULT I'M NOT A VERY FAST TO
AND DEEP WAY AND I THINK I'M
TRYING TO GRAPPLE. WITH THAT SO
I APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK. MAY
I ADD THAT THE DOCTORS NEED TO
BE EDUCATED AS WELL. WE DO IT
WE DON'T KNOW HOW TO ASK AND
TREAT THESE THINGS AND THE WHAT
THE KIDS ARE DOING WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW THAT THEY'RE THE SAME
PARENTS. OR THE PROVIDERS WHO
ARE TRYING TO KEEP. MAY NOT
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THIS PROBLEM
IS OUT THERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IN THE GARAGE DOCTOR
TALKING IT CAN REALLY FOR
PRESENTATION I WILL ADMIT TO
THAT YOUR PRESENTATION SCARE
THE CRAP OUT OF ME. BECAUSE WE
HAVE DONE IS SUCH HARD WORK IN
TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS NOW. SEEMS TO BE
COMING RIGHT BACK AGAIN AND SO
THE SENSE OF URGENCY IS VERY
REAL BUT I WANT TO MAKE PERHAPS
CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
SLIDE THAT YOU PROVIDED TO US
WITH RESPECT TO ONE THIRD OF
TO. SHOPS AND VAPE SHOP SOLD
HIM IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN. YOUR GRAPHIC HERE
ABOUT 34% OF USAGE COMES FROM
TOBACCO AND BABY. A BIG SHALL
SPECIFICALLY SO THAT OF ONE
THIRD GOING TO THAT OF MINORS.
WE HEARD EARLIER ABOUT THAT OF
LOCALS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
THE CHALLENGES OF LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES TRYING TO TACKLE
THIS ISSUES OF BANDS OUT RIGHT.
AND OFTENTIMES AT THE STATE
LEVEL WE BATTLE ON. THAT OF
LOCAL CAN OVER THIS A MILLION.
THAT THE LOCALS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY CONTROL. AS I'VE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO MEET OF
WHEN WE'RE NOW AT A SESSION
WITH LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
BOARD MEMBERS THIS IS THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE THAT THEY ARE
HEARING AND SEEING ABOUT THAT
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO TACKLE
THIS AND THEY'RE ASKING
SPECIFICALLY FOR ADDITIONAL
HELP OFTEN THE STATE TO ATTACK
THIS DO YOU HAVE ANY AGAINST
INSIGHTS WITH RESPECT TO THAT
OF LOCALS AND THE ROLE OF STATE
VERSUS LOCAL AND AGAIN. SEEING
THAT THE LACK OF ENFORCEMENT
SPECIFICALLY GOING TO SELLING
TO MINORS OF ONE THIRD GOING TO
TOBACCO STORES DO YOU HAVE ANY
SENSE ON THE OBSERVATIONS OR
MECHANISMS TO YOUR HEARING AS
YOU ARE ENGAGING TALKING TO
THOSE MOST IMPACTED. THEIR
NUMBER JURISDICTIONS ARE
STRONGER TUCKER RETAIL
INSTANCES MANY DON'T HAVE
RETAIL LICENSES RIGHT NOW AND
ARE LOOKING AT ADOPTING THEM
WITH STRONGER FEES ASSOCIATED
STRONGER PASSED TO YOU AND THEN
ALSO THE INCLUSION OF FLAVOR
BANDS. THAT THE PHONE FLAVOR
VAN IS BECAUSE I KNOW THAT.
PEOPLE ARE IN THIS BACK TO YOU
SPEAK HAS THE PROPER. THEY SEEM
LESS WELL AS SALT. THOSE
PRODUCTS IT'S ELIMINATING
PRODUCTS THAT ARE ATTRACTING
USED TO PURCHASE. YOUR BY THE
BED TO IT AS WELL SOURCE IN THE
TRANS A GIVEN YOUR PRESENTATION
THERE ARE THAT THAT'S A
RELATIVELY SMALL SEGMENT OF
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES THAT HAVE
ACTUALLY TAKEN ACTION. AND YET
THE IMPACTED POPULATIONS SINGS.
IT IS TO USE ALSO SHOWN THE
PERCENTAGE CONTINUES TO RISE
BUT AGAIN I THINK IT MAY BE DO
YOU HAVE ANY INSIGHTS WITH
RESPECT TO DO YOU BELIEVE THAT.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
ACTUALLY DOING WHAT THEY CAN
AND SHOULD BE DOING TO TRY TO
TACKLE THIS ISSUE IS GIVEN THE
RATES AND THEN ALSO GIVEN THE
STATISTICS OF THAT OF
ENFORCEMENT GOING TO MINORS
BECAUSE AGAIN LOCAL CITY HERE
ALL THE TIME THE CONTROL BUT
THEY'RE CLEARLY NOT AGAINST ALL
IF. OF THE MIND MINERS ARE
BEING SOLD THESE PRODUCTS. I
THINK THAT SOME JURISDICTIONS
IN THE STATE HAVE A STRONGER
HISTORY OF ADOPTING STRONG
TOBACCO CONTROL ORDINANCES AND
WE SEE THAT WITH THOSE
JURISDICTIONS HAVING POLICIES
IN PLACE NOW. I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK BEING
DONE THROUGHOUT THE STATE BUT I
KNOW THAT THEIR REGIONS WHERE
IT MAY NOT BE HAPPENING. SURE
DID YOU OFF THE TOP HER HEAD
YOU TO JUST REFERENCE THAT
NUMBER OF JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE COMPREHENSIVE POLICIES
THAT MAYBE HE'S- DOING BETTER
WITH RESPECT TO THAT OF
ENFORCEMENT AND SOME HIS BOSS
ALREADY. I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT
AND FORCE MEANT PIECE BUT I
KNOW THAT. SPECIFICALLY THE BAY
AREA HAS BEEN THE CHAMPION. FOR
FLAVORED ORDINANCE I WE KNOW
THAT LOS ANGELES HAS RECENTLY
THERE COUNTY HAS RECENTLY HAD
AN ORDINANCE THE CITY IS
LOOKING AT AN ORDINANCE. THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO'S WHICH JUST
WENT INTO EFFECT. SO DEFINITELY
MORE OF THE URBAN COMMUNITIES
HAVE ORDINANCES THAT ARE.
ALREADY ADOPTED OR CLOSER TO
ADOPTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER COOPER. A FOLLOW UP TO
DISCLOSE QUESTIONS ORDINANCES
THEY HAPPEN IN PLACE BUT YOU
WALK AROUND DOWNTOWN OUTSIDE
PEOPLE STILL VAPING BE AT
SACRAMENTO LA OR SAN FRANCISCO
BUT ONLY BACK TO DOCTOR CDCS TO
TAKE A BREAK FROM VAPING AND
THAT'S JUST UNREALISTIC I THINK
WHEN PEOPLE ARE INVOLVED IN
ADDICTION BE IT TOBACCO ALCOHOL
THE C. DRUGS. IT IS TOUGH TO
KEEP NO MATTER WHAT. SO WE'VE
GOT A WHOLE GROUP OF PEOPLE.
OUT THERE AND I THINK IT'S
UNREALISTIC TO DO THAT MAYBE
TEN YEARS FROM NOW WHATEVER WE
FIND OUT WE MORE INFORMATION ON
THIS I DON'T KNOW THERE'S NO
TIME LINE REALLY AND I'M SURE
IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN ANYTIME
SOON. SO BEING REALISTIC.
THEY'RE NOT TAKING A BREAK. I
GUESS THAT'S THE DOCTOR. VAPING
IF IT'S I GUESS IF IT'S NOT
FROM THE BLACK MARKET IS STILL
SAFER THAN SMOKING TOBACCO THEN.
SO I THINK THIS IS WHERE THE
FTA REGULATION AS OF THE
CIGARETTES IS STILL NOT THERE
AND- THIS IS FOR THE
MANUFACTURERS TO SUBMIT
INFORMATION ABOUT HEALTH SO I
DON'T THINK WE CAN EVEN MAKE
THAT STATEMENT THAT IT'S A SAFE
AND IT RIGHT NOW THE CITY
SAYING THERE IS NO. SAFE
TOBACCO PRODUCT. WE KNOW THAT
THEIR INHALING THESE CHEMICALS
WITH VAPING CAN HAVE IMMEDIATE
HEALTH EFFECTS SO. AS THE
SURGEON GENERAL HAS NOTED YOU
KNOW EVEN FOR NON USERS
SECONDHAND AEROSOL HAS HARMFUL
CONSTITUENTS. SO I THINK WHAT
WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW IS MAYBE
WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO IS.
DOES MAYBE HAVING LESS
CARCINOGEN AND SOME OF THESE
PRODUCTS MAYBE DOES THAT MEAN
LESS HARM AND I THINK THAT'S
WHY I'M TRYING TO. ALSO SHOW OF
THIS IS MAYBE WHAT WAS FOR LOW
TOP BEFORE BUT IT. SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE TO KEEP COMING EVERY
DAY. THE MEDIA BIOLOGICAL
EFFECTS AND IT'LL TAKE A FEW
YEARS TO GET EPIDEMIOLOGY DATA
SO I THINK THAT'S WHERE A LOT
OF THE PUBLIC CONFUSION IS
WHERE THEY THINK THESE ARE
NEWER SAFER CLEANER PRODUCTS
THEY DON'T MAKE YOU SMELL IT
MIGHT MUST BE BETTER BUT I
THINK WE ARE NOW. FINDING OUT.
THERE IS STILL A LOT OF. ON THE
SCIENCE SO FAR THE SIGNS THIS.
THIS IS NOT A SAFE PRODUCT SO
FOR SOME THE PREVIOUS VAPING
PENS FROM NICOTINE PART THAT
ONE THREE FTA THEY WERE
APPROVED BY THE FDA AND TESTED.
THE NEVER WHAT WHAT WHAT ARE
THE MANUFACTURE SUBMITTED TO
THE FDA RIGHT SO I THINK AND
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AT THE
DEEMING RULED BY THE FDA IS
THAT IT HAS A FORTY. TO
REGULATE E. CIGARETTES BUT
RIGHT NOW WHATEVER'S ON THE
LABEL IT'S NOT REGULATED BUT
THAT HASN'T BEEN IMPLEMENTED
YET SO THAT'S WHY THEY STARTED
TRYING TO MOVE UP THAT
MORATORIUM TO SAY START
SUBMITTING IT'S ACTUALLY IN
THESE THINGS THE FDA DOES FUND
WHAT'S CALLED TO COURT THESE
TOBACCO CENTERS OF REGULATORY
AND SEVEN PRODUCING SOME OF
THIS. SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE AND
IT NEEDS TO BE COMPILED AND
THEY'RE ALSO INFORMING THE FTA
ABOUT THESE PRODUCTS AS WELL SO.
IT'S STILL EARLY STAGES TO SAY
THAT THESE THAT WE EVEN KNOW
WHAT'S IN THESE PRODUCTS AND
THE EFFECTS ON HUMAN HEALTH SO
THE MEDIA'S BEEN ALL OVER THIS
NAY FAMILIAR EGGS. A LOT OF
TEST SAMPLES FOR TESTING AND
FROM WHAT I'VE- SEEN. IN THE
MEDIA. OTHER TESTS OF THAT CAME
BACK. WERE FROM THE ILLICIT
MARKET. BE IT TOBACCO OR
CANNABIS. IN NOT THE GYM IT
MANUFACTURES. SO AS IN WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THIS I MEAN A LOT OF IT
COMES FROM. EARLIER YOU GUYS
TALKED ABOUT THE BRICK AND
MORTAR IT'S LIKE SEVENTY FOUR
PERCENT. A LOT OF IT COMES FROM
THE ILLICIT MARKET SO. HEY IT
IT SEEMS TO ME IN JUST AS A
LEYVA IN THAT THAT IS A BIG
ISSUE WITH IT WHERE A LOT OF
THESE PRODUCTS DO COME FROM. NO
DOUBT THAT SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE REGULATED AND YOU KNOW AS
YOU'RE MENTIONING YOU KNOW WE
NEED. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
ALSO HELP WITH THIS BUT AS- YOU
KNOW I THINK. IT'S VERY
CHALLENGING BECAUSE THE
PRODUCTS THAT THE CDC
INVESTIGATION HAS THEN IT'S NOT
EVEN ALL OF THE CASES THAT
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET THE
PRODUCTS AND TEST SO THEY DON'T
KNOW AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
CONCLUDE IS RIGHT NOW THERE IS
NO SINGLE PRODUCT OR SUBSTANCE.
AT THE SAME TIME THEY'RE SAYING
PLEASE ASK SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHERE PEOPLE
GETTING IT HOW ARE THEY USING
IT WHAT ARE THEY FILLING IT UP
WITH AND THEY'RE ASKING DOCTORS
TO ASK THESE QUESTIONS TO HELP
IT OUT. WE DON'T KNOW. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE. I'D LIKE TO
GO AHEAD OF ALL OF THE LAST
YEAH. SO MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
INSPIRED SOME ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FOR YOU. WHAT IS IT
YOU KNOW THE DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION THE DIALOGUE IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE IN CALIFORNIA
THIS YEAR. WAS PREDOMINANTLY ON
ONE HAND FOLKS THAT WANTED TO
FOCUS. ON THE MORATORIUM FOR
THE BANNING OF FLAVORED. HE
SAID PRODUCTS. AND THE OTHER.
BLESSED AFTER WE HAD WAS TO
FOCUS MORE ON THE OVERSIGHT
REGULATION TAXATION OF THE SIX
AS WE DO IN TO PATRICIA TRACK.
I WAS INVOLVED IS ONE OF THE
AUTHORS ON THE OVERSIGHT
REGULATORY APPROACH AND THE
INSPIRATION FOR THAT WAS
FRANKLY ATTRITIONAL TRACK RIGHT
WE'VE SEEN INTEREST MICHAEL
EDUCATION OVERSIGHT REGULATION
TAXATION HAS BEEN A SUCCESSFUL.
RECIPE TO REDUCE CONSUMPTION
WITH YOUTH AND THE GENERAL
PUBLIC RIGHT. AND SOMETIMES WE
DON'T NEED TO BE SMARTER THAN
OURSELVES UP HERE BUT RATHER
LOOK AT AFFECTED PRACTICES IN
THE REPLICATION THIS IS SO. AT
ONE POINT WE HAD A BILL BEFORE
LEGISLATURE THAT OF THE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND REPORTED. TOBACCO
FLAVORS EASTICK FLAVORS THAT
WERE OUT THERE WOULD HAVE
RESTRICTED THE SALE FOURTEEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED NINETY
SEVEN AMONG CONSISTENT WITH
TRADITIONAL TRACK WHERE YOU
HAVE MEANT ALL INTERNATIONAL
TOBACCO FLAVORS AVAILABLE BUT
NOT. SOME OF THESE FLAVORS THAT
WE DISCUSSED EARLIER. AND. THE
COMMITTEE THAT I SERVE ON THE
REGULATORY TRACK OF ALCOHOL AS
WELL AND I WOULD POINT TO
PROHIBITION IN THE EARLY PART
OF THE LAST CENTURY AS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHERE MORE TRAINS
BANDS. AREN'T ACTUALLY ALWAYS
EFFECTIVE IN FACT SOMETIMES
THEY SERVE TO EXASPERATED BLACK
MARKET. AND NOW IS WERE FACED
WITH REAL HEALTH CONCERNS THAT
ALL EVIDENCE THUS FAR SEEMS TO
POINT TO BLACK MARKET PRODUCTS.
I HAVEN'T SEEN I HAVEN'T READ A
LOT THAT SUGGESTS THE LEGAL THC
AND OR TOBACCO PRODUCTS WERE
COSTS THAT THEY MAY BE AND
OTHERS A LOT YET TO LEARN. BUT
WE CERTAINLY KNOW THAT SOME OF
THESE BLACK MARKET PRODUCTS
HAVE CAUSED SOME DAMAGE. SO. DO
YOU AGREE OR DO YOU NOT AGREE
BASED ON YOUR WORK. THAT
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT EDUCATION
TAXATION WOULDN'T BE A GOOD
DIRECTION TO GO FOR. THE SIX
JUST AS WE'VE DONE WITH
TRADITION TOBACCO OR DO YOU
SHARE THE VIEW. THAT WE ARE YOU
SOMETHING ENTIRELY DIFFERENT DO
MORE OF A PROHIBITION STYLE A
BAN ON PRODUCTS. THE SPORT.
THAT WAS. JUST THAT WAS A
SOFTBALL QUESTION BECAUSE YOU
WERE. I CAN WRITE. WELL I THINK
THIS IS A PERSONALLY AND I'M
JUST SPEAKING FOR MYSELF I MEAN
I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING I
MEAN PEIPING IS SO NEW ALL
THESE HEALTH EFFECTS AND HEALTH
HARMS ARE JUST GROWING WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT EVERY SINGLE OPTION
I MEAN FOR SURE. TO CONTROL AT
WHATEVER WE CAN IS MOST
IMPORTANT. I THINK WE'RE
LEARNING EVEN. TWO ONE BUT- YOU
KNOW AS A PROVIDER THE OPIATE
EPIDEMIC IS VERY MUCH ON ALL OF
OUR MINDS AND THIS IS SOMETHING
WE ARE TASKED VERY HEAVILY TO
DO. AND THAT WAS UNDER A
MEDICAL MODEL AND NOT A MARKET
MODEL. SO EVEN THAT YOU KNOW WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE ADDICTION
IS A VERY CHALLENGING THING
THAT PEOPLE GET FROM MANY
DIFFERENT SOURCES AND A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH IS VERY
MUCH NEEDED. AND I WOULD SAY
THE SAME. IN REGARDS TO. THE
TYPE OF WORK THAT'S BEING DONE
AND WE KNOW AND WE LOOK BACK TO
TWO THOUSAND NINE WE KNOW THAT
WHEN WE REMOVE FLAVORS FROM
CIGARETTES. HEARING CALIFORNIA
EVERY POPULATION HOW TO
DECREASE IN CIGARETTE
CONSUMPTION WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS WHO HAVE
THE HIGHEST RATES OF MONTHLY
DID USE. SO WE KNOW THAT THERE
IS A POSITIVE IMPACT BY
REMOVING THOSE FLAVORED
PRODUCTS. AND SO I CAN ONLY BE
ASSUMES THAT WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE TWO DIFFERENT ISSUES AND I
AGREE WITH DOCTOR WOULD THAT WE
HAVE AN ISSUE HAVE YOU FACING.
AND I INCREASING AND THEN WE
HAVE THE ISSUE OF THE
ILLNESSES. BUT LOOKING
SPECIFICALLY AT THE U. FACING
SIDE THAT. REMOVING YOU
FRIENDLY PRODUCTS AND FLAVORED
PRODUCTS FROM THE MARKET. WHAT
HAPPENED. ON YOUTH USE OF THE
PRODUCTS AND EVENTUALLY. THEIR
TRANSITION TO OTHER TOBACCO
PRODUCTS DOWN THE ROAD WHICH
WHAT THE RESEARCH IS SHOWING US.
I TEND TO AGREE WITH THAT. IS
WHY WE- DESIGNED THE BILL THAT
WE ARE WORKING ON. SELECT
TOBACCO EXACTLY WHICH IS
BANNING FLAVORS OUTSIDE OF
TRADITIONAL TOBACCO FLAVORS
MENTAL AND INTERNATIONAL
TOBACCO. SOME THAT DID WORK IN
SEEMS LIKE COULD WORK AGAIN THE
OTHER EFFORTS ON FLAVORS. ARE
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED. THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAD. IS AVAILABILITY AND
POPULARITY OF NICORETTE. YES
THE QUESTION IS WHAT WHAT WHEN
I FIRST LEARNED ABOUT THE
CIGARETTE OF A PICKUP TRUCK I
WENT AND WANTED TO SEE ALL OF
THESE CRAZY FLAVORS RIGHT AYE
CAPTAIN CRUNCH AND BUBBLE GUM
THIS AND ICE CREAM THAT. AND SO
I WENT TO THE JEWEL WEBSITE.
START LOOKING THEY FIND ANY OF.
I HAD BEEN TOLD OTHERS ALWAYS
CRAZY YOU KNOW FIFTEEN THOUSAND
FOR EVER SINCE I WON THE
WEBSITE AND FOUND FRUIT MEANT.
AND SEVERAL OTHERS RIGHT AND I
LOOKED AT A COUPLE OTHER
COMPANY WEBSITES AND FOUND
SIMILAR. SIMILAR RESULTS. WHAT
STRUCK ME ABOUT THAT IS I WAS
FAMILIAR THROUGH SOME FRIENDS
AND FAMILY WITH FOLKS WHO HAD
USE NICORETTE THE PAST. AND IT
STRUCK ME THERE WERE SIMILAR OF
NICORETTE FLAVORS. AND I WAS
RIGHT THERE'S A TYPE OF FRUIT
MEANT SAME TYPES OF FLAVORS
THAT WERE OFFERED IN THESE
PRODUCTS. WHY NOT SEE AN
EPIDEMIC OF NICORETTE USE.
AMONG STATES IF IN FACT JUST
BEING LOGICALLY CONSISTENT THE
FLAVORS DRIVE CONSUMPTION TEENS
THAT I WOULD ASSUME WE SHOULD
NEVER NICORETTE EPIDEMIC. AND I
DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE. THAT'S
ON THE DOCTOR. SURE SO USUALLY.
NICOTINE GUM OR LOZENGE IS
USUALLY TWO MILLIGRAMS OF
NICOTINE WE'RE TALKING THESE
TOOL PARTS THAT THE
MANUFACTURER SAYS HAS LIKE
FIFTY SIX MILLIGRAMS. AND
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE THE
EQUIVALENT OF AT LEAST ONE PACK
OF CIGARETTES SO WHEN YOU'RE
HAVING FLAVORS FLAVORS IS JUST
ONE PART OF THE MARKETING AND
IT'S ALSO THE TASTE THAT MASKS.
MAYBE WHATEVER BITTERNESS EVEN
IN NYC NICOTINE GUM OR LOZENGE
YOU KNOW PATIENTS SAY THEY'RE
SOME PEPPERY TASTE THAT BOTHERS
THEM IN THE MIDST NOMS IT AND
MASKS THAT SO. I THINK WE'RE
TALK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TAUGHT
AT THE HIGH POTENCY NICOTINE
PLUS. THE FLAVOR THEY PEEL OF
FLAVORAND THAT IN THE NATION I
THINK IS SOMETHING. THAT'S WAY
DIFFERENT FROM THESE VAPING
PRODUCTS THAT AND WITH. THE
MESSAGE THAT THE F. A. OVERSEAS.
GREECE AND YOUTH USE OF MONTHLY
THAT BIG CAN DEVICES AND MEANT
BABY DEVICES. AND A DECREASE IN
FRUITS AND CAN BE A
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER SO WE ARE
GETTING TO A POINT WHERE YOUNG
PEOPLE. ARE SWITCHING TO MEN'S
WERE STARTING WITH MINT
PRODUCTS. I'M ON THE NECK RIGHT
SIDE ZIPPER SHOULD ABOUT BABY
PRODUCTS NOT AT NOT G
RRECT SO ON THAT ON THE G
DE. SO IT IS THERE IS NO
STANDARD FOR USE OF NICOTINE
REPLACEMENT THERAPY PRODUCTS
FOR USE WITH MINORS. THOSE
PRODUCTS ARE MARKETED TO MINORS
AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT JEWEL
WHO I THINK WE CAN CALL HIM HOW
WORK ON THEIR CURRENTLY AGAIN
UNDER INVESTIGATION FOR THE
PRACTICES OF THE MARKETING THAT
THEY DID DO TO YOUTH
SPECIFICALLY. AND SO THAT'S A
HUGE DIFFERENCE IS THAT I'M
ACCESS TO THESE PRODUCTS
THEY'RE A LOT MORE ATTRACTIVE
TO YOU FAN G
OMOTED BY PROVIDERS AND THEN
ALSO THE INVASIVE MARKETING OF
THESE NEW DEVICES. ON SOCIAL
MEDIA SITES AND SPECIFICALLY TO
YOU. SO THERE MIGHT POINT IS
BACK IN THE DIRECTION OF
RESTRICTIONS ON MARKETING
EDUCATION TAXATION INCREASED
OVERSIGHT AND PENALTIES ALL
THOSE THINGS THAT MIGHT. DIAL
IN ON. ACCESSING THOSE PRODUCTS
MAKE IT MORE SIMILAR TO A
NICORETTE PRODUCT THAT'S MORE
RESTRICTIVE. ITS AVAILABILITY
WOULD ALSO ARE JUST TO FOLLOW
UP ON YOUR THOUGHT DOCTOR
BRINGS UP AND WE DID NOT
DISCUSS THIS AT LEAST NOT THAT
I'M AWARE OF AND- PERHAPS SOME
OTHER CHURCH MEMBERS DID
DISCUSS IT. WAS THE- FOCUSING
ON THE NICOTINE CONTENT WHICH I
THINK YOU KNOW YOU BRING UP
THIS KIND OF EXCESSIVE NICOTINE
CONTENT MAY BE WITH ME WE NEED
TO FOCUS TAXATION. MORATORIUM
PROHIBITION PROVISIONS ON
EXACTLY ON THE AMOUNT OF
NICOTINE CONTAINED IN A PRODUCT
THAT SOME WE HAVE LOOKED AT
BUT- DO YOU THINK THAT MIGHT BE
AN EFFECTIVE AVENUE TO GO DOWN.
I THINK THAT'S WORTH EXPLORING
ON THE E. LIQUIDS AND TRYING.
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S IN THEM
AND ALSO. YOU KNOW WE KNOW
PEOPLE ARE PRICE RESPONSIVE SO
THAT AS- WITH THE CLOSEST WE
GOT THAT I KNOW THE BILL THAT I
WAS WORKING ON SOME MY
COLLEAGUES WE WERE WE WERE.
LOOKING AT A TAXATION APPROACH
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN BASED OFF.
OF THE NICOTINE. CONTENT IN THE
PRODUCT. SO GO BACK AND TAKE
ANOTHER LOOK AT THAT. BASED ON
YOUR COMMENTS HERE TODAY. I
THINK ALSO AT JUST TO NOTE JUST
LIKE WITH THE TAR YOU KNOW
WHATEVER'S REGISTERING IN THE
MACHINE WE STILL NEED TO LEARN
WHAT'S ACTUALLY. GOING ON WITH
THE HUMANS AS WELL. IN MY FINAL
MY FINAL QUESTION I WAS SURE I
HEARD YOUR ANSWERS ON
PROHIBITION. YOUR FOR A
PROHIBITION OR BAND VERSUS
REGULAR REGULATION OVERSIGHT
TAXES I CAN LAY THAT OUT THERE
AND I DIDN'T HEAR YOU GUYS.
ANSWER THAT. AS A PROVIDER I'M
NOT SURE THAT'S USUALLY MY
REALM. AND I'M HERE TO EDUCATE
ABOUT THEIR QUESTION
LEGISLATURE'S ON YOUR YOU KNOW
OPINION GIVEN YOUR INVOLVED
WITH ALL WELL I THINK TIME IS
TELLING THAT THESE PRODUCTS ARE
NOT SAFE AND SO IT'S WORTH.
LOOKING AT EVERY ANGLE. THAT
WE'RE UNDERSTANDING BEES BUT
THE VAPING US A PULMONARY
INJURY WE STILL HAVE A LOT TO
LEARN THAT. YOU KNOW IF THE CDC
IS SAYING TO STOP APING. YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE OUR OPTIONS SO. I
DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S CALLED
PROHIBITION BUT I THINK IT'S
CALLED. HOW DO WE ACT FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU WHAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FEW QUESTIONS
FOLLOW UP. I JUST WANT
COMMENTED COMMENT AND. MISTER
GRANT I AGREE AND DISAGREE ON
THINGS AND SO AT THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT BE OBVIOUS PEOPLE SAID.
THAT'S OKAY BUT- BUT- HE POINT
OUT THAT YOU KNOW WE TALKED
ABOUT BANNING THE FOURTEEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED NINETY
SEVEN FLAVORS AND STILL LEAVING
OTHERS OUT THERE. BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM TOBACCO FREE
KIDS IS THAT WHEN YOU LEAVE
MEANT AND MENTAL ON THE TABLE.
YOU STILL GOT FIFTY PERCENT.
THAT'S THE PREFERENCE 450% OF
USERS SO THAT'S TO ME IS A IS
KIND OF A PROBLEM AND SO. AND
THAT'S THAT'S DATA THAT WAS
FAIRLY DECENT I CAME OUT IN
AUGUST PLEASE SO. THANK MEANT
WAS SOME. AND HE HAD MENTAL IN
THERE AND THE NUMBER STILL HIGH
SO IN OTHER WORDS THAT'S WHY
RULE THAT'S WHY MISTER CARTY
NINE PARTICULAR LOOKING AT A
BAN ON ALL FLAVORS BUT SO BUT-
TALKING ABOUT THE FTA AND
SAFETY AND PENSION T. CORPSE OR
TWO COURSES THAT THE COURSE. IT
SEEMS KIND OF COUNTER INTO IT
SEEMS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE IT
SEEMS WRONG THAT WOULD PUT
PASSED THE INDUSTRY TO PROVIDE
US WITH SAFETY DATA
CONSIDERING. THE HISTORY OF THE
INDUSTRY AND HOW THEY'VE BEEN
SENT ON TO GO THROUGHOUT TIME.
TO THAT BEEN OUT THERE SO. FAIL
TO SEE WHY. YES YOU HAVE DAYS
PUSHING THAT UP BUT HOW DO WE
GET OTHER DATA OUT THERE THAT
ISN'T POTENTIALLY BUYS IT FEELS
A LITTLE LIKE THE FOX GUARDING
THE HEN HOUSE QUITE FRANKLY.
AND IT JUST FEELS BACKWARDS
ESPECIALLY IN THIS ERA. WITH A
HISTORY OF NOT BEING TRUTHFUL
ON ON ISSUES WHY WOULD WE THEN.
TAKE THE SAME PEOPLE AND HAVE
THEM. HAVE THEM YOU KNOW
CONDUCT THE RESEARCH AND THAT
THEY YOU KNOW. THIS IS THIS IS
SAFE. YES WELL THERE ARE A LOT
OF CONTRADICTIONS IN THE
HISTORY OF TOBACCO CONTROL AND
I THINK WORD THIS WHOLE VAPING
EPIDEMIC IS MAKING US TRY TO
EXAMINE EVERYTHING FROM OF.
FROM UP WHAT WE KNOW AND WHAT
WE'RE SEEING NOW. I JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT SOME OF THESE
T. CORES ARE. VERY CAN SERVE AS
IN TERMS OF INDEPENDENT REVIEWS
SO I'VE HAD COLLEAGUES AT UC
SAN FRANCISCO WHERE THERE'S A
NEW PRODUCT THAT. CALLED I
COAST THAT IS THE HEAT NOT BURN
PRODUCT IT'S NOT VAPING IT'S
HEATING AND THEY JUST GOT FTA
THEY SUBMITTED THROUGH THE FDA
APPROVAL TO MARKET. AND THE
FOLKS AT THESE CENTERS LOOKED
AT THE DATA INDEPENDENTLY AND
CAME TO SOME DIFFERENT
CONCLUSIONS SO FOR EXAMPLE THIS
PRODUCT. THAT HE'S NOT BURNS
TOBACCO VERSES REGULAR
CIGARETTES WHEN THEY LOOKED AT
THE INDUSTRY DATA THEY SHOWED.
THERE WAS ACTUALLY. TWO HUNDRED
A 1000% HIGHER. OF OVER FIFTY
CONSTITUENCIES OUT OF A HUNDRED
CHEMICAL CONSTITUENTS IN THIS
HEAT NOT BURN PRODUCT COMPARED
TO REGULAR CIGARETTES AND EVEN
HIGHER. LIVER FUNCTION TESTS
LIVER INFLAMMATION FROM BLOOD
TESTS THAN REGULAR CIGARETTES
SO. I THINK. THESE TWO COURSES
THAT ARE HELP TO THAT ARE
HELPING THE FTA UNDERSTAND WHAT
IS IMPORTANT DATA FOR
REGULATORY SCIENCE PLAY VERY
CRITICAL ROLES. BUT THEY ARE
NOT INDUSTRY THEY'RE TYPICALLY
UNIVERSITIES THAT ARE PROVIDING
DATA AND ALSO CAN HELP WITH
INDEPENDENT. REVIEW OF DATA AS
WELL. IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I-DO HAVE SOME OTHER COMMENTS AND
ALL AND ALL MONEY HIT ON THEM
BUT BUT I KNOW WE'VE GOT A LOT
A BIG AGENDA AHEAD OF US HERE
THANK YOU WITH REGARDS TO
MISTER LOS TALK ABOUT THAT
REALLY A SMALL NUMBER OF CITIES
AND THAT HAVE ACTUALLY TAKEN
ACTION IN A SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME THE FACT IT. ALMOST 10% OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. IN SOME
ACTION ON. THANK YOU
SIGNIFICANT I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA SEE THAT NUMBER GROW. IF
THERE IS AN ACTION FOR ME THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF THE STATE
SO I THINK PART OF THAT IS JUST
PEOPLE SAY WHAT WE GOT A
PROBLEM HERE WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING AND MAYBE IT'S NOT
THE RIGHT THING TO DO. BUT IT'S
BETTER THAN DOING NOTHING AT
ALL AND SO I THINK THAT THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE MORE AND
MORE OF THAT HI TO HEAR THAT IS
LIKE THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN
SCHOOL BAKING. AND IT ISN'T
DISTINGUISH REMAKING TOBACCO
INVADING CANNABIS IT'S A BABY
IT'S ALL LUMPED TOGETHER IS THE
NUMBER IT IS THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE I HEAR FROM FROM PEOPLE.
WE HAVE DONE A MARVELOUS JOB ON
EDUCATION RELATED TOBACCO I
THINK IT SHOWS BYTHE NUMBER OF
THE PERCENTAGE AND HOW THAT CAN
OF ACTUAL TRADITIONAL TOBACCO
USE AND CONTINUE TO GO DOWN.
THE START CHANGE BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND-
EIGHTEEN AND THEN NOW INTO
NINETEEN. I GOTTA WONDER IF IT
ISN'T JUST BECAUSE OF THE
TRENDY LITTLE DEVICE. THOSE
ORIGINAL DEVICES WERE PRETTY.
KEY AND BIG. AND HARD TO HIDE
AND- MOM SEE THAT WHAT THE HECK
IS THIS THING. BUT IT'S HARD
IT'S A MUCH EASIER TO CONCEAL
SOMETHING LIKE LIKE THE JEWEL
DEVICES AND SO. THAT MAKES IT
COOL AND I WONDER HOW MUCH OF
THAT IS AN ISSUE. I THINK NOW
WE'RE ALSO WE ARE HEARING NOW
THAT. THAT IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ALL CALL IT RIGHT NOW
WITH. THE ILLNESSES THAT ARE
HAPPENING. KIDS ARE ARE ARE
TAKING A MORE CAUTIOUS
APPROACH. ABOUT THAT SOME KIDS
ANYWAY. FEMALES MORE THAN MALES
BECAUSE I THINK. GUYS THING TO
THINK THEY'RE INVINCIBLE
PERIOD. AND SO I THINK THAT
THERE ARE THERE AT THE LEAST.
FOR NEW. STARTS AND THOSE THAT.
ARE CURRENTLY THERE ARE QUITE A
QUALITY. CONTENT. BECAUSE IT'S
DICTION IT'S SIMPLE IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE. TO WALK AWAY FROM.
I THINK ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE IN EDUCATION
CERTAINLY THE CANNABIS SPACES.
THE PROMISE OF PROSPECTS BEFORE
WAS REVENUE FOR THAT. AND WE
HAVE A TIME LAG NOW AND THE
REVENUE ISN'T WHAT WE EXPECTED
FROM THE TAXES AND SO WE'RE
KIND OF. A LITTLE BIT BEHIND
THE SCENES ON THAT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AND WE ARE PROGRAMS
EITHER SO MAYBE WE PIGGY BACK
OFF OF. THE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS
THAT YOU'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
BUT THE RESOURCES. TO MOVE THAT
HAVE AND HAVEN'T BEEN IS
AVAILABLE YEAH. IT IS
INTERESTING I HAVE A SON IS NOW
TWENTY THREE HE'S HE SAID AND
THRUST MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH
SCHOOL. THAT CANNABIS WAS MUCH
MORE ACCESSIBLE AND MUCH MORE
CONSUMED. AND TOBACCO ONCE AND
SO THE NUMBERS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT USAGE DOESN'T
SURPRISE ME TOO MUCH BASED ON.
THAT AND WHAT I HEAR FROM FROM
OTHER FROM OTHER PEOPLE SO. IN
IT AS FAR AS TAXATION WHETHER
WE ARE IF WE ARE TAXING. CAM
NICOTINE PRODUCTS OR CANNABIS
PRODUCTS MAYBE EVEN YOU KNOW
LABELING YOU KNOW DIFFERENT
LABELS AND- YOU KNOW MAYBE WE
GO AT SOME POINT TO I THINK
THERE'S A ISN'T THERE SOME SORT
OF A- IS LIKE A STICKER
SOMETHING ON. TOBACCO PRODUCTS
ITS STANCE MAYBE GO THAT WAY IT
WITH CANNABIS AT SOME POINT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T HELP US WITH
THE ILLICIT MARKET. AND SO THAT
I THINK IS THAT THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE THAT'LL HELP
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN THE TWO
MARKETS BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT HELPS US WITH THE OF
LISTEN MARKET. UNTIL THERE'S A
REPORT SO ANYWAY AS FAR SO IF
YOU WANT TO COMMENT I THREW A
LOT OUT THERE SORRY. YEAH I WAS
A QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR
COMING TO HAVE YOU VOTE. SO
WHEN IT'S ON THE COOL FACTOR OF
THESE DEVICES CERTAINLY IT'S
VERY COOL WE WORK WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ARE ENGAGED AND
WORKING ON THESE ORDINANCES IN
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AND
THEY HAVE COME IN SHARED WITH
US THAT THEY SHY AWAY FROM
TELLING THEIR PEERS WHAT
THEY'RE WORKING ON BECAUSE IT'S
NOT COOL TO BE AN ANTI TOBACCO
PERSON RIGHT NOW BECAUSE BIG
BEEPING HAS BECOME. THE NORM SO
THAT'S AN ISSUE BUT THE ISSUE
IS THAT EVEN IF IT WAS JUST A
CALL TRANSFER A LITTLE BIT IT'S
A COOL TURN WITH THE HIGHLY
ADDICTIVE SOLUTION. SO NOW
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE DICTATED SO
EVEN IF THEY DON'T WANT TO USE
ANYMORE AS YOU'D MENTIONED THIS
IS AN ADDICTION NOT A HABIT.
AND SO NOW WE'RE DEALING WITH
SOMETHING THAT WAS COOL WHO HAS
CREATED A NEW GENERATION OF
NICOTINE ADDICTS SO THAT'S A
BIG ISSUE. THE OTHER THING
WE'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT
THE BEING AS THAT'S THE INTENT
OF THIS HEARING. BUT ALSO JUST
TO NOTE THAT THE FLAVORS THAT
WE SAW CIGARETTE SMOKING. GOING
DOWN OVER THE LAST MANY YEARS
AND MUCH OF. THAT CAN BE A
TRIBUTE TO FTA. AND REMOVING
THE FLAVORS THAT CAN BE
ATTRIBUTED TO THE AMAZING WORK
THAT'S HAPPENED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KNOW THAT TOBACCO USE OF
OTHER PRODUCTS WAS NOT CHANGING
OR WAS INCREASING WITH USING
ADULTS AND THAT'S EITHER FLAVOR
TOBACCO PRODUCTS. AND
OFTENTIMES YOUNG PEOPLE WILL
SMOKE THEIR MARIJUANA WITH A
FLAVORED. CIGAR WRAPPER. AND SO
THEY CONNECTION THERE IS. ALL
OF THE FLAVOR TOBACCO IT'S NOT
SIMPLY FLAVORED NICOTINE
SOLUTIONS IT'S AN ISSUE WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE. IT'S THE
FLAVORING AND ALL OF THE
PRODUCTS. SO I'VE SEEN OUR
COMMENTS HAVE DRAWN UP MORE
QUESTIONS SO. MR MCCARTY AND
THEN MR RIVAS YEAH AND WHAT THE
FIRST THING ABOUT THE CITY'S I
JUST WANT TO MENTION DOCTOR
WHAT IS THERE'S 10% RIGHT NOW
BUT I WOULD SAY THE POPULATION
WISE IT'S PROBABLY CLOSE TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY WITH LA SAN
FRANCISCO LA COUNTY THE CITY OF
LA ON THE VERGE OTHER BIG
CITIES AND SO. SOME OF THE
RULES ARE DIFFERENT SO THAT'S
ONE THING LIKE WE SAW WITH A
PLASTIC BAGS IN MENU LABELLING
OF ALL THESE JURISDICTIONS WITH
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT LAWS IT'S
MASK FUSION FOR CONSUMERS AND
THE INDUSTRY PROBABLY I'M NOT
LET'S HAVE ONE STATEWIDE A
POLICY WITH AN GET SUPPORT FROM
THE TAX CAN REGULATION. I GET
WHAT YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
TERM GRAY BUT THERE'S SOME
PRODUCTS THAT YOU KNOW WHEN
THERE'S MODERATE USE TAXING
REGULATION OVERSIGHT MAKES
SENSE LIKE ALCOHOL MODERATE USE
WE DON'T TAX IT REGULATES AND
HAVE HAVE POLICY FOR COCAINE
HEROIN AND METHAMPHETAMINE
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S UNSAFE FOR
ANY. SET SUBSET OF HUMANS THE
KIDS ESPECIALLY I THINK THE
SAFETY THING IS THE QUESTION
HERE AND ONE THING WE HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT YET ASK YOU LAST
QUESTION HERE. IS THAT THE
TOBACCO MINOR SETTINGS VERY
DIFFERENT IN THIS PRODUCT OF
THE NICOTINE THE HIGH DOSAGE
HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THEIR DEVELOPMENT
THEY'RE STILL THERE DEPRESSION
ANXIETY AND BEHAVIORAL ISSUES
THERE'S ONE YOUNG MAN THAT
SUING TOOL TALKING ABOUT WHAT
IT LET LED TO HIS. LIFESTYLE
CHANGE AND THAT'S A PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE THAT HAS COST UPON
SOCIETY AND HEALTHCARE COSTS
AND SO YOU KNOW THAT PIECE WE
HAVEN'T REALLY TALKED ABOUT YET
IS THAT THE IMPACT IT HAS JUST
ON THE ACTUAL YOUNG PEOPLE'S
DID HE MENTION TALK ABOUT THAT
FIRST THING THOUGH. YES SO I
THINK WHEN THE SURGEON
GENERAL'S TALKING ABOUT THE
DEVELOPING BRAIN HE'S ALSO
ADDRESSING MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
AND I THINK. THAT UP AND IT'S
GETTIN MARIJUANA'S AND IT'S NOT
TO SAY THE DOES IT'S NOT
IMPORTANT. FOR OLDER PEOPLE
IT'S JUST THAT. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY IN. POURTANT FOR THE
NEXT GENERATION SO. I THINK
THOSE ARE VERY EXCELLENT POINTS
YOU BRING UP UP THAT IT'S NOT
JUST WILL HELP THAT. YOU KNOW
THESE PULMONARY INJURY CASES
ARE. ALARMING BUT THERE'S YOU
KNOW IT'S THE WHOLE PERSON THAT
WE NEED TO LOOK AT. THANK YOU
RIVAS YEAH SO I APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION YOU KNOW I COME
FROM. PART OF MY TIME THE
ASSEMBLY I WAS SCHOOL
DISCIPLINE MANAGER SO I SAW THE
SEVEN EMIC RIGHT BEFORE MY EYES
I SAW ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING
YOU KNOW. AND SO I GUESS IS A
VERY COMPLEX ISSUE AND A
DISCUSSION WE PROBABLY MAKE IT
WORSE BY ALL THE DIALOGUE
YOU'VE HEARD UP HERE I MEAN
MORE COMPLEX. BUT CERTAINLY
SEEMS LIKE A RACING AGAINST THE
CLOCK IT SEEMS LIKE THIS
EPIDEMIC IS GETTING WORSE DAY
BY DAY AND 'VE BEEN BASED ON
ALL THIS CONVERSATION UP HERE
IT'S YOU KNOW VERY EASY TO GET
LOST IN THE WEEDS OF THIS
COMPLEX ISSUE. I AND THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY A LOT THAT WE DO NOT
KNOW. BUT BASED ON WHAT WE DO
KNOW WE DO KNOW THAT THERE IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEM THERE'S A
CRISIS RIGHT THAT WE HAVEWAS
IT MORE THAN A THOUSAND CASES
OF LUNG ILLNESS THAT HAVE BEEN
REPORTED. IN PEOPLE UNDER
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE 60% OF
THOSE PATIENTS ARE UNDER
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD. 21% ARE
BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
YEARS OF AGE AND AS OF THIS
MORNING TWENTY NINE DEATHS
RELATED TO THIS. AND IN IN YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY AS I MENTIONED
EASY TO GET IN THE WEEDS
BUSINESS COMES AS WE TALK ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT WE COULD TALK ABOUT
FLAVORS AND UNFLAVORED WE TALK
ABOUT T. C. WE TALK ABOUT. YOU
KNOW. THE NICOTINE WE TALK
ABOUT TAXATION. BUT THE ONLY
THING WE CAN THAT WE REALLY DO
KNOW THE ONE THING WE CAN POINT
TO. IS THAT THE RELATE THE ONE
THING WE COULD POINT TO RELATE
TO THE COST OF ALL THE
ILLNESSES AND THE DEATHS. IS
BABY. THAT ALL REPORTED
PATIENTS HAVE A HISTORY OF
USING PAPER PRODUCTS RIGHT. AND
SO TO ME STANDING UP HERE WE
WE'VE GOT ALL THE INFORMATION
WE LOOK AT WHAT OTHER STATES
ARE DOING WE KNOW WHAT YOU KNOW
OUR GOVERNOR DID THROUGH
EXECUTIVE ACTION. BUT IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT IT ABSENT A COMPLETE
VAN OF ALL BABY PRODUCTS THE
FLAVOR NOT FAVOR ALL THE
PRODUCTS. NOTHING IS GOING TO
BE IN IN LESS WE HAVE THAT
NOTHING IS GOING TO BE ENOUGH.
TO PREVENT FUTURE ILLNESSES
INTEL WE ABSOLUTELY KNOW WHAT
IS CAUSING THESE ILLNESSES. IT
IS SO YOU KNOW. AND TELL YOU
KNOW IN IN THE MEANTIME THAT
WERE ROLLING OUT ALL THESE
PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS THAT
WE ARE ADOPTING REGULATIONS AND
BUILD A POLICY FRAMEWORK YOU
KNOW REGULATORY FRAMEWORK TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS. YOU KNOW
AND FIND THE MOST EFFECTIVE THE
SOLUTION OR HOWEVER MANY YOU
KNOW ID IS GOING TO TAKE.
UNLESS WE HAVE AN ABSOLUTE BAN.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WE'RE GONNA
KEEP READING ABOUT MORE
ILLNESSES WE'RE GONNA KEEP READ
ABOUT MORE DEATHS. ASIDE FROM
THE PUBLIC HEALTH COST IMPACT
THE TREATMENT OF SOME OF THESE
PEOPLE IS. GOING TO BE
ASTRONOMICAL AND I REPRESENT A
RURAL AREA. WHERE WE ARE WE
KNOW WE LACK HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND SO UNDERSTANDING
AVAILABILITY OF TREATMENT. LET
ALONE THE COST IS A PROBLEM SO
ABSENT SO I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS ABSENT A COMPLETE BAN. YOU
KNOW THIS IS ONLY GONNA GET
WORSE IS THAT TRUE OR NOT TRUE
OR YOU KNOW. I DON'T KNOW. I
THINK I'LL COMMENT THAT EVERY
WEEK MY SLIDES ARE OUTDATED
BECAUSE THESE CASES ARE RISING
AND THIS IS. THESE ARE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO CAN AND SOME OF THEM
AS YOUR NOTING HOSPITALIZED IN
THE ICE YOU VERY EXPENSIVE
COSTS OF CARE THEY'RE LUCKY
THEY'RE YOUNG BECAUSE THEY CAN
WALK OUT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DYING ARE MIDDLE AGED. YOU KNOW
HOW DO WE STOP THIS I THINK
THIS IS. THIS IS WHY WE'RE
COMING TOGETHER TODAY BUT- TO
AB ANTICIPATE THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF THIS IT
HAS TO BE MORE UPSTREAM. AND AS
I THINK EVERYONE'S NOTED TODAY
A VERY COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S THE CAT'S
OUT OF THE BAG ALREADY AND YOU
KNOW WHAT CAN WE ALL DO
TOGETHER. TO HELP CONTROL THE
EPIDEMIC. THANK YOU THANK YOU
BOTH VERY MUCH. FOR KICKING
THIS OFF. MUCH VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE INFORMATION AND
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND. WITHOUT
SHERMAN LOW ONE SECOND PANEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN AS
WE THEN CLEAR THE TABLE FOR THE
NEXT A PANEL OF THE NEXT PANEL
IS HOW BEEPING AND ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES ARE REGULATED IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WHAT MORE NEEDS
TO BE DONE OUR PANELISTS SUSAN
FINELLI THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
LAURIE AJAX CHIEF OF THE BUREAU
OF CANNABIS CONTROL NICOLAS
MADURO'S DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION. KAREN
LEAF SENIOR ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR TOBACCO LITIGATION
AND ENFORCEMENT SECTION AND
THEN FINALLY HERDER KAPUT FOR
SENIOR ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR THE CANVAS CONTROL
SECTION AND MEMBERS AND
COLLEAGUES THAT JUST AS A POINT
OF. THEIR VACATION THAT IF IT'S
BEEN AN HOUR AND FORTY FIVE
MINUTES AND OUR FIRST PANEL
DISCUSSION AND I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE THIS PANEL AND ADDITIONAL
PANEL AFTER THAT FOLLOWED BY
PUBLIC COMMENTS SO. I KNOW THAT
WILL TRY TO BE VERY DIRECT WITH
SOME OF OUR COMMENTS IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME TO BE ABLE TO
GET AS MUCH INFORMATION AS
POSSIBLE SO HAVING SAID THAT.
AMOUNT WE FIRST BEGIN THEN IN
ORDER. HERE AND WE BEGIN WITH
SEASON FINALE PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON TEARS TEARS AND
MEMBERS I'M SUSAN VALLEY ACTING
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
I'VE BEEN ASKED TODAY TO SPEAK
ABOUT THE ROLE OF THE PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. IN TOBACCO IN
VAPING REGULATION. FIRST I WANT
TO START WITH AS YOU'RE AWARE
GOVERNOR'S SOME DID ISSUE THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND GAVE
SPECIFICALLY ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. TO
LAUNCH A TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
STATEWIDE DIGITAL AND SOCIAL
MEDIA. PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN TO EDUCATE YOUTH YOUNG
ADULTS AND PARENTS ABOUT THE
HEALTH RISKS OF VAPING.
DEVELOPING RECOMMENDATIONS TO
REDUCE THE VEIL ABILITY OF
VAPING DEVICES TO PERSONS UNDER
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE
INCLUDING THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
WARNING SIGNS ABOUT THE HEALTH
RISKS OF VAPING. AT BOTH THE IN
ADVERTISING AND AT RETAIL
RETAILERS. INCREASED
ENFORCEMENT REGARDING ILLEGAL
SALES OF VAPING PRODUCTS AND
SPECIFICALLY E. LIQUID FLAVORS
TO YOUTH IN ADDITION SEE THE
PAGE WAS CHARGED TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF STANDARDS. FOR
NICOTINE CONTENT AND UNIFORM
PACKAGING FOR PURPOSES OF
INCLUDING NICOTINE CONTENT IN
THE CAP CALCULATION TAXES. FOR
TODAY NO RECOMMEND HE NO
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN
FINALIZED AT THIS TIME AND WE
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE ALL
COMPREHENSIVE OP SET OF OPTIONS
AS WE LOOK TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. WE WILL RELEASE AN
ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN JUST
WAITING YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
PEIPING RAISING AWARENESS OF
THE NEW OUTBREAK ASSOCIATED
WITH VAPING ANDY NORMALIZING
ALL TOBACCO USE IN CALIFORNIA.
ON THAT CAMPAIGN IS SET TO
START NEXT WEEK. AS YOU HEARD
THIS MONTH THIS AFTERNOON FROM
THE FIRST PANEL THE NUMBERS
AROUND USE VAPING ARE VERY
CONCERNING IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE HIGH SCHOOL
SMOKING PREVALENCE IN
CALIFORNIA WAS 2% COMPARED 28%
NATIONALLY. BUT WE'RE AFRAID
THAT PROGRESS IS GOING TO GO
THE OTHER WAY AT THE SAME TIME
WE'RE SEEING THIS ALARMING RISE
IN THE NUMBER OF SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN USING ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES. AND E. CIGARETTES
WERE THE MOST COMMONLY USED
TOBACCO PRODUCT ON HOW
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
EIGHTY SIX POINT 4% OF THE HIGH
SCHOOLS TOBACCO USERS REPORT IT
USING A FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCT. THE COST OF SMOKING
CALIFORNIA IS ESTIMATED
EIGHTEEN ONE POINT ONE BILLION
OR FOUR HUNDRED AND FOUR
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND THREE
DOLLARS PER SMOKER ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE PAYING THESE
COSTS NOT JUST THE SMOKERS.
MOST RECENTLY THIS PEIPING
OUTBREAK RAISES GREATER
CONCERNS FOR YOUTH AS WELL AS
ADULTS IN THE NEXT PANEL DR
CHARITY DEAN FROM OUR ARE
ACTING STATE HEALTH OFFICER
WILL SHARE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE OUTBREAK AND THE HEALTH
IMPACTS. SO NEXT TIME WHEN I
TURN TO OUR ROLE IN. REGULATING
BOTH TOBACCO AND CANNABIS FIRST
OFF I WANT TO START BY
EMPHASIZING THAT MUCH OF THE
REGULATORY CONTROL IF YOU AS
YOU HEARD IN THE FIRST PANEL IS
RESIDES WITH THE FEDERAL FOOD
AND DRUG ADMINISTRATION FOR
TOBACCO PRODUCTS. SEE THE PAGE
PROGRAMS FOCUS ON EDUCATION
PREVENTION AND USE REDUCTION IN
ADDITION TO ENFORCEMENT IN
LIMITING ACCESS TO YOU. SEE
DEVIATED MENTORS ADMINISTERS TO
TOBACCO RELATED PROGRAMS THE
CALIFORNIA TOBACCO CONTROL
PROGRAM AND THE STOP. TOBACCO
ACCESS TO KIDS ENFORCEMENT ACT
OR STATE. THAT TOBACCO CONTROL
PROGRAM IS COMPREHENSIVE
STATEWIDE TOBACCO USE
PREVENTION AND REDUCTION
PROGRAM. IT CONDUCTS HEALTH
EDUCATION INTERVENTIONS AND
BEHAVIOR CHANGE PROGRAMS AT THE
STATE LEVEL IN THE COMMUNITY
AND OTHER NON SCHOOL SETTINGS
WITH A FOCUS ON. AND CHANGING
THE ROLE THAT COMMUNITY NORMS.
INFLUENCING BEHAVIORAL CHANGE
REGARDING TOBACCO USE. THIS
PROGRAM CONSISTS OF A STATEWIDE
MEDIA CAMPAIGN STATEWIDE AND
COMMUNITY TOBACCO USE
PREVENTION REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
CONDUCTED BY LOCAL HEATH
DEPARTMENTS AND NONPROFIT
AGENCIES AND STATEWIDE TOBACCO
RELATED SURVEILLANCE AN OUT AND
EVALUATION ACTIVITIES. THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM CD PAGE PROVIDES
MONEY FOR CONDUCTING SMOKING
CESSATION PROGRAMS AND
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN POINT
THREE MILLION ANNUALLY TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND GRANT
PROJECTS. THE SINGLE LARGEST
PROVIDER OF SMOKING CESSATION
ASSISTANCE IN CALIFORNIA IS THE
SMOKERS HELPLINE THAT OPERATES
WITH A BUDGET OF NINE MILLION
ANNUALLY FROM C. PH M. RECEIVED
ANOTHER ONE POINT FOUR MILLION.
FROM FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA. THE
CALIFORNIA SMOKERS HELPLINE
PROVIDE CESSATION COUNSELING
AND SUPPORT IN SEVEN LANGUAGES
AND FOR THE- HEARING IMPAIRED
IT OFFERS SUPPORT BE THE
TELEPHONE CHAT TEXT MESSAGING
AND APPLE N. APPS. IT ALSO
PROVIDES COUNSELING TAYLOR TO
E. CIGARETTES AND SMOKELESS
TOBACCO USERS AND A PROVIDES
ASSISTANCE TO TEENS AND
PREGNANT WOMEN. I AM PURSUANT
TO THE EXECUTIVE ORDER OUR
TOBACCO CONTROL POINT PROGRAM
WILL INCREASE SURVEILLANCE
ACTIVITIES TO MONITOR AWARENESS
AND PERCEPTIONS OF A BANK OF
THE OUTBREAK. THE STOP TOBACCO
ACCESS TO KIDS ENFORCEMENT ACT
I'M IS. THE STATE PROGRAM IS A
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM FOCUSED
ON DECREASING ILLEGAL TOBACCO
SALES TO PERSONS UNDER TWENTY
ONE YEARS OF AGE BY CONDUCTING
INSPECTIONS THAT TOBACCO RETAIL
FACILITIES AWARDING GRANTS TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
FOR TOBACCO RETAIL INSPECTIONS.
AND TRAINING AND CONDUCTING
TOBACCO RELATED RETAIL
INSPECTIONS BY THE US FOOD AND
DRUG ADMINISTRATION. WE WILL BE
AND INCREASING THE COMPLIANCE
CHECKS THROUGH THE STAKE ACT
AND READ. WITH THE AIM OF
REDUCING ILEGAL SALES TO YOUTH
PROP FIFTY SIX PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL SIX MILLION DOLLARS
TO INCREASE OUR ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES UNDER STATE. I'M IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
MINIMUM LEGAL TOBACCO SALE AGE
WAS MOVED TO AGE TWENTY ONE
YEAH IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE STATE WIDE RATE OF THAT
ILLEGAL TOBACCO SALES TO UNDER
AGE ADULTS WAS NINETEEN
PERCENT. THE RATE OF ILLEGAL
TOBACCO SALES FOR HIRE WAS
HIGHER FOR E. CIGARETTES AT 22%
NUMBER A TURN TO THE A VERY
DIFFERENT ROLE THAT WE HAVE THE
IN MAN YOUR MANUFACTURING CAM
ABOUT US ON THE MANIFEST
MANUFACTURED CAMPUS SAFETY
BRANDS. IS VERY DIFFERENT IN
CONTRAST IN CONTRAST TO TOBACCO
CONTROL WHERE THE MAJORITY OF
REGULATORY CONTROL RESTS WITH
THE FEDERAL FTA CALIFORNIA
REGULATES NEARLY EVERY EVERY
ASPECT OF THE STATE'S CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. CPA'S HOUSES THE
MANUFACTURED CANNABIS SAFETY
BRANCH WHICH ENFORCES A STRICT
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
ESTABLISHED THROUGH PROP SIXTY
FOUR MEDICINE ON ADULT USE
CANVAS REGULATORY SAFETY ACT
MALCHUS I. AM REGULATIONS FOR
CANNABIS PRODUCTS THIS
AUTHORITY INCLUDES GENERAL
CANNABIS MANUFACTURING
OVERSIGHT PACKAGING AND
LABELING ADVERTISING AND
MARKETING MANUFACTURING AND
REGULATIONS REGAL. REGARDING
PROHIBIT PRODUCTS AND EMERGENCY
ORDERS CD PH OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES TO GET
CONTINUE TO WORK TO BRING.
CANNABIS BUSINESSES INTO THE
LEGAL MARKET PLACE BUT AS WE
ACKNOWLEDGE IN THE FIRST PLACE
PANEL THAT STILL A PROBLEM.
JUST SO YOU KNOW MAP TO HAS
BUILT IN PROVISIONS THAT REDUCE
YOUTH ACCESS AND PREVENT
PRODUCTS WITH HARMFUL COMMIT
CONTAMINANTS FROM BEING SOLD TO
CONSUMERS THESE INCLUDE. AGE
RESTRICTED RATE RETAILERS
CANNABIS RETAIL STORES ARE
ONLY. AVAILABLE FOR ADULT
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE AND
OLDER TESTING REQUIREMENTS.
FOUR PESTICIDES HEAVY METALS
MICROBIAL AS AND RESIDUAL
SOLVENTS UNDER THE BCC.
GOVERNMENT WARNING STATEMENTS
OUTLINES A COVER MORNING
STATEMENT MUST BE EVERY CAN
ABOUT A LACK. AND ALERTS CAN
EMERGE TO POTENTIAL FAX
ADVERTISING DESTRUCTIONS IT AND
IN ELECTIONS WITH FURTHER
CLARIFY AND THOSE STATUTORY
PROTECTIONS TO REQUIRE GOOD
MANUFACTURING PRACTICE BY ON
CANVAS MANUFACTURERS.
PARLIAMENT TO DISCLOSE ALL OF
THE INGREDIENTS PROHIBITIONS
THAT LABELS ON PRODUCTS CANNOT
BE ATTRACTIVE TO YOUTH
MANUFACTURES CANNOT ADD
NICOTINE. OR CAFFEINE PRODUCT
TO THEIR PRODUCTS REQUIRING THE.
REVERSAL SYMBOL ON VAPE
CARTRIDGES AND A PROHIBITION
AGAINST HEALTH CLAIMS ON THOSE
PRODUCTS. A CLOSING WE CONTINUE
TO WORK THROUGH THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO ADDRESS
THE OUTBREAK AND TO REDUCE
YOUTH YOU SOME TO BACK ON
CANNABIS PRODUCTS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. TO ADDRESS THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT IS ACT.
THANK YOU FAIRS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION MY NAME IS
LAURIE AJAX AND ON THE CHIEF OF
THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL.
AS ONE OF THE STATE AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE FOR REGULATING
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS LICENSES
INCLUDING DISTRIBUTION MICRO
BUSINESSES RETAILERS AND
TESTING LABS THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROLS BEEN CLOSELY
FOLLOWING THE OUTBREAK OUTBREAK
OF HEALTH ILLNESS IS BEING
REPORTED ACROSS THE COUNTRY
THAT HAVE BEEN LINKED TO
VAPING. THE BUREAU SUPPORTS
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER IN SEPTEMBER TAKING
DIRECT ACTION TO ADDRESS THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. ALL
CANNABIS AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS
LEGALLY SOLD IN CALIFORNIA MUST
COME THROUGH A SUPPLY CHAIN OF
ONLY LICENSE CANNABIS
BUSINESSES STARTING AT
CULTIVATION AND ANY WITH THE
SALE TO CONSUMER. THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE ALL LICENSEES
MUST COMPLY WITH REQUIREMENTS
THAT PUT PUBLIC SAFETY FIRST.
THE MOST CRUCIAL PUBLIC HEALTH
RELATED STEP IN THE LEGAL
SUPPLY CHAIN IS MANDATORY
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE TESTING.
BEFORE ANY CANNABIS OR CANNABIS
PRODUCT CAN BE SOLD BY LICENSED
RETAILERS IN CALIFORNIA IT MUST
GO THROUGH RIGOROUS TESTING FOR
CONTAMINANTS SUCH AS PESTICIDE
MOLD HEAVY METALS PROCESSING
CHEMICALS RIDGES RURAL SOLVENTS
AND OTHER HARMFUL INGREDIENTS.
FOR EXAMPLE CANNABIS AND
CANNABIS TRUCK PRODUCTS ARE
TESTED FOR SIXTY SIX PESTICIDES
AND TWENTY RESIDUAL SOLVENTS
AND PROCESSING CHEMICALS. IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION THE
BUREAU IS SET LEVELS FOR THESE
CAN. IT'S THAT CANNOT BE
EXCEEDED IN CANNABIS OR
CANNABIS PRODUCTS THESE LEVELS
ARE SET BASED ON WHAT ARE
CONSIDERED A SAFE AMOUNT FOR
HUMAN CONSUMPTION. ONLY AFTER A
TESTING LABORATORIES CONFIRM
THAT THE CANNABIS ARE CANNABIS
PRODUCT DOES NOT EXCEED ANY OF
THESE LIMITS CANNOT BE
DISTRIBUTED TO RETAILERS FOR
SALE TO CONSUMERS. CANNABIS AND
CANVAS PRODUCTS THAT CANNOT
MEET TESTING STANDARDS MUST BE
DESTROYED. WELL NO SINGLE
SUBSTANCE OUR PRODUCT HAS YET
BEEN LINKED TO THE CASES
INVOLVING VAPING RELATED
ILLNESSES IT HAS BEEN REPORTED
THAT MANY OF THE CASES INVOLVE
THE USE OF THC CONTAINING
PRODUCTS PARTICULARLY FROM THE
UNLICENSED MARKET. THEREFORE TO
ASSIST WITH THE DRIVE
ADDRESSING THE VAPING HEALTH
ISSUES THE BUREAU IN
COOPERATION WITH OTHER STATE
EIGHT AND EIGHT ENTITIES IS
FOCUSED ON LICENSE ACTIVITY
TRACING SOURCES OF VAPING
ILLNESSES AND PUBLIC EDUCATION.
THE BUREAU THE CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT UNIT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING TOGETHER TO
IDENTIFY AND SHUT DOWN
UNLICENSED RETAILERS
DISTRIBUTORS AND MANUFACTURERS.
THE CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT UNIT
PROVIDES SWORN PEACE OFFICER
SERVICE TO INVESTIGATE AND
LICENSE ACTIVITY COMPLAINTS
RECEIVED BY THE BUREAU. THE
BUREAU ON THE CANVAS
ENFORCEMENT UNIT ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO PRIORITIZE
COMPLAINTS INVOLVING ILLEGAL
CANNABIS VAPING PRODUCTS. IN
THE LAST SIX WEEKS THE CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT UNITS SERVE TWELVE
SEARCH WARRANTS INVOLVE
ILLEGALLY MANUFACTURED VAPING
PRODUCTS. THE SEARCH WARRANTS
WERE SERVED ON UNLICENSED
CANNABIS RETAILERS DISTRIBUTORS
AND MANUFACTURERS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. DURING
THESE OPERATIONS TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND POUNDS OF CANNABIS
GOOD RECEIVED WITH A RETAIL
VALUE OF FIFTY ONE MILLION.
THIS INCLUDED THE SEIZURE OF
TWENTY THOUSAND VAPE PENS AND
VAPE PEN CARTRIDGES. THE MOST
RECENT CASE YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
IN THE MEDIA IS ABOUT THE
SEIZURE OF CUSHY PUNCH PRODUCTS
I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT THE
SITUATION IS BEING ACTIVELY
INVESTIGATED HOWEVER I'M NOT
ABLE TO PROVIDE ANY FURTHER
DETAILS ABOUT THIS DURING MY
TESTIMONY TODAY AS THIS
INVESTIGATION IS ON GOING. IN
ADDITION TO STOPPING AND
LICENSED RETAILERS AND
COUNTERFEIT CANNABIS PRODUCTS
IT IS CRITICAL TO EDUCATE
CONSUMERS ABOUT HOW TO IDENTIFY
A LICENSED RETAILER. THE
BUREAU'S OVERSEEN A STATEWIDE
PUBLIC INFORMATION CAMPAIGN
CALLED HASH TAG GET WE'D WEISS.
THE CAMPAIGN INCLUDES EXTENSIVE
OUTREACH EDUCATING CONSUMERS
ABOUT THE RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
CANNABIS PURCHASED FROM
UNLICENSED BUSINESSES AND
ENSURING THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
ONLY CANNABIS AND CANNABIS
PRODUCTS PURCHASED FROM
LICENSED RETAILERS HAVE PASSED.
STATE REGULATORY TESTING. THE
BUREAU IS HIGHLIGHTING HOW A
CONSUMER CAN USE THE CA POT
CHECK DOT COM WEBSITE TO VERIFY
THE BUSINESS IS LICENSE BEFORE
MAKING A PURCHASE. THE CAMPAIGN
ALSO IS MAKING IT CLEAR TO AND
LICENSE BUSINESSES THAT THEY
WILL BE PROSECUTED FOR THEIR
ACTIVITIES. IN LESS THEY CEASE
OPERATIONS OR GET LICENSE. THE
BUREAU SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S
EFFORTS TO CONFRONT THE YOUTH
OF AB AN EPIDEMIC AND ADDRESSES
ONGOING PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
THE BUREAU WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THESE PRODUCTS ARE SAFE
FOR CONSUMER THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NOW NICOLAS
MADURO'S FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS TO
COMMITTEES MY NAME'S NICK
MADERA SOME THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISED TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION CD TFA. IT'S A
MOUTHFUL TO SAY THE CALIFORNIA
PROPERTY TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION SO. CDFA
ADMINISTERS ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN
TAX PROGRAMS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OUR LARGEST IS THE
SALES AND USE TAX PROGRAM BUT
WE ALSO ADMINISTER THE TOBACCO
TAXES FOR THE STATE AS WELL AS
THE CANNABIS TAXES. TODAY ALL
FOCUS ON THOSE TWO PROGRAMS.
I'D LIKE TO FOR STARTUP BY
DISCUSSING HOW THOSE TAX
PROGRAMS WORK THEN BRIEFLY
OUTLINE OUR ENFORCEMENT METHODS
AND LASTLY ALL HIGHLIGHTS SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES WE FACE AS WE
ILLEGAL THEY PRODUCTS BOTH IN
THE TOBACCO AT HAND CANNABIS.
ROUNDS SO THE TOBACCO TAX
PROGRAMS WE HAVE THREE BASIC
CATEGORIES OF TAX PROGRAMS WE
ADMINISTER SUIT CIGARETTE TAXES
TOBACCO PRODUCT TAXES AND SERVE
CIGARETTE TOBACCO PRODUCTS
LICENSING FEES. LAST YEAR THE
DEPARTMENT BROUGHT IN AND
ADMINISTERED ABOUT SEVENTY FOUR
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
TAX REVENUE OF THAT TWO POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS. IS RELATED
TO THESE TOBACCO TAX AND FEE
PROGRAMS. OTHER TOBACCO
PRODUCTS WHICH ARE THE NON
CIGARETTE TAXES ACCOUNTED FOR
ABOUT 13% OF THAT REVENUE WERE
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FY. EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THOSE ARE TAXES
DERIVED FROM HISTORICALLY IT
WAS CIGARS SMOKING TOBACCO
CHEWING TOBACCO AND SNUFF. WITH
PROP FIFTY SIX AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN. ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES
AND VAPE PRODUCTS WERE ADDED TO
THAT DEFINITION OF TOBACCO
PRODUCTS AND SO ON. IT IS ONLY
SINCE THEN THAT WE'VE BEEN.
TAXING THOSE VAPING PRODUCTS AS
OTP OR OTHER TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
WE ESTIMATE THAT LAST YEAR THE
TAX REVENUE FROM THOSE PROGRAMS
FROM TO FROM VAPING PRODUCTS
AMOUNTED TO ABOUT FIFTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS STARTING NEXT
YEAR WE WILL HAVE EXACT NUMBERS
AS WE'RE CHANGING OUR RETURNS.
TO REQUIRE THAT VAPING PRODUCTS
BE SEPARATELY LISTED ON THE TAX
RETURNS. THE RATE ON T. P.
INCLUDING VAPING PRODUCTS IS
SET BASED ON THE TOBACCO THE
CIGARETTE TAX RATE SO
CIGARETTES ARE TAXED AT TWO
DOLLARS AND EIGHTY SEVEN CENTS
PER PACK IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOW STARTED OUT AS
THREE CENTS BACK IN THE FIFTIES
AND ROB TO TWO EIGHTY SEVEN.
WHAT WE DO ANNUALLY IS WE TAKE
THAT TWO EIGHTY SEVEN AND WE
ADD FIFTY CENTS TO IT SO YOU'RE
AT THREE DOLLARS AND THIRTY
SEVEN CENTS PER PACK WE DIVIDE
THAT BY TWENTY WHICH IS THE
NUMBER OF CIGARETTES IN A
SINGLE PACK. YOU GET SIXTEEN
POINT EIGHT FIVE CENTS AND THEN
WE DIVIDE THAT NUMBER EACH YEAR
BY THE AVERAGE WAITED COST OF A
SINGLE CIGARETTE. THIS YEAR
THAT MEANS THAT T. P. INCLUDING
ALL OF THESE TO BACK OF EGG
PRODUCTS. ARE TAXED AT A RATE
OF FIFTY NINE POINT TWO SEVEN
PERCENT. NOW ONE. CURIOUS THING
ABOUT THE WAY THE CALIFORNIA
TAXES ARE SET UP IS THAT THAT
AVERAGE WILL STILL COST WHICH
IS THE DENOMINATOR IN THE
EQUATION. RISES EACH YEAR
BECAUSE OF INFLATION. WHICH
MEANS THAT THE TAX RATE ON
OTHER TOBACCO PRODUCTS ACTUALLY
GOES DOWN EACH YEAR. IT IS. TO
ME A STRANGE OUTCOME BUT WE
HAVE. ANYWAY IN ADDITION TO
THAT TAX WE ALSO HAVE THE
CIGARETTE TOBACCO PRODUCTS
LICENSING PROGRAM WHICH
LICENSES ANNUALLY OF ABOUT
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND RETAILERS
THREE HUNDRED WHOLESALERS AND
EIGHT HUNDRED DISTRIBUTORS NOW
ON THE TOBACCO SIDE OF THE
EQUATION. WE ADMINISTER THE
SALES AND USE TAX PROGRAM WHICH
APPLIES TO THESE TOBACCO SALES
AS WELL AS THE EXCISE TAX AND
THE CULTIVATION TAX. LAST
FISCAL YEAR THAT ALL OF THOSE
PROGRAMS TOGETHER BROUGHT IN
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND TO DATE
SINCE ADULT. LEGAL CANNABIS. OF
THEY'VE HAVE BROUGHT IN ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. THE EXCISE TAX
IS AGAIN A VERY COMPLICATED ONE
AT THE MOMENT IT'S 15% BASED ON
THE WHOLESALE COST. PLUS AND
MARK UP RATE THAT CD TFA
DETERMINES EACH YEAR WHICH IS
CURRENTLY SET AT 60% SO IT'S
NOT A 15% ON THE ACTUAL PRICE
PAID BY THE CONSUMER. IT COULD
BE MUCH LESS THAN 15% IT COULD
BE MUCH HIGHER BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY MARK UP THE ACTUAL
MARKUP. VARIES IN TRANSACTIONS
AND THAT. ANYWAY SO THOSE THE
TAX PROGRAMS WE ADMINISTER. HOW
WE ENFORCE THEM WE HAVE THREE
BASIC METHODS INSPECTIONS
INVESTIGATIONS AND AUDITS. WE
HAVE TEN INSPECTION TEAMS
DEDICATED TO TOBACCO
ENFORCEMENT AND NOW. THROUGH B.
C. P. LAST YEAR TO ACT CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT AS WELL AROUND THE
STATE. THEIR JOB DAY IN AND DAY
OUT IS TO DO INSPECTIONS OF
RETAILERS TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
THE PRODUCTS IN THOSE STORES IS
TAX PAID. IN THE CASE OF
CIGARETTES AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER ALL OF THE TAX PAID
MATERIALS HAVE STAMPS THE EVERY
PACK OF CIGARETTES IN THE STATE
HAS TO HAVE A TAX STAMP AND
ACTUALLY THE TAXES PAID WHEN
YOU PARK WHEN THE DISTRIBUTOR
PURCHASES THAT STAMP AND PLACES
IT ON THE- THE- PACK OF
CIGARETTES. FOR OTHER MATERIALS.
OUR INSPECTORS GO IN AND HAVE
TO ASK FOR THE INVOICES AND-
THE RETAILERS HAVE TO PROVE TO
US THAT THE MATERIAL IS TAX
PAID IF THEY CAN'T PROVE IT
THEN WE SEIZE THE MATERIAL. IN
SINCE JULY OF THIS YEAR OUR
INSPECTORS HAVE DONE ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
INSPECTIONS. IN THE PAST TWO
MONTHS ALONE WE'VE DONE A
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
INSPECTIONS OF VAPING SPECIFIC
RETAILERS. OF THOSE HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX WE'VE HAD SEVENTEEN
SEIZURES OF PRODUCTS AMOUNTING
TO ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF VALUE NOW
THAT'S ON THE TOBACCO SIDE OF
THE HOUSE ON THE CANNABIS
FRONT. WE'VE DONE ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED INSPECTIONS SINCE JULY
AND PARTICIPATE IN SEVENTY FIVE
SEARCH WARRANTS AS AS LAURIE
MENTIONED WE PARTNER OFTEN WITH
BCC AND CONSUMER AFFAIRS AS
WELL AS LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
ALL AROUND THE STATE. IN
ADDITION TO THOSE VISITS OUR
OUTREACH PROGRAM BECAUSE OF THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM WE'RE
DEALING WITH WE'VE HAD OUR
OUTREACH TEAMS AROUND THE STATE
ALSO DOING CANNABIS VISITS
THEY'VE DONE ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT. SINCE
JULY AND IN THOSE CASES WE'RE
ACTUALLY VISITING NOT JUST
PERMIT HOLDERS WERE VISITING
AND THE. CANNABIS SELLER THAT
WE CAN FIND AND DUE TO SITES
LIKE WITH MAPS AND OTHERS.
PEOPLE ARE HIDING THEIR RETAIL
ACTIVITY. THERE ARE SOME REAL
CHALLENGES ON BOTH OF THESE
FRONTS AND I'D LIKE TO JUST
ADDRESS THOSE VERY BRIEFLY. ON
THE TOBACCO SIDE. THE LACK OF
STAMPING. OUTSIDE OF CIGARETTES
IS A CHALLENGE IT'S MUCH EASIER
TO GO INTO A STORE AND SEE
THAT. ALL THE PRODUCT IS
STAMPED AND ACTUALLY THE STAMPS
CONTAIN. INFORMATION OUR
INSPECTORS HAVE DEVICES WHICH
ALLOW THEM TO READ THE STAMPS
AND YOU CAN TELL. WHO THE
DISTRIBUTOR WAS WHEN IT WAS
DISTRIBUTED A LOT OF BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ON. ON EACH OF
THOSE. STAMPS. ALSO ON THE
VAPING SIDE. THE TAX RATE. IS
LOWER I THINK THAN YOU WOULD
ANTICIPATE. BECAUSE IT BECAUSE
THE TAXES BASED ON THE
WHOLESALE COST THE WHOLESALE
COST OF SOME OF THESE PRODUCTS
IS. RELATIVELY LOW AND SO IF OF
APING CARTRIDGE IS THE
EQUIVALENT OF ONE PACK OF
CIGARETTES IN MANY INSTANCES
THE TAX ON A BEEPING CARTRIDGE
IS MUCH LESS THAN THE TWO
DOLLARS AND EIGHTY SEVEN CENTS
TAX ON A PACK OF CIGARETTES SO
THAT'S AN ISSUE. WE'RE ALSO
SEEING IT YOU KNOW THERE'S A-
VERY THERE'S BOTTOM EASE OF
MARKET ENTRY IN THE VAPING
SECTOR. WE'VE SEEN A. PEOPLE
CAN GO ON LINE ORDER MATERIALS
FOR THEIR STORES THEY CAN SELL
THE NICOTINE LIQUID SEPARATELY
FROM THE OTHER LIQUIDS AND
PEOPLE CAN MIX THEM AT HOME
ONLY THE NICOTINE LIQUID IS
TAXED CURRENTLY NOT ANY OF THE
OTHER VAPING FLAVORED JUICES IF
THEY'RE SOLD SEPARATELY ONCE
THEY'RE COMBINED AND IT'S ALL
TAX BUT OTHERWISE ONLY THE
NICOTINE. THE PENALTIES HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN PRETTY LOW
FOR NON COMPLIANCE THAT
ACTUALLY GOES ON THE CAñADA
SIDE AS WELL. OUR INSPECTORS AT
LEAST ARE OPERATING IN A WORLD
WHERE THE PENALTIES ARE OFTEN
MISDEMEANORS WHERE IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT EVEN WANT TO GET
INVOLVED IN A MISDEMEANOR CASE
AND THE FINES ARE PRETTY LOW.
EVEN FOR FAILURE TO LEAD OUR
INSPECTORS IN TO RECORD SEE
YOUR BOOKS YOU KNOW IT'S A FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE IF
SOMEBODY'S OPERATING ON THE FAR
SIDE OF THE LAWN MAKING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ACTING
ILLEGALLY. THE PROSPECT OF MY
AUDITOR'S WITH THEIR POCKET
PROTECTORS SHOWING UP AND
KNOCKING ON THE DOOR AND THE
YOU HAVE A POTENTIAL OF BUT A
MISDEMEANOR THAT. IN SOME CASES
AS MANY REDUCE DOWN TO FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS BY LOCAL COURTS
IS NOT A REAL THREAT TO MANY OF
THESE FOLKS ON THE CAñADA SIDE
THE ILLEGAL MARKET IS VERY
LARGE THE WAY WE HAVE
TRADITIONALLY APPROACH.
ENFORCEMENT IS CUMBERSOME AND
SLOW IT RELIES LARGELY ON THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH
IS. SLOW AND DIFFICULT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO BUILD THE CASES IT
TAKES TIME. WITH THOUSANDS OF
ILLEGAL OPERATORS AROUND STATE
IT'S NOT I DON'T THINK THAT'S A
METHOD THAT SEARCH THE STATE
BEST AND WE'RE LOOKING AT OTHER
WAYS OTHER THINGS THAT WE CAN
DO. AND AS TO WITH TOBACCO WERE
ALSO STUDYING STAMPING WE'RE
WORKING CURRENTLY ON. A
THOROUGH REVIEW IN LIGHT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
WHICH WILL BE PRESENTING TO HIM
AT THE END OF THIS MONTH THAT
WILL. REVIEW ALL OF THESE
OPTIONS AND SEE IF WE CAN'T
FIND A BETTER WAY ANYWAY LOOK
FOR YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND FINALLY AT TWO
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE WHEN
AND CANNABIS CONTROL SECTION
AND ALSO IN THE TOBACCO
LITIGATION ENFORCEMENT SECTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CARILLO AS
WELL AS CHAIRMAN WOULD AND
CHAIRMAN GRAY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KAREN LIFE
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAVE YOUR FOR SERRA.
THE I AM THE HEAD OF THE
TOBACCO LITIGATION AND
ENFORCEMENT SECTION WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE MY COLLEAGUE HERE HER
WINDOW POR IS THE HEAD OF
CANNABIS CONTROL SECTION WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA. ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE SO THE TWO OF
US ARE HERE TO REPRESENT THE
TURNING GENERAL AND. MY
COLLEAGUE RENDER WILL BE
SPEAKING TO YOU ABOUT THE
CANNABIS SIDE OF THE VAPING
ISSUES WHILE I WILL. FOCUS MY
REMARKS ON THE TOBACCO SIDE.
LET ME SAY THAT WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL TO HAVE THIS HEARING
BECAUSE IT CALLS ATTENTION TO
WHAT WE DO IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES. OF OTHERS
HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN TO THE
SEVERE HEALTH ISSUES THAT HAVE
SURFACED WITH THE USE OF VAPING
DEVICES IN RECENT MONTHS AS
WELL AS THE HUGE SPIKE IN UNDER
AGE USE OF ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES I DON'T THINK I NEED
TO REPEAT THAT AT THIS TIME.
EXCEPT TO REMIND ALL OF US THE
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY
NINETEEN NATIONAL YOUTH TOBACCO
SURVEY PULMONARY DATA WERE NOW
NATIONWIDE A POINT WHERE MORE
THAN ONE OUT OF FOUR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IS USING
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES THIS IS
THE MOST POPULAR. FORM OF
TOBACCO USE. AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE
TODAY. AND THIS IS FOR A PUBLIC
HEALTH STANDPOINT EXTREMELY
ALARMING BECAUSE IT THREATENS
TO REVERSE MUCH OF THE GREAT
WORK IN PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN
DONE OVER MANY YEARS TO REDUCE
TOBACCO USE IN THE UNITED
STATES. THE PRODUCT THAT KILLS
MORE AMERICANS THAN ANY OTHER
PRODUCT IT IS THE SINGLE
LARGEST SOURCE OF PREVENTABLE
DEATH AND DISEASE IN OUR
COUNTRY CLAIMING THE LIVES OF
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND AMERICANS. EVERY YEAR.
END ALL THIS IS OCCURRED IN THE
FACE OF A REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AT LEAST WITH RESPECT TO
TOBACCO IS FAIRLY ROBUST AND I
WILL TURN MY REMARKS TO THAT
NOW. UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES ARE
CONSIDERED TOBACCO PRODUCTS AS
SUCH THEY ARE SUBJECT AS MY
COLLEAGUE HERE NICOLAS MADURO
SAID TO STATE EXCISE TAXES AND
STATE LICENSING LAWS STATE
SMOKE FREE LOS STATE UNDER AGE
SALES LOANS AND REMOTE SAW
SALES LOSS AND I'M SURE I
HAVEN'T GIVEN THE FULL LIST BUT
IT THERE'S FAIRLY
COMPREHENSIVE. REGULATION OF
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES AT THE
STATE LEVEL IN ADDITION MANY
LOCAL COMMUNITIES OF ADOPTED
ORDINANCES TO REGULATE.
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES IN ONE
FASHION OR ANOTHER MAINLY THIS
COMES IN THE FORM OF LOCAL
RETAIL TOBACCO LICENSE
ORDINANCES BUT IN SOME
INSTANCES IT IS A LEGISLATION
THAT IS SPECIFICALLY DIRECTED
AT ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES OR
FLAVORED PRODUCTS. AT LEAST
SEVEN COUNTIES IN MORE THAN
THIRTY TWO OF CITIES IN THE
STATE REGULATE IN THIS FASHION.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES ARE
REGULATED BUT TO A LESSER
DEGREE THE FEDERAL FOOD AND
DRUG ADMINISTRATION HAS
REGULATORY AUTHORITY UNDER THE
FEDERAL FAMILY SMOKING
PREVENTION AND TOBACCO CONTROL
ACT WHICH WAS PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE AND UNDER
THEIR DEMAND RATINGS.
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES ARE
WITHIN THEIR REGULATORY AMP IT
HOWEVER. FTA HAS IT HERE TO AN
ENFORCEMENT POLICY WHICH HAS
ALLOWED ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES
TO BE SOLD AND MARKETED IN THE
UNITED STATES INCLUDING IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH THE REQUIRED PREMARKET
APPROVAL PROCESS BY THE FDA.
NOW I'VE SEEN IN NEWS REPORTS
TO THE FACT THAT THE FDA IS
REVIEWING THAT ENFORCEMENT
POLICY AND MAY. CHANGE IT
ESPECIALLY WITH RESPECT TO
FLAVORED ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES
BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING
DEFINITIVE FROM THAT AGENCY AT
THIS POINT OF I WOULD NOTE THAT
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO FEDERAL EXCISE TAXES
NOR OR THEY SUBJECT IS A NUMBER
OF OTHER. FEDERAL LAWS THAT
APPLY TO OTHER TOBACCO PRODUCTS
SUCH AS THE PACT ACT WHICH
GOVERNS. INTERESTED INTERSTATE.
A NET AND MAIL ORDER SALES OF
CIGARETTES AND SMOKELESS
TOBACCO OR THE FEDERAL
CONTRABAND CIGARETTE
TRAFFICKING ACT WHICH GOVERNS
SMUGGLING OF CIGARETTES. WITH
THAT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OWN ROLE
WITH RESPECT TO BACK UP. THIS
ROLE DATES BACK. SEVERAL
DECADES NOW TO REALLY THE MID A
NINETEEN NINETIES WHEN
CALIFORNIA AMONG A LARGE NUMBER
OF OTHER STATES SUED THE MAJOR
CIGARETTE MANUFACTURERS FOR. A
HOST OF WRONGDOING BUT MOST
NOTABLY THEIR DECADES LONG
CONSPIRACY TO DECEIVE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT THE
HEALTH RISKS OF THE PRODUCTS
AND THEN TAKE TO DO THIS OF
NICOTINE. THOSE LAWSUITS WERE
RESOLVED BY THE- MASTER
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT WHICH AT
THE TIME WAS THE LARGEST CIVIL
SETTLEMENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
IT IMPOSES A NUMBER OF ON GOING
OBLIGATIONS ON THE PART OF THE
SIGNATORY MANUFACTURERS
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREAS OF
ADVERTISING AND MARKETING BUT
THEY ALSO OBLIGATE THE
MANUFACTURERS TO MAKE PAYMENTS
TO THE SUBTLE IN STATES. IN
PERPETUITY SO ALONG AS THEY
CONTINUED TO MANUFACTURE AND
SELL THEIR PRODUCTS. IN THE
DOMESTIC STREAM OF COMMERCE.
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS HAD A UNIT
NOW FOR TWENTY YEARS THAT HAS
OVERSEEN. THEIR COMPLIANCE WITH
THIS. REALLY LANDMARK
AGREEMENT. WE HAVE NOT
HESITATED TO SUE INDIVIDUAL
MANUFACTURERS WHEN WE THOUGHT
THE DAY DID NOT COMPLY WITH
THEIR OBLIGATIONS UNDER THAT
AGREEMENT SO WE HAVE SUED AND
WON ON ISSUES SUCH ISSUES
TARGETING AND REACHED AN FREE
SAMPLING. WE HAVE OVERSEEING
THEIR COMPLIANCE WITH PAYMENT
OBLIGATIONS AND THEY ARE
SUBSTANTIAL. TO DATE CALIFORNIA
HAS RECEIVED SIXTEEN POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN PAYMENTS
FROM THE SIGNATORY
MANUFACTURERS. AND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN A LITTLE CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED JUST SHY OF EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITION TO MAKING
SURE THAT THE COMPANIES THAT
ARE PART OF THE MASTER
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. LIVE UP
TO THEIR OBLIGATIONS UNDER THAT
AGREEMENT. THE STAFF WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE AND FORCES A ST PAUL
CALLED AN ESCROW STATUTE THAT
APPLIES TO THE MANUFACTURERS
THAT I'M NOT PART OF THAT
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. THERE ARE
CERTAIN OBLIGATIONS THAT THEY
HAVE BASED ON THEIR SALES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE THANKFUL
WE HAVE ANOTHER STATE LAW
CALLED THE TOBACCO DIRECTORY
STATUTE THAT SHORES UP OUR
ABILITY TO ENFORCE BOTH OF
THOSE LAWS. THAT LAW OBLIGATES
THE TOURNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO
CREATE AND MAINTAIN A PUBLIC
LIST ON OUR WEBSITE. OF ALL THE
CIGARETTE MANUFACTURERS AND
BRANDS THAT ARE LAWFUL FOR SALE
IN THE STATE AN THERE IS A IN
SCREENING PROCESS. THE MY STAFF
AND I DO WITH RESPECT TO EVERY
SINGLE CIGARETTE MANUFACTURER
THAT WANTS TO BE LISTED ON THAT
DIRECTORY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE SATISFIED THE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS WHICH
INCLUDE. A SHOWING THAT THEY'VE
COMPLIED WITH THEIR FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS AND THEIR COMPLAINT
WITH OTHER LAWS SO TO STATE
LICENSING STATUTES. SO WE HAVE
THAT AS A TOOL I CAN TELL YOU
BASED ON MY OWN EXPERIENCE THAT
IT IS SERVED CALIFORNIA WELL IT
IS A GATE KEEPING FUNCTION.
THAT HAS BEEN VERY VALUABLE IT
AND BEING ABLE TO SURE THE- THE
CIGARETTES THAT ARE SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA. ARE AWFUL FOR SALE
IN CALIFORNIA AND TO MAKE THOSE
OUT THERE IN THE FIELD EASILY
IDENTIFIED THE VOGUE BRANDS
INVOKE MANUFACTURERS WHO THAT
QUALIFY AS CONTRABAND. WELL I
MUST SAY THE TOBACCO DIRECTORY
ALASKA'S COACH YOU DON'T APPLY
THE LIKE TONIC CIGARETTES THAT
SAID THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS BEEN
ACTIVE WITH RESPECT TO
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES AMONG. OF
OVERSEEING THE COMPLIANCE OF
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE SELLERS
THAT SELL OVER THE INTERNET TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
COMPLIANT WITH CALIFORNIA'S
STEAK ACT AND OTHER LAWS THAT
APPLY TO THEM AND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN SO FAR THIS YEAR ALONE
WE HAD ISSUED FORTY MORE THAN
FORTY WARNING LETTERS TO
RETAILERS THAT ARE SELLING
THROUGH THE INTERNET. THAT HAVE
SOLD TO UNDER AGE CUSTOMERS OR
OTHERWISE NOT COMPLIANT WE HAVE
ALSO. HAVE NOT HESITATED TO
SUIT OF EASTER EGG COMPANIES
FOR OTHER FORMS OF WRONGDOING
INCLUDING FALSE ADVERTISING AND
OF USE TARGETING AND WE HAVE A
JUDGMENT AGAINST TO WE ALSO
WORK CLOSELY WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES INCLUDING CITY TFA WE
SHARE INFORMATION WITH THEM
ABOUT BUSINESSES THAT WE HAVE
REASON TO THINK MAY BE
OPERATING WITHOUT REQUIRED
STATE LICENSES OR POTENTIALLY
VIOLATING THEIR OBLIGATIONS TO
PAY THE STATE EXCISE TAXES THAT
ARE OWED. AND IN ADDITION THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE OR MORE PRECISELY
ATTORNEY GENERAL BRACERO HAS
URGED THE FDA TO STEP UP ITS
ENFORCEMENT. WITH RESPECT TO
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES TO ACT
MORE AGGRESSIVELY IN THE NAME
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. IN EARLIER
THIS YEAR ATTORNEY GENERAL THE
SERRA ALONG WITH SEVERAL OTHER
STATE ATTORNEYS GENERAL URGED
THE FDA TO PRIORITIZE
ENFORCEMENT OF ALL FLAVORED
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES. ALL SO
IT IS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ON
RECORD. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
AREA OF ENFORCEMENT. I WOULD
ADD THE THANKS TO PROP FIFTY
SIX THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE HOUSE OF NEW
ISSUE ROLE. IN SUPPORTING LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THE PROP FIFTY
SIX AS HAS BEEN NOTED IS AMONG
OTHER THINGS INCREASES THE
STATE EXCISE TAX ON CIGARETTES
AND OTHER TOBACCO PRODUCTS IF
YOUR MARKS THE REVENUE FOR A
NUMBER OF PURPOSES INCLUDING
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
THAT IS ALLOCATED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR
DISTRIBUTION TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. FOR ENFORCEMENT OF
STATE AND LOCAL LAWS THAT DEAL
WITH ILLEGAL AN UNDER AGE SALES
OF TOBACCO SO THERE'S A
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON SALES AND
USE BY MINORS. MISSILE MAY I
ASK YOU TO CONCLUDE YOUR
REMARKS THAT WE CAN GET ON TO
THE NEXT BE FANTASTIC I'M SORRY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WAS
REALLY JUST ABOUT FINISHED I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE THE
PROGRAM HAS FUNDED OF MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED GRANTS TO DATE. AND
THAT HAS FUNDED A VARIETY OF
LOCAL AGENCIES OF POLICE
DEPARTMENT SURE SUPPORT OFFICES
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS MANY OF
THEM ARE USING THE GRANT FUNDS
FOR A LOT DEALING WITH
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE ISSUES IN
THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES SO WITH
THAT I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
THERE'S. MORE INFORMATION ON
OUR PUBLIC WEBSITE AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. A GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN GRAY CHAIRMAN LOW AND
CHAIRMAN WORD AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR CONVENING
THIS HEARING ON AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. I AM GOING TO
CUT SOME OF MY REMARKS SO IN
LIGHT OF THE TIME. AGAIN MY
NAME IS FREDERICK ACCORDING TO
SENIOR ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR THE COUNT OF THIS
CONTROL SECTION IN THE OFFICE
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THIS IS
ONE OF THE NEWER SECTIONS IN
THE OFFICE I WANT TO JUST GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND
ON WHAT THE SECTION. WAS SET
OUT TO DO. A SECTION WAS FORMED
BY ATTORNEY GENERAL THE SERRA
INTO TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. WE
REPRESENT A LICENSING AGENCIES
THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
IN IRAQ AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IN
CIVIL AND ADMINISTRATIVE
MATTERS WE ALSO WORK WITH
INFORMS ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. STATE WATER AND
REPRESENT THEM IN THEIR
CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES
WE ALSO PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO A
NUMBER OF STATE AGENCIES
INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS THE CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT UNIT. WE ALSO
ADVISE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL ON
MATTERS IMPACTING LEGAL
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS OPERATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA RECENTLY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SUPPORTED US.
HE ACTUALLY HE CONTINUES TO
SUPPORT A STRONG REGULATED
MARKET AND WITH THIS IN MIND
EIJI BUT SERRA RECENTLY SIGNED
ON TO SEVERAL LETTERS IN
SUPPORT OF FEDERAL LEGISLATION.
I NAMELY THE SAFE BANKING ACT
AND THE STATE'S ACT IN ADDITION
HE PROVIDED SUPPORT FOR COMMENT
FOR THE FDA TO ENGAGE IN
RESEARCH ON C. B. D. AND OTHER
CANNABIS RELATED PRODUCTS.
YOU'VE HEARD ALL ABOUT THE
REGULAR RATIONS SO I WON'T GO
INTO THAT EXCEPT TO SAY THAT
CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE REGULATION OF
CANNABIS CANNABIS PRODUCTS IN
CANNABIS SALES. NOW TO
REITERATE CALIFORNIA HAS SOME
OF THE MOST RIGOROUS STANDARDS
FOR TESTING CANNABIS AND
CANNABIS PRODUCTS THAT ARE SOLD
IN THE REGULATED MARKET PLACE
IN THIS STATE. UNFORTUNATELY WE
STILL HAVE A VERY LARGE ARMY.
THE ONLY CALL MARKET. AND THEY
SELL THEY CONTINUE TO SELL
PRODUCTS IN THE STATE THAT ARE
OF UNKNOWN ORIGIN AND HAVE NOT
BEEN TESTED. I AGAIN WILL NOT
REPEAT TO THE CDC INFORMATION
THAT YOU'VE HEARD SEVERAL
TIMES. EXCEPT TO SAY THAT WE
NEED TO KEEP IN MIND THAT THE
CDC HAS BEEN UNABLE TO LINK THE
OUTBREAK TO A SINGLE PRODUCT OR
SUBSTANCE. HOWEVER WE WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MOST OF THE
PATIENTS REPORTED A HISTORY OF
USING T. H. C. CONTAINING
PRODUCTS. A FEW ARE REPORTED
NICOTINE ONLY PRODUCTS BUT THE
CDC ALSO REPORTS ABOUT THE
PATIENTS REPORTED THAT THEY
DIDN'T PURCHASE THE SEAT TNC
PRODUCTS FROM LICENSED
REGULATED MARKET PLACES THEY
OBTAIN THEM FROM OTHER SOURCES
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN FRIENDS
FAMILY MEMBERS. NO ONE KNOWS
WHERE THEY CAME FROM. SO AS YOU
ALL KNOW PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
RESULTED IN THE REDUCTION OF
MANY. UP AND SAYS I WAS MAKING
THE FRACTIONS ARE MISDEMEANORS
SO WHEN IT COMES TO REGULATING
UNLICENSED MARKET PLACE. IT'S
BECOME A LITTLE DIFFICULT FOR
OUR PROSECUTORS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO PURSUE THESE
CASES. AS YOU ALSO KNOW OUT
SEVERAL SECTIONS OF THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE REDUCED CRIMES
TO INFRACTIONS AND
MISDEMEANORS. UP THERE REALLY
AREN'T TOO MANY FELONIES EXCEPT
MAYBE SALE TO MINORS IF YOU CAN
ATTACH A FELONY TO ANOTHER
OFFENSE FRAUD ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT. YOU HAVE A MORE WEIGHT
TO PURSUE A PROSECUTION. THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO INCLUDED IN MY
CURSOR A- BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE TWO SIX ZERO
THREE EIGHT WHICH ALLOW CIVIL
PENALTIES OF UP TO THREE TIMES
THE AMOUNT OF THE LICENSE FEE
FOR EACH VIOLATION OF
UNLICENSED COMMERCIAL ACTIVITY
AND MOST RECENTLY AS PART OF
THE TRAILER BILL YOU ADDED A
CODE SECTION BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE SECTION TWO
SIX ZERO THREE ONE. POINT FIVE
WHICH ALSO PERMITS A LICENSING
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE CITATIONS TO
LICENSED OR UNLICENSED
OPERATORS ARE THE CITATION CAN
INCLUDE IN ORDER OF ABATEMENT
OUTDOOR ADMINISTRATIVE FINES
NOT TO EXCEED FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER VIOLATION FOR A
LICENSEE AND THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER VIOLATION FOR AN
UNLICENSED PERSON. AGAIN EACH
DAY A VIOLATION CONSTITUTES A
SEPARATE VIOLATION. A BY RECENT
ESTIMATES 80% OF THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA REMAINS
UNLICENSED UNREGULATED. WE ARE
NOW TWENTY TWO MONTHS INTO
LICENSING. ARE THOSE BUSINESSES
WE CAN ARGUE THAT INTENDED TO
COME INTO THE LEGAL REGULATED
MARKET HAVE ALREADY DONE SO OR
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING SO
BY HAVING OBTAINED PROVISIONAL
LICENSE IS SUBMITTED ANNUAL
LICENSE APPLICATIONS AND OR
SUBMITTED APPLICATIONS TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. ARE BASED ON THE
VOLUME OF ILLEGAL BUSINESS IS
CONTINUING TO OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA ANY MEANINGFUL
ENFORCEMENT REQUIRE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES IN COORDINATION OF
EFFORTS. I'M IN THE PAST
SEVERAL WEEKS WE HAVE HEARD
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WHAT
WE'VE HEARD IS WHERE
ENFORCEMENT DOES TAKE PLACE IT
IS QUESTIONABLE AS TO WHAT
IMPACT IT IS HAVING DUE TO THE
LIMITED ABILITY OF PROSECUTORS
TO TAKE MEANINGFUL ACTION
AGAINST THOSE IN THE ILLEGAL
UNREGULATED MARKET PLACE. AGAIN
CURRENTLY VIOLATIONS OF THE
LAW. THAT ARE ONLY BASED ON
CAMPUS VIOLATIONS ARE
GENERALLY. INFRACTIONS ARE
MISDEMEANORS. FOREIGN I'M LEGAL
ON REGULATED BUSINESS RUNNING
POTENTIALLY THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS AS MR MAJORIS ALSO
INDICATED THOSE MINES MAY BE
VIEWED AS THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS AND MIGHT NOT HAVE
BEEN ANY IMPACT ON DETERRING
CONTINUED PARTICIPATION IN THE
ILLEGAL. UNREGULATED MARKET
PLACE. IN MANY INSTANCES RETAIL
POP UP SHOPS ARE SHUT DOWN ONE
DAY AND WE UP HERE THE NEXT DAY
SEVERAL DOORS AWAY. IN ONE
RECENT MEETING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT REPRESENTATIVES
THIS WAS DESCRIBES POINT WHAT
KAMAL. SO WHILE PROVIDING
LICENSING AGENCIES WITH
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS THERE REMAINS
A GAP FOR MEANINGFUL
ENFORCEMENT CRIMINAL AGAIN THE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES BEING
INFRACTIONS AND MISDEMEANORS
FOR UNLICENSED DOWN I'M WANT TO
FOCUS ON UNLICENSED ONLY. IT'S
NOT HAVING A FACT. THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SUPPORTS BOTH A STRONG
REGULATE ACCOUNT OF THIS MARKET
AND EFFORTS TO ENSURE THE
SUCCESS FOR THE LEGAL MARKET
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FURTHER DISCUSS HOW THIS CAN BE
DONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE GIVEN AND THEN AGAIN
IT WILL GET INTO A COMMON SING
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
JOINT COMMITTEE AND JUST AS A
REMINDER AT TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT WE STILL HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL. PANEL AS WELL AS A
PUBLIC COMPANY SO WITH FIRST
BEGIN WITH DOCTOR WOULD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO ALL OF YOU
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION AND I CAN SENSE.
THAT YOU ARE ALL SOMEWHAT
OVERWHELMED BY THE ENORMITY OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE. I
DID HERE MISS AGE ACTUALLY
TALKED YOU SAID THAT YOU WERE.
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH
MANUFACTURERS AND RETAILERS AND
SO ON I DIDN'T HEAR DELIVERIES
ARE YOU ENFORCING AGAINST
DELIVERY DRIVERS UNTIL AN
ILLICIT DELIVERY OPERATIONS AS
WELL. YEAH WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
RETAILERS WE. DELIVERY YES I
OPPOSE A HUGE NUMBER OF YEAH
LICENSE DELIVERIES AND THAT AND
I DO WONDER WHERE THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR PRODUCTS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO STORE FRONT TO TRACE
IT BACK TO. IN MANY CASES. WITH
REGARD TO THE AND I KNOW YOU
CAN'T TALK ABOUT COULD YOU
PUNCH THING AND SO I'M NOT
GOING THERE BUT IT DOES MAKE ME
WONDER HOW MANY OTHER
OPERATIONS ARE OUT THERE SO
WHEN YOU GUYS ARE SHUTTING DOWN
THE LIST OF OPERATIONS ARE YOU
TESTING IN THE PRODUCTS THAT
COME OUT OF THOSE STORES TO SEE
ARE THOSE PRODUCTS IN LINE WITH.
CURRENT STANDARDS I WOULD GUESS
THAT THEY'RE NOT AND WOOD I
KIND OF WELL I WOULD THINK LIKE
TO THINK NOT I KIND OF WONDER
HOW MANY MORE COULD SHE PUNCHES
ARE OUT THERE QUITE FRANKLY
WITH WITH THE VALUE OF PRODUCT
THAT MAY NOT PASS TESTING AND
NEEDING AN OUTLET TO RECOUP.
THEIR THE MONEY THAT GOES WITH
THAT SO. LITTLE FRUSTRATING
THAT WE DON'T HAVE MUCH IN THE
WAY OF ENFORCEMENT TOOLS IT
SOUNDS LIKE TO. OTHER THAN
CITATIONS AND MISDEMEANORS
RICHARD HARDLY EVEN A SLAP ON
THE WRIST IT FEELS LIKE. I'M
CERTAIN THAT WAS MORE OF AN
EDITORIAL COMMENT BUT IF YOU
HAVEN'T. OBVIOUSLY IF YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENT ON THAT. SO
DEPENDING ON THE YOU KNOW WE
GET MANY COMPLAINTS ON
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY AND NOW
ESPECIALLY WITH ALL THE MEDIA
SURROUNDING THE VAPING CRISIS
WE GET A LOT OF COMPLAINTS SO
WE WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND IF WE FEEL SOMETHING NEEDS
TO BE TESTED WE ARE WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM TO HAVE
THAT PRODUCT TESTED. WITH
REGARDS TO THOSE ARE. MISS
MADURO'S FROM CD TFA. SO AS WE
TALK ABOUT. THE TAXATION
TAXATION. THOSE ARE ALSO SORT
OF A SLAP ON THE WRIST AS WELL
I THOUGHT. I THOUGHT PEOPLE IN
GENERAL KIND OF FREIGHT. ABOUT
THE TAX COLLECTORS INFORMER SO.
I KNOW I AM I AM VERY CAREFUL
ABOUT MY RETURNS AND THINGS.
BUT I GOT THE IMPRESSION FEELS
LIKE. THAT MAYBE SOME PEOPLE
ARE NICE AND SOME IS INDUSTRIE
I THINK THAT'S RIGHT I TO HAVE
SOMEBODY THREATEN ME WITH A
MISDEMEANOR AS A- NERDY MIDDLE
AGED FELLOW WOULD BE. AFRAID
BUT. ALAS THOSE PEOPLE LEARNING
LOTS OF MONEY IN THE ILLEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET DON'T SEEM
AFRAID AND THAT IN THE TÁI
HERE TO THE VAPING IN MY MIND
IS THAT. YOU KNOW I WOULD. THE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE BEING SOLD
THAT ARE UNTAXED ARE ALSO
UNTESTED RIGHT AND THAT'S THE
REAL I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE.
FOR THAT HE'S GOT I THINK
THAT'S A THAT'S THE KEY CAN I
DO THINK. I IN MY MIND IT IS
BOTH THE CRIMINAL SANCTIONS BUT-
TO BRING A CRIMINAL CASE TAKE
SO LONG. AND IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT WHEN WE'RE- GOT
THOUSANDS OF THESE IN MY MIND
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IS THERE
NEEDS TO BE THERE NEED TO BE
CIVIL PENALTIES. OR TAX
PENALTIES. THAT ARE ALLOWED TO
BE PUT ON VERY QUICKLY AND IF
THEY'RE PUT ON AN AIR PEOPLE
CAN APPEAL BUT- I JUST. THANK
THAT EVEN GOING TO A FELONY THE
IS NOT GOING TO ADDRESS THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM BECAUSE IT
WILL TAKE SO LONG TO GET
THROUGH THE NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
OPERATORS THAT WE'RE SEEING OUT
THERE WE ARE TRYING ALL SORTS
OF WAYS IN THE TAX FROM
INCLUDING ASSESSING TAXES AND
TELLING PEOPLE YOU KNOW WE'VE
YOU WON'T GIVE US YOUR RECORDS
WE'VE DETERMINED THAT YOU OF
THE STATE OF MILLION AND A HALF
DOLLARS AND- WE'LL- TAKE YOUR
HOUSE AND ALL OF YOUR
POSSESSIONS AND EVERYTHING
ELSE. BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE. BEST
WEIGHT I MEAN A THEY DO THE
MONEY TO THE STATE BUT WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE BEST WAY
TO PROCEED IS AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT. WHAT WE'VE ALWAYS DONE.
IS WHAT. WILL WORK IN THIS
SITUATION. AS I THINK YOU HAVE
A PRETTY BIG TOOL BELT BUT NOT
A LOT OF TOOLS. THAT'S ONE WAY
TO PUT IT. THINKING ALONG ALONG
THESE LINES IS. AND THIS IS
MORE A QUESTION FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
BECAUSE AND MAKING THIS TO
VAPING WHICH IS REALLY WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT BUT THIS IS
BRINGING UP SOME OTHER ISSUES
THAT ARE OF CONCERN I THINK THE
CHAIRMAN GRAY AND I WERE
COMMENTING TO GET TOGETHER
TWENTY TWO MONTHS INTO THIS AND
WE HAVE 80% OF THE MARKET
UNLICENSED. IS PRETTY APPALLING
AND IT'S ROOM IN IT I WOULD
IMAGINE FOR THOSE PEOPLE IN THE
LICENSE MARKET IT'S PRETTY IT'S
PRETTY FRUSTRATING EXTREMELY
FRUSTRATING TO KNOW THAT
THEY'RE PLAYING BY THE RULES
AND WE'VE GOT THIS AND I
UNDERSTAND IT AND IT FEELS LIKE
ALL OF YOU HAVE TOOL BELTS AND
NOT ENOUGH TOOLS AND NONE OF
RESOURCES IT'S A BY THE TOOLS.
AND SO ON SO IT IS A CHALLENGE
SO I WANT TO ASK A QUESTION AND
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER AND SO
IT BUT I AM CURIOUS AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT HOW THIS EQUATES IN
THE REST OF THE WORLD SOMEONE
TO ASK THE SAME QUESTION. IF WE
WERE TO FIND THAT THERE WASAN
ENTITY OR SOMEONE WHO WAS
ADDING SOMETHING TO THE VAPING
LIQUIDS THAT WAS CAUSING THIS
OUTBREAK. THAT HAS CAUSED GREAT
BODILY HARM. AND DEATH IN SOME
CASES. WE'VE TO DECRIMINALIZE
SO MUCH AROUND CANNABIS. WHAT
WHAT THE RECORDS FOR THE H. E.
B. WITH THEIR HOW WOULD YOU
PROSECUTE THAT CASE OR WOULD
YOU BE ABLE TO PROSECUTE IT
BASED ON. WHAT IN THE ROLE OF
THE LAWS UNDER PROP SIXTY FOUR.
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER I'M
JUST AYE BUT I'M CURIOUS. THE
REASON I SAY THAT I WOULD BET
THAT IF YOU WERE GROWING
LETTUCE OR SPINACH SOMEWHERE.
AND YOU DID SOMETHING IN THE
ADDED SOMETHING THERE. AND
PEOPLE DIED ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES THE YOU'D BE PRETTY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT AND A
WHOLE NUMBER WAYS SO. IS THIS
INDUSTRY GOING TO BE THIS HAVE
THE SAME LEVEL OF
RESPONSIBILITY AS THE LETTUCE
INDUSTRY. OR THE SPANISH
INDUSTRY. OR TYLENOL OR
ANYTHING ELSE OUT THERE BUT
BECAUSE IT ADDED A PRODUCT TO
SOMETHING THE CAUSE GREAT
BODILY HARM AND DEATH. WELL AS
I INDICATED IF YOU CAN ATTACH A
CANNABIS VIOLATION TO SOMETHING
ELSE CAN IT BECOMES A FELONY SO
I THINK IN THE CASE OF A DEATH
YOU CAN ATTACH IT TO A
DIFFERENT LAW THAT WOULD
CREATE. A FELONY VIOLATION. IT
WOULD JUST BE A YOU KNOW UP A
MANUFACTURING CANNABIS
VIOLATION ANYMORE IT WOULD BE
SOMETHING MORE THAN THAT.
THOUGH IT WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
SOMEBODY IS SOME AT. SOME
ENTITIES OR WHATEVER WERE FOUND
TO BE ADDING SOMETHING THAT
BECAUSE THIS. WHETHER KNOWINGLY
OR UNKNOWINGLY I MEAN CREATING
A PUBLIC HEALTH HAZARD. WELL I
THINK YOU WOULD DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN KNOWINGLY OR
UNKNOWINGLY ISN'T ONE OF THEM.
OBVIOUSLY NO THERE ATTY RIGHT
OUT OF THE CONSEQUENCES. YEAH
THERE WOULD BE CONSEQUENCES
ABSOLUTELY. OKAY JUST LIKE IT
WOULD BE FOR LETTUCE GROWERS.
WELL OR OR YOU KNOW AT A
CULTIVATOR WHO USES SAT DEADLY
PESTICIDES AND CULTIVATION IN A
TIE RETURN VITAL MENTAL HARM
OR- SOME OTHER FELONY CRIME AND
PURSUANT BOKEH OUR OUR IS THE
ARE THERE CASES BEING PURSUED
WERE WITH CULTIVATORS HERE
USING. BANNED PESTICIDES AND
THAT HAVE BEEN CAUGHT. BECAUSE
THEY GET NOW YOU'VE LINKED
THOSE THINGS ARE THOSE CAN
OTHER CASES ACTUALLY BEING.
BEING PROSECUTED NOW OR OR.
CHARGED OR OR THOSE
MISDEMEANORS. WELL MY OFFICE IS
REVIEWING SEVERAL CASES I
REALLY CAN'T COMMENT ON WHAT WE
WILL END UP CHARGING. BUT WE
ARE AS I SAID WE DO OUR WORK IN
CONJUNCTION WITH STATE WATER
AND DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE. AND BECAUSE THOSE ARE
ENVIRONMENTAL THOSE ARE
DIFFERENT LOTS OF PEOPLE HAVE
TO CORRECT THEY HAVE ABOUT
WATER CODES YOU CAN ATTACH.
OKAY I THANK YOU. IT'S A GREAT.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN LOW. I WILL
DO MY BEST TO CONDENSE SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS I MAY PROVIDE
SOME QUESTIONS TO THE PANEL IN
WRITING POST COMMITTEE BECAUSE-
THERE'S A LOT I WANT TO GET
INTO AND I KNOW. IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME ALL TRY. GET
TO THE KEY POINTS AS I SEE
THEM. I'M A START OVER HERE
WITH THE PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
DURING THE PROCESS OF
CONSTRUCTING A BE SIXTEEN
THIRTY NINE WHICH LEGISLATION
MYSELF AND SEVERAL MY
COLLEAGUES AND SERVICE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WORKED ON. WE
BROUGHT IN THE PART OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WE BROUGHT IN A. B. C.
AND TALKED ABOUT WHAT STING
OPERATIONS ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES WERE CURRENT. WHEN
THE A. B. C. CAME IN IT WAS
SUCH A 354-040-5000 STING
OPERATIONS ERRATICALLY INVOLVED
ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN NGUYEN DPH
CAME IN. THEY SAID WE DON'T
KNOW. AND THEY TOLD ME ALL WORK
WE'RE ISSUING GRANTS TO LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT ASKED HOW MUCH
MONEY WAS IT DIDN'T SEEM
SIGNIFICANT MY IMPRESSION. BUT
I'M LEFT FOR THIS PART PUBLIC
HEALTH IS NOT DOING MUCH FOR
ENFORCEMENT THEIR TOBACCO
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THE
FRANKLY THE GRANTS WERE GIVEN
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT VERY IN
TASTING FOR LOCAL AW
ENFORCEMENT TO GET INVOLVED IN.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO MY
IMPRESSION. WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND VISITS TO RETAILERS
EVERY YEAR OF THOSE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE HAVE THREE
HUNDRED FORTY FIRST TIME
VIOLATIONS WHICH ENDED UP IN
SUSPENSION OF LICENSE AS TEN
SECOND TIME VIOLATORS AND ONE
THIRD TIME BY LATER ON AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WE REALLY DO MORE
AND OF THE TRAINING OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OF WHAT. THEY WOULD
DO I DON'T HAVE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT. SPECIFICALLY THE
NUMBER OF LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
VISITS BUT I CAN TRY AND GET
THAT FOR YOU. WELL CERTAINLY I
THINK WE NEED IF YOU DON'T NEED
TO FIND OUT AND WE NEED TO GIVE
YOU THE TOOLS YOU THE FINE AND
CONDUCT MORE STING OPERATIONS
BECAUSE IT'S- AGAIN WE DON'T
NEED TO REINVENT THE WHEEL WE
KNOW THAT WHAT WE DO IN THE
AREA ABOUT COST CONTROL
EFFECTIVE. LAW ENFORCEMENT
KNOWS HOW TO DO THIS I THINK
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS THAT WE
HAVE THE ENFORCEMENT ANY NON
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. BUT
NONETHELESS. I THINK WE MAKES
AN IMPROVEMENT THERE BUT I'LL
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU AND
I'D LIKE SOME FEEDBACK WHEN I
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATION AND-
WHICH IS WERE TAKING. SECONDLY.
ACTUALLY YOU MAY HAVE ANSWERED
HOW MANY. LICENSES WERE RIVER
REMOVED THERE WERE NO LICENSES
REMOVE THERE IS ONE THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN REMOVED EXCEPT THAT
THE BUSINESS SHOT DOWN SO IT
WAS NO LICENSES REMOVED RIGHT.
OKAY FROM THE STATE LEVEL I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT THE LOCAL
LEVEL UNDERSTOOD I'M GONNA MOVE
ON NOW TO APPEAR OF CANNABIS
CONTROL. I WANT TO BEGIN WITH
THE FLAVOR ISSUE. I RECENTLY
VISITED DISPENSARY TO TAKE A
LOOK AT. A DISPATCHER FROM A
FLAVOR VIEWPOINT. AND. I'M A GO
AHEAD AND READ YOU SOME OF THE
FLAVORS THAT WERE DISPLAYED ON
THE BOARD OF MARIJUANA BANANA
SPLIT BLUEBERRY MILKSHAKE
WEDDING CAKE ICE CREAM CAKE.
KEY LIME PIE. PUNCH IT BETTER
BREAST. SO I'M CURIOUS AS TO
YOUR PERSPECTIVE GIVEN THAT
FLAVORS ARE A MAJOR CONCERN FOR
SOME MY COLLEAGUES AS IT
RELATES TO E. CIGARETTES.
WHAT'S THE PERSPECTIVE ON THESE
FLAVORS IF EASTER FLAVORS ARE
DRIVING TEENAGE CONSUMPTION AND
AN UNDERAGE CONSUMPTION THAT I
WOULD ASSUME. THAT IS TRUE WITH
MARIJUANA BUT ARE THERE NO
RESTRICTIONS. SO EIGHT A LOT OF
THOSE COULD BE ALSO STRAINED
NAMES THAT THEY USE IT'S NOT
ALWAYS NECESSARILY FLAVORS ON
THE DO YOU HAVE A CANNABIS
TERPENES. BUT MOST THE TIME
WHAT WE SEE THOSE ARE STRAIN
NAMES AND SO WE DO LOOK AT
ESPECIALLY FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH SIDE. YOU KNOW
ANY PACKAGING CAN'T BE
ATTRACTED TO CHILDREN ON THE
CAN ADVERTISE TO CHILDREN BUT
FOR MOST OF THESE THOSE WOULD
BE CANNABIS FLOWER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND SO.
RESTRICTIONS ON PACKAGING AGAIN
WOULD BE STILL CAN'T BE
ATTRACTED TO CHILDREN. NOW
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE NAMES
REPRESENT A FLAVOR OR A STRAIN
I THINK AS FAR AS WE TALK ABOUT
MARKETING THE NAME OF A PRODUCT
IS IN FACT MARKETING. AND DOES
CERTAINLY AT LEAST STRIK ME AT
FIRST BLUSH AND I'M GONNA TRY
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THIS AS
DIRECTED TOWARDS YOUNG PEOPLE
OR PERHAPS. PERHAPS NOT MAYBE
THE FLAVORS AREN'T THE KEY
ISSUE I'M SURE THEY OPEN THAT
WE'VE BEEN. DEBATING THAT ALL
YEAR LONG. HOW MANY. CANNABIS
LICENSE HAVE BEEN. SUSPENDED OR
REMOVED THIS PAST TWENTY TWO
MONTHS. SO MOST OF OUR LICENSES
AT THE BUREAU ARE PROVISIONAL
LICENSES SO WE ISSUE WE ISSUE A
VARIETY OF DISCIPLINARY WE CAN
GIVE AND IF WE GO INTO A RETAIL
INSPECTION AND WE FIND
VIOLATIONS WE CAN ISSUE A
NOTICE TO COMPLY WE CAN ALSO
SUSPEND OR WE CAN ALSO REVOKE.
WE WE'VE GOT WE'VE DONE SOME
SUSPENSIONS LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
FOR A SALES TO MINOR THAT WE
HAD WITH THE LIVERY OF A
LICENSED A RETAILER MOST OF THE
TIME WE ARE TRYING TO GET OUR
RETAILERS OR ANY OF OUR
LICENSEES TO COMPLY WITH OUR
REGULATIONS IF THERE'S A PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE THEN WE WILL
REVOKE THE LICENSE OR IN SOME
CASES AND SPLIT LICENSEE WILL
CANCEL THEIR LICENSE OR- OF
WHAT NOT SO WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
OF THOSE I DON'T HAVE THE
EXACT. NUMBERS BUT I CAN
CERTAINLY PROVIDE THOSE TO YOU.
THANK YOU AND HOW MANY. STING
OPERATIONS HAVE BEEN CONDUCTED
ON UNDER AGE PURCHASES. SO
THAT'S HANDLED BY THE SWORN LAW
ENFORCEMENT PART OF THE BUREAU
UNDER THE CANVAS ENFORCEMENT
UNIT AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND I CAN
CERTAINLY. GET THOSE FOR YOU TO
AS WELL. OKAY WELL WAIT FOR
THOSE. ANSWERS AND I'LL HAVE
SOME FOLLOW UP. DEPART OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION. I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY AS A- YOUNG
STAFF LEGISLATIVE STAFFERS IN
THIS BUILDING TO WORK ON THE
TAX STAMP PROGRAM WORKING WITH
DAN GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONSHIP
OR DRUM PORTENT AND MY
UNDERSTANDING I HAVE A FALL
THAT PROGRAM THE YEARS IS THAT
IT'S BEEN A PRETTY EFFECTIVE IN
ADDRESSING BLACK MARKET SALES
OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS AND I WANT
TO GET YOUR TAKE ON. I THINK IT
HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE IN IN
CIGARETTES WHICH IS ALSO
APPLIES TO IN ADDRESSING BLACK
MARKET SALES THAT'S. THE CARD
TAKES ME TO MY NEXT QUESTION
WHICH IS. IN A IN ARBIL THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING OUR WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO. MOVE IN THE
DIRECTION OF A TAX STAMP
PROGRAM FOR VAPING PRODUCTS OR
E. CIGARETTE PRODUCTS KNOWING
THAT IT WAS EFFECTIVE IN DEAL
WITH THE BLACK MARKET CRUCIAL
BACK OR ONE WOULD ASSUME WE
COULD ACCOMPLISH THE SAME THING
WITH THE CIGARETTES. DO YOU SEE
WHAT HURDLES CHALLENGES TOOLS
ARE NEEDED IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT WELL I DON'T
THINK WE COULD JUST SORT OF
LIFT AND SHIFT WITH THE SAME
TAX STAMPING REGIMEN THAT WE
HAVE THEIR INTO VAPING FOR A
FEW REASONS ONE. CIGARETTES ARE
ALL TAX TO TWO DOLLARS AND
EIGHTY SEVEN CENTS PER PACK THE
TAX ON OTHER TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
IS BASED ON THIS WHOLESALE COST
CALCULATION SO IT'S NOT YOU
COULDN'T SELL JUST A SINGLE
VALUE STAMP AND SAY THAT THAT'S
YOUR STAMP FOR EVERY PRODUCT IF
YOU WANTED TO BE AN ACTUAL TAX
STAMP. THE OTHER ISSUE IS THAT
THE PACKAGING ON THESE OTHER
PRODUCTS THE SIZE THE NUMBER OF
ITEMS CONTAINED IS ALSO NOT THE
SAME WITH CIGARETTES EVERY
SINGLE PACKAGE TWENTY
CIGARETTES. AND THERE ARE
MACHINES THAT ARE DEVELOPED
THAT OPEN THE- BOXES AND STAMP
EVERYTHING. AND IT BECOMES VERY
EFFICIENT. THAT SAID. THE IN MY
MIND IS THAT ONE OF THE MAJOR
THINGS THAT COULD BE ADDRESSED
YEAR IS TRACING WHERE THE
PRODUCTS CAME FROM AND ENSURING
THAT ITS TAX PAID AND INSURING
THAT IT'S NOT A COUNTERFEIT
PRODUCT AND THOSE COULD BE
ACHIEVED WITH WITH A STAMP THAT
IS REQUIRED THAT IS NOT
NECESSARILY A STAMP THAT THE
DISTRIBUTOR BUYS FROM US FOR A
CERTAIN TAX AMOUNT ALTHOUGH
THAT'S POSSIBLE BUT YOU WOULD
HAVE TO HAVE VARYING VALUES SO
IT IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMPLICATED BUT I DO THINK AND
THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S ASKED US TO LOOK
AT THAT WILL BE REPORTING OUT
TO HIM. LATER THIS MONTH ON
THAT THAT IT'S POSSIBLE TO
DESIGN A SYSTEM THAT WOULD
ACCOMPLISH THAT I WILL ALSO SAY
THAT I BELIEVE. THAT INITIAL
GETTING THE CIGARETTE TAX TAX
STEP UP AND RUNNING TOOK I
THINK THREE YEARS. WHICH IS A
LONG TIME I'D ALSO LIKE TO COME
UP WITH SOMETHING THAT WE COULD
DO MORE QUICKLY. THE DOES THE
SAME ISSUES WE WERE STRUGGLING
WITH AN A. B. SIXTEEN THIRD I
WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO. FAST TRACKED THE- THE
TAXPAYER PROGRAM AS RELATES
ALTHOUGH FAR ENOUGH THE ISSUE.
THAT STALLED ARE LEGISLATION IN
THE STATE SENATE THIS YEAR. IT
WAS IN FACT THE ISSUE YOU
RAISED ON EQUIVALENCY. AND I
RELEASE LANGUAGE IN EARLY
AUGUST. THAT ATTEMPTED TO
CREATE A MORE QUIBBLING TAX
BETWEEN TRADITIONAL TRACKING
SIX THAT WE WERE GOING TO PUT
INTO A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE.
WHEN THE SENATE FOUND OUT ABOUT
THAT THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
REFUSED TO GRANT US A HEARING.
ON THE LEGISLATION IS THEY
DON'T WANT TO ADDRESS A ATTACKS
AT THIS TIME. BUT WILL BE
COMING BACK FIRST THING IN THE
YEAR TWO STILL WORK ON THAT
ISSUE AND I'M TO PROVIDE. YOU
THE LANGUAGE THAT WE HAVE TO
GET YOUR FEEDBACK. AND ALSO
LIKE. SOME ADDITIONAL FEEDBACK
ON THE ISSUES YOU RAISED ABOUT
A NON COMPLIANCE WITH TAXES AND
HOW WE MIGHT ASSIST IN AMPING
UP THE PENALTIES ARE NO
CHAIRMAN WOULD RAISE THAT AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE'D ALL
LIKE TO. HAVE SOME POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS ON YOU KNOW THAT
CERTAINLY CAN BE A VERY
EFFECTIVE. METHOD OF ADDRESSING
BLACK MARKET ACTIVITIES. I WILL
BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU ANY.
ASSISTANCE WE CAN. TAKE A LOOK
AT THE EQUIPMENTS ATTACKS THAT
I PROPOSED IN AUGUST AND SEE IF
SEE IF THAT MEETS. THE MARK YES
OKAY. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THE THING THAT CONCERNS ME THE
MOST I I'VE GOT ABOUT SIX
QUESTIONS HERE BUT THE THING
THAT YOU RAISED ON THE
INCONSISTENCIES IT YOU KNOW A
IN THE WAY RETRIEVES DIFFERENT
PRODUCTS AND THE AND THE
PENALTIES AND TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO YOU TO ENFORCE RIGHT AND HOW
THAT WAS A AS I UNDERSTOOD IT.
MADE FURTHER DIFFICULT BY SOME
OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORMS
THAT THIS BODY IN THE STATE
HAVE ENACTED IN THE PAST YOU
KNOW DECADE. ARM IS AN ACCURATE
DEPICTION OF WHAT YOU SAID. YES
EXCELLENT. SO I'D LIKE TO SEE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
DOJ AND FROM OUR TRADE GENERAL
ON. WHAT STEPS THE LEGISLATURE
CAN TAKE TO GIVE YOU THOSE
TOOLS SO AS TO HAVE PROPER
ENFORCEMENT I THINK MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WILL BE INTERESTED
IN THAT AS WELL. WITH THAT ARE.
I WILL DO MY FOLLOW UP WITH ALL
OF YOU AND PROVIDE YOU THE
DRAFT LANGUAGE THAT WE HAVE
PREPARED THAT'S GOING TO BE A
CONSISTENT APPROACH TO VAPING
TOBACCO AND MARIJUANA. AS WELL
AS ENFORCEMENT YEAH I THINK I
THINK WE HAVE THE KNOW HOW YOU
MAY NOT ALL HAVE ALL THE TOOLS
YOU NEED BUT WE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT THOSE TOOLS THAT ARE
MISSING ARE AND THEN WE NEED TO
GET A CONSISTENT. APPROACH TO
ALL OF THESE PRODUCTS BECAUSE
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW IS. YOU
KNOW THERE'S CERTAIN
LEGISLATORS. IN THIS BUILDING
WHO WERE. HI IT WITH ONE HAND
BANNING FLAVORED TOBACCO AND
WITH ANOTHER HAND ENCOURAGING
US TO SMOKE MARIJUANA AND
MOVING VEHICLES WHAT WE NEED TO
GET A MORE CONSISTENT POLICY
HERE THERE'S SOME REAL
INTELLECTUAL DISHONESTY WITH
WHICH WE'RE DOING IN THIS AREA
AND I THINK WE NEED YOUR
ASSISTANCE AND I THINK A LOT OF
ISSUES HAVE BEEN RAISED HERE
TODAY. THE DON'T MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE AND NOT WE NEED TO GET ON
THE SAME PAGE SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY ALTERNATE BACK
TO GERMAN Là THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IT'S GREAT AND NEXT UP AND
MISTER MCCARTY HELD BY MISTER
COOPER. I THINK IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME I PREFER GOING TO THE
NEXT PANEL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER GOV GREAT THANK VERY
MUCH PHYSICAL. I AGREE WITH
MISTER CHRIS BODIES IT
CONSISTENT AT BEING
INCONSISTENT REALLY THE BILL IS
MEAN NOTHING SO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE MISDEMEANOR FIVE
THOUSAND ARE FINE THAT'S THE
SAME WITH SOME OF BREAKING A
WINDOW SOMEONE'S WIND OR DO A
LOT JOB IT'S A MISDEMEANOR NO
ONE'S GOING TO JAIL COUNTY JAIL
IT'S BEEN A TIME FOR
MISDEMEANOR BUT TIMES PLEA
BARGAINING COURT. THE FINAL BE
A THOUSAND DOLLARS A FIVE OR
DOLLARS THAT'S REAL THAT'S REAL
REALITY SOUL WHY NOT DO IT I
MEAN YOU'VE A LOT OF GOOD
BUSINESSES THAT ARE FOLLOWING
THE LAW AND THAT ARE PREDICTED
BUSINESSES WE HAVE THAT THAT
ELEMENT TO GO DEAL WITH AND
JUST LIKE BUT COULD SHE PUNCH
WE HAD ONE FOOT IN THE LEGAL
AND ONE FROM THE BLACK MARKET.
YEAH WE TRY TO DO WITH ALL THE
TIME WE ARE 60% OF MARIJUANA
CALIFORNIA GOES OUT OF STATE
GROW HOUSES SACRAMENTO'S GROW
EL CENTRAL IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY SO WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S
FRUSTRATING FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
THEY'LL DO A POWER SURGE WERE
BECAUSE OF POWER USAGE HIT THE
HOUSE DO WITH ELECTRICITY
WHERE'S. MOTOR P. JEANNIE WILL.
AND THE LEAVE THE MARIJUANA IN
THE HOUSE. SEE THE ONE THOUSAND
SOUTH THE PLAN THROUGHOUT
THEIR- LIVES PLANS MAKE IT BACK
IN THE BLACK MARKET. SO HOW DO
WE CHANGE THAT. I HAD A BILL
AND SEVENTEEN. THAT WOULD
ADDRESS THIS. IT DID WITH THE
CIVIL FUNDING FOR THE STATE
AGENCIES. CAN HELP THESE
DEVELOP LEGITIMATE CANNABIS
BUSINESSES. THAT BILL. WAS
GONNA DIE IN PUBLIC SAFETY.
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET ANY THESE
BILLS OUT OF PEOPLE TAKING
EITHER HOUSE. THAT'S REALLY
WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO. AND IT
IS CRAZY SOME OF THINGS THAT GO
ON WITH THIS. IT'S A BIG ISSUE.
SO WE SHOULDN'T FEEL THE BABY
OUT WITH THE BATH WATER. BUT
HOW WE DO IT. THESE FOLKS
THROUGH THE BLACK MARKET. YOU
FIND THEM AND PUNISH THEM.
BECAUSE IT LASSEN MINISTRATIONS
THAT HEY WE'RE NOT SIGNING ANY
LAW THAT PUTS ANYBODY IN JAIL
OR PRISON. GOT A NEW GOVERNOR.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT HIM AND I
WANT THANK HIM FOR LIKE HIS
TEAM TO COME OUT HERE. AND
RIVER LAW ENFORCEMENT TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW THEY CAN SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM HOW CAN HOW TO
ATTACK IT SO HE'S- HE'S BEEN
COLLABORATIVE AND. HEALTHY WILL
SEEM MORE BIG THINGS IN THE
GOVERNOR. MORNING LISTEN
CITATIONS THEY DON'T CARE YOU
MAKING SO MUCH MONEY. I'M
TALKING THE BLACK MARKET LEGAL
MARK A BLACK MARKET. IN THE
BUSINESS TO MAKE MONEY. BY
SELLING. PRODUCT IN THE MORE
YOU MAKE THE MORE YOU GO SO
IT'S WORTH IT FOR THE PENALTY
THERE'S NOTHING. IT'S LIKE NO
HARM NO FOUL. WANNA KEEP GOING
YOU'RE MAKING TENS OF THOUSAND
DOLLARS. EVERY DAY WHY WOULD
YOU STOP THAT. BUT THIS
LEGISLATURE. RIGHT NOW THERE'S
NO PENALTIES FOR ANYTHING. THEY
DON'T WANT TO ASSN FORFEITURE.
AND SO THESE GUYS ARE MAKING
BIG BIG MONEY. AND YOU HAVE TO
USE ASSET FORFEITURE LESS THIS
DOESN'T WANT TO DO THAT. SO HOW
DO WE CHANGE THAT. HOW DO WE
GET IT DONE. HOPEFULLY THEY
DEAL COME OUT AND- AND HELP
WITH SOME OF THAT BUT I DO HAVE
A QUESTION. FOR MR MADERO'S. ON
THE- WE SELL TO A WITH THE
ISSUES. EXCUSE ME TRUE. AS FAR
AS THE OPEN THEY'VE SYSTEM THAT
GOES UNTAXED. HOW HOW DO WE
CHANGE THAT. WELL FOR THE. NON
TOBACCO ELEMENT OF THE VEIL I.
ONE COULD CHANGE THE DEFINITION
OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS TO INCLUDE
THAT THOSE OTHER LIQUIDS OR IF
YOU WENT TO NICOTINE BASED TAX
THAN WHATEVER THE NICOTINE CAN.
PORTION IS WOULD BE TAXED AT
PRESUMABLY A FAIRLY ROBUST RATE
AND SO IF YOU MIXED IT IT
WOULDN'T MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE
BECAUSE YOU'RE JUST TAXING THAT
NICOTINE PORTION BUT NOT AT THE
SAME CALCULATION NUMBER USING
CURRENTLY IN FROM IS A JACKSON
YOUR OPINION HOW BAD IS IT KILL
THIS BLACK MARKET IMPACTING
LEGITIMATE. CANNABIS BUSINESS.
WELL IT'S PROBABLY THE
EXCELLENT NUMBER ONE COMPLAINT
THAT WE GET THE COMPLAINTS
COMING INTO THE BUREAU IS THE
LICENSE MARKET AND HOW IT'S
DIRECTLY COMPETING WITH OUR
LICENSEES AND I THINK. WE ALL
AGREE WITH YOU THAT ENFORCEMENT
IS. A TOP PRIORITY AND WE ALL
WORK TOGETHER VERY WELL TO
COMBAT THAT AND PARTNER
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE WERE
ATTACKING THE LEGAL MARKET BUT-
IT THERE THERE THERE IT IS VERY
PREVALENT HERE DO YOU HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES. I THINK
BETWEEN ALL OF US WORKING
TOGETHER AS A STATE WE HAVE WE
DO HAVE SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCES I
THINK WE'RE STILL LEARNING THE
SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM AND AGAIN
WE FEEL IT'S A TOP PRIORITY ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU FOR. ALL
OF US COLLABORATE AND IT'S NOT
JUST THE PEOPLE AT THIS TABLE
IT'S WITH US CDFA AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS BEING HUGE WITH
ASSISTING US WITH SOME OF
THESE. ON YOU KNOW SERVING THE
SEARCH WARRANTS AND- BUT WHAT
ABOUT YOUR RESOURCES AT BCC. A
WE HAVE RESOURCES YOU KNOW
WE'RE STILL FILLED SUFFICIENT.
WE'RE STILL BUILDING OUR OUR
STRUCTURE SO. OKAY SHOT THERE
I'VE NEVER HEARD IN THE
DEPARTMENT HEAD IN MY FIVE
YEARS HERE CONFORMS. IN SAY NO
WITHOUT SEVERE RESOURCES
BECAUSE WE KNOW THEIR BOSSES SO
I GET THIS YOU DON'T WANT TO
DIS YOUR BOSS LIKE I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU WANT TO BE. WILL BE
POLITICALLY CORRECT BUT THAT'S
A BIG ISSUE AND I'LL BE OFF
WITH ONE THING. THE STATE. THE
PAY SUCKS SO WHEN GOVERNOR
BROWN GOT IT BE ANY PROGRESS
CLOCKING FOR SMITH THERE'S A
LOT OF EXPERTISE HERE THAT IS
GONE THAT'S BEEN GONE THERE'S
NO EXPERTISE WITH THAT. SO NOR
**** NOT SOMETHING YOU LEARN
OVERNIGHT AS FIFTEEN YEARS. SO
THIS LONGTIME DEVELOP EXPERTISE
SO MOST FOLKS FROM LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT HAVE THAT
EXPERTISE SO THE STATE IT'S
TOUGH TO DO THAT. THE PAY
SUCKS. IN WITH PEPPER YOU KNOW
IT'S IS VERY DIFFERENT AS THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES SO THAT'S
THE TOUGH PART YOU DEAL WITH
IT'S FINE THE FOLKS THAT ARE
CAPABLE THAT CAN DO IT SO. TO
ME IT GOES BACK TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TELL THOSE FOLKS
BEING ABLE PART OF THIS TO DEAL
WITH THIS HAVE THE EXPERTISE
THAT NEED THE FUNDING THERE. TO
MAKE THESE INVESTIGATIONS AND
DO THEM. WE'VE GOT THOUSANDS OF
ILLEGAL. STOREFRONTS LA WITH
THE RIGHT RESOURCES THEY CAN DO
IT. THAT ALSO CHANGING IT ON
THE JUST WHEN YOU GET A
MARIJUANA ARE YOU READY TO
MARIJUANA. WHATEVER FLOWER
WHATEVER THEY CALL IT. DUE TO
STRUCTURE. RIGHT AWAY. AS
REASON LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
CANNABIS OUR FLOWER WHATEVER.
IS BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO STORE
IT. AND YOU GET THOUSANDS OF
PLACES TO OUR WAREHOUSE FOR A
YEAR OR SIX MONTHS WHATEVER IT.
IS NOT FEASIBLE AS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND TAKE IT. VERSUS
HAVING AN IMMEDIATE DESTRUCTION
ORDER. YOU DESTROY THAT IN ALL
THE IMPLEMENTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT. IF YOU'VE GOT A DOCTOR'S
NOTE THAT WOULD LEAVE YOUR
ELEVEN PLANTS. WE'RE TAKING
EVERYTHING ELSE. SO IT IT'S GOT
A CHANGE THAT. UNTIL THIS BODY.
GETS OFFICE BUT. NOTHING'S
GONNA CHANGE THIS WHATSOEVER HE
STARTS THE LEGISLATURE AND WE
CAN'T GET A HIT BILL FOR
HEARING. THE DAM COMMITTEE
THAT'S THE PROBLEM. THAT IS A
PROBLEM YOU HAVE GREAT BILLS
THAT COME THROUGH THAT A
REASONABLE NOT CRAZY STUFF. BUT
THEY DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT SO
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
IN THE COMMITTEE SO. THAT'S
REALLY WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO.
YOU KNOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER COOPER. A DOCTOR WOULD.
YEAH JUST REALLY BE THIS WAS A
THANK YOU I KNOW I FEEL LIKE
YOU. YOU YOU KNOW I'VE I SOUND
HARSH AYE AYE AYE BUT I'M
REALLY. APPRECIATE THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING I FEEL LIKE YOU
PROBABLY FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
SWIMMING UPSTREAM ALL THE TIME
AND- AND YOU KNOW WE GAVE. WE
GAVE THE INDUSTRY TOOLS TO
BECOME INTO COMPLIANCE. WE GAVE
TIME FOR PEOPLE TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE AND IT'S FRUSTRATING
THAT 80% OF THE- THE INDUSTRY
HAS CHOSEN NOT TO DO THAT. AND
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE TOOLS TO
ENFORCE AGAINST THAT. IN A IN
IN IN A MORE EXPEDITIOUS WAY
MAYBE THAT'S THE RIGHT WAY TO
SAY IT. I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
BUT IT FEELS LIKE IT FEELS
LIKE. IT'S LIKE WELCOME ALL.
PROBABLY IN IN SOME PLACES AND-
AND YOU KNOW IT'S UNFAIR TO THE
FOLKS THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH
ALL THE HOOPS AND TO DO IT
RIGHT. SO I THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING YOU YOU ALL ARE
DOING. AND THE BEFORE I GET IN
THE ANY OF FINAL CLOSING
COMMITTED TO. ANY OF THE FIVE
OF YOU WISH TO. SHARE ANY
OBSERVATIONS OUR RESPONSES TO
ANY OF THE DIALOGUE THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY MADE ON THIS DICE.
SEEN ON NO OKAY. I ALSO WANT TO
ECHO THOSE COMMENTS IN THE DEEP
APPRECIATION AS A DOCTOR WOULD
AND NUMBER OF MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE WORK THAT YOU ARE DOING.
PLEASE INTERPRET ARE COMMON TO
SAYING THAT WE WANT TO BEST
UNDERSTAND HOW TO BEST EMPOWER
AND EQUIP YOU WITH THE TOOLS
NECESSARY IN THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY. TO BE TO DO THE JOBS
THAT YOU KNOW IS IMPORTANT TO
DO FOR THE LARGEST REGULATED
MARKET IN THE WORLD ARGUABLY. A
SIMILE ALONG THOSE LINES IT'S
CLEAR THAT YOU OF ALL STATED
SOME DEFICIENCIES IN THE AREAS
OF OPPORTUNITY AND THE LOST
OPPORTUNITIES. THAT YOU'VE HAD.
AND WOULD LIKE TO TELL YOU TO
HELP CREATE A GREATER SENSE OF
URGENCY YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
LACK OF ENFORCEMENT A SLAP OF
ON THE WRIST. COMMENTS LIKE
JUST IN NORAL. MODES OF
OPERATING PROCEDURE FOR MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS. BUT TO COME
TO US AND SAY THIS IS WHAT WE
ARE SEEING A WE NEED THIS STORY
THE LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT TO BE
ABLE TO TACKLE THESE ISSUES.
IT'S ALSO CLEAR TO ME THAT
THERE ARE NUMBER OF VARIOUS
ENTITIES THAT OVERSEE THIS OF
ENFORCEMENT AND WITHIN CANNABIS
VAPING ALIKE. WE ALSO TALK
ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL. AND STATE
CONTRACTS STATE A POSITION AS
WELL A PERHAPS MY COLLEAGUES
MAY ALSO JOIN ME IN EXPLORING
THEN PERHAPS A CONSOLIDATION
INTO DEPARTMENTAL STATUS. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
UNIFORM APPROACH TO SOME OF
THESE AREAS SO WE HAVE A SENSE
OF CONSISTENCY ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY. SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A SENSE OF HOW WE ARE
TACKLING THIS ALL IN ONE HOUSE
AS WELL TOO SO THE
EFFICIENCIES. I THINK AS MISTER
COOPER ALSO MENTIONED IS VERY
IMPORTANT. A SIMILE ALSO WANT
TO MAKE A POINT THAT WE OFTEN
TIMES IN THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY.
HAVE SOUGHT TO TRY AND ADDRESS
MANY THESE DIFFERENT ISSUES. IN
FACT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THAT OF
LOCAL CONTROL CITY SAYING THAT
WE WANT TO MAINTAIN LOCAL
CONTROL WHEN IN FACT I SAY
AGAIN. CITIES ARE NOT IN
CONTROL THERE ARE UNLICENSED
DISPENSARIES OPERATING. ALL THE
TIME YEAH AND MANY DIFFERENT
PLACES AND SO WHEN WE THEN SAY
LET US HELP OPEN UP THE
REGULATED MARKET. FOR BILL
PROPOSAL ON COMMENSURATE LE.
THIS IS ON A. B. C. LICENSES
IN. CITIES THAT BILL DOES NOT
PASS. WE ALSO SAW A BILL
PROHIBITING DELIVERY THAT
BUILDS NOT PASSED WE SAW A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION TO LOWER.
EXCISE TAX THAT DID NOT PASS.
SO WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO DO WHAT
WE CAN. ABOARD I THINK IS.
GOING TO BE HELPFUL IS IF YOU
HELP PROVIDE US OF THE
SPECIFICS AND SAYING THE
JUSTIFICATION IS VERY CLEAR.
WHICH ARE WHO I WOULD SUGGEST
ARGUE BUT IT LEAVE IT TO PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT IS ACTUALLY IN
UNISON. TO THAT OF WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING FROM INDUSTRY WHICH IS
WE THE REGULATED AND THE
INDUSTRY THAT IS REPRESENTED IN
THIS AUDIENCE. ALSO SAY WE WANT
TO JOIN IN LOCKSTEP WE ARE
WILLING TO PAY OUR TAXES WE
WILLING TO PAY FOR THESE. WE
KNOW WHO THE BAD ACTORS ARE WE
WANT TO BE IN THE REGULATED
MARKET. BUT THEY FEEL LIKE.
THEY ARE NOT SURVIVING. AND NOT
ONLY IS THAT THAT INDIVIDUALS
ARE DYING AS WE ALL KNOW BUT
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS ARE ALSO
DYING. AT SO. THERE NEEDS TO BE
A GREATER SENSE OF URGENCY SO.
WE IMPLORE YOU TO HELP CREATE
THAT. SENSE OF URGENCY FOR US
BECAUSE WE WANT TO WORK WITH IN
THE STATE BUDGET TO HELP GIVE
YOU MORE. TOOLS AND RESOURCES
AND PEOPLE WE ALSO WANT TO
CHANGE LEGISLATION TO HELP
EMPOWER YOU SO THAT YOU CAN GO
AFTER THE BAD ACTORS ALIKE. UP
AND THEN ALSO MESSAGE VERY
CLEAR TO THE ADMINISTRATION. OF
THAT THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING THAT HAS ENGAGE WITH
BROAD PUBLIC SUPPORT OF ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. TO THAT WHEN YOU
SEE PIECES OF LEGISLATION. THAT
COMES FROM US THIS IS GETTING
THE ADMINISTRATION INVOLVED AND
STAKEHOLDERS ALIKE. SO AGAIN WE
WANT TO WORK HAND IN HAND WITH
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU. I YOU
PROVIDE AS A SOME GOOD TOOLS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS LIKE. A BUT
AGAIN WE NEED TO CREATE A
GREATER SENSE OF URGENCY FOR
THIS BECAUSE- THIS IS OF
IMMENSE IMPORTANCE TO NOT ONLY
PUBLIC HEALTH. BUT THE FUTURE.
THAT WILL TRANSCEND BEFORE LONG
BEFORE LONG AFTER WE WILL WE
WILL BE HERE. SPECTER OF THESE
CHAIR DO SO AGAIN DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR ALL. OF YOUR
COMMITMENTS AND WE LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
LOW END AT THANK YOU AGAIN. AT
THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO THE FINAL. PANEL TODAY WHAT
AT THE HEALTH EFFECTS
ASSOCIATED WITH VAPING AND
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES OF WHAT
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE WITH
WELCOME DOCTOR CHARITY DEAN
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR ACTING STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IF
YOU COULD. COME UP AND PRESENT
YOUR TESTIMONY PLACE. WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR CHARITY DEAN
ACTING STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE VAPING
ASSOCIATED PULMONARY INJURY.
THE CURRENT STATUS OF THE BABY
OUTBREAK IS ALARMING.
NATIONALLY THERE HAVE BEEN ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED NINETY
NINE CASES AND AT LEAST TWENTY
SIX DEATHS. THE NATIONAL
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION REPORTS 76% OF
PATIENTS SELF REPORT USING THC.
TODAY NEW DATE IT WAS POSTEDON
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WEBSITE CD PH DOT
CA DOT GOV AND I'M GOING TO
DISCUSS IT. WE'VE HAD A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE CASES IN
CALIFORNIA THREE DEATHS THE
MEDIAN AGE OF CASES HAS BEEN
TWENTY SEVEN. ALL OF THOSE
CASES HAVE BEEN HOSPITALIZED.
OF THOSE 43% REQUIRED CARE IN
THE INTENSIVE CARE UNIT AND 28%
REQUIRED MECHANICAL INTUBATION.
SEVENTY EIGHT OF THOSE CASES
HAVE BEEN INTERVIEWED THIS
MEANS THAT THEY SELF REPORT TO
THE PERSON INTERVIEWING THEM
WHAT THEY USE AND WHERE THEY
OBTAINED THE PRODUCT. THE CASE
IS REPORT VAPING OR DABBING
MOSTLY CANNABIS PRODUCTS AND
WAXES OILS AND OTHER FORMS. OF
THE SEVENTY EIGHT INTERVIEWED
81% SELF REPORT USING THC. 38%
UCB D. 47% USE NICOTINE. MOST
USE A COMBINATION OF THESE AND
ONLY 10% REPORTED USING ONLY
NICOTINE. THERE WAS ONE CASE
THAT DID SELF REPORT PURCHASING
FROM A CONFIRMED LICENSED
RETAILER MANY ASPECTS OF THAT
ARE BEING INVESTIGATED AND THAT
INVESTIGATION IS STILL ONGOING.
THE REMAINING CASES WHO SELF
REPORTED DURING THE INTERVIEW
STATED THAT THEY HAD PURCHASED
THEIR VAPING PRODUCTS FROM
ILLICIT STREET VENDORS. POP UP
SHOPS. SOCIAL CONTACTS OR
UNVERIFIED SELLERS AND BY
UNVERIFIED SELLERS WE MEAN
RETAILERS THAT EITHER COULD NOT
BE LOCATED OR COULD NOT BE
VERIFIED AS HAVING A LICENSE.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE PATTERNS OF
LUNG INJURY WHICH ARE EMERGING
BASED ON THE MEDICAL FINDINGS
FROM TISSUE BIOPSIES AUTOPSIES
AND BLOOD WORK. MANY OF THESE
ARE NOW EMERGING IN PUBLISHED
LITERATURE. I'M GOING TO LIST A
FEW THE YOU MAY HAVE HEARD OF
IN THE MEDIA EXHAUSTION A
SLIGHT PUEDEN AMMONIA. THE
THEORY BEHIND THAT WAS IT AND
HAILING VAPORIZED OILS CAN
CAUSE THIS CLINICAL SYNDROME.
THAT CAN BE SEEN ON SOME OF THE
CLINICAL SPECIMENS LIKE LONG
WASHINGS. CHEMICAL PNEUMONITIS
OR CHEMICAL INHALATION INJURY.
ACUTE EOSINOPHILIC PNEUMONIA
BRONCHIOLITIS OBLITERANS
DIFFUSE ALVEOLAR DAMAGE DIFFUSE
ALVEOLAR HEMORRHAGE ALL OF
THESE INVOLVE ACUTE LUNG INJURY
AND INFLAMMATION SO YOU CAN SEE
THAT THERE ARE NOW A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT CLINICAL SYNDROMES
THAT ARE EMERGING NOT JUST ONE.
THE CHALLENGE THERE IS THAT
MULTIPLE PATTERNS OF LONG
INJURY SUGGEST MULTIPLE
MECHANISMS WHICH IN TURN
SUGGESTS THAT THERE MAY BE
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT CAUSES
DIFFERENT CHEMICALS LEADING TO
THIS NOT JUST ONE. EXTENSIVE
LABORATORY TESTING IS BEING
DONE NATIONALLY THERE ARE
PUBLISHED AND ANECDOTAL REPORTS
FROM LABS AT THE FEDERAL AND
STATE LEVEL. ALL OF THEM AGREE
THAT AT THIS POINT THERE IS NO
SINGLE DEVICE SUBSTANCE PRODUCT
OR DEVICE TYPE THAT HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS THE CAUSE OF THE
OUTBREAK. VITAMIN E. ACETATE
HAS BEEN RECOVERED FROM SOME
PRODUCTS BUT NOT ALL. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH I RECEIVED A HUNDRED AND
FORTY SIX CARTRIDGES ARE PODS
WHICH WERE VOLUNTARILY
SURRENDERED BY PATIENTS AND THE
EXTENSIVE TESTING IS ONGOING.
THERE ARE MANY UNKNOWNS ONE I
WOULD HIGHLIGHT IS THE UNKNOWN
OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU MIX
CHEMICALS TOGETHER HEAT THAT
MIXTURE AN AEROSOLIZED IT.
WHICH MAY CREATE NEW TOXIC
COMPOUNDS THE EFFECT OF WHICH
ON THE LONG TISSUE IS UNKNOWN.
ANOTHER UNKNOWN ARE VARIABLES
INTRINSIC IN THE DEVICES
THEMSELVES HEATING ELEMENTS
BATTERIES REFILLABLE CARTRIDGES
AND METALS AND AGAIN THE
COMBINATION OF THESE WITH HEAT
MAYBE CREATING UNKNOWN
SUBSTANCES THAT WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW TO TEST FOR. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH HAS HAD A ROBUST
RESPONSE TO THIS OUTBREAK. THE
MEDICAL AND HEALTH COORDINATION
CENTER WAS ACTIVATED IN AUGUST
IT IS NOW ACTIVATED AT LEVEL
TWO. WE HAVE ISSUED THREE K.
HAD ALERTS STATEWIDE. MULTIPLE
HEALTH ADVISORIES INCLUDING TO
THE PUBLIC AND TO HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS. WE ISSUED A
PRESS RELEASE AND HAVE BEEN
VERY RESPONSIVE TO MEDIA
INCREASE. FROM THE BEGINNING
FROM AUGUST FROM THE FIRST DAY
WE'VE COLLABORATED WITH OUR
NATIONAL PARTNERS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WITH THE CDC WITH
OTHER STATES THAT WERE
REPORTING CLUSTERS WITH OUR
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS AND
WITH PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA.
ACROSS OUR DEPARTMENT MULTIPLE
CENTERS HAVE BEEN INVOLVED THEY
HAVE ALL COME TOGETHER TO OFFER
STAFF AND EXPERTISE TO RESPOND.
I SPECIALLY WANT TO MENTION THE
WORK OF OUR STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
LABORATORIES WHERE IT'S BEEN A
TEAM EFFORT TO SYNTHESIZE AND
TEST VARIOUS CHEMICAL
HYPOTHESES. DESCRIPTION OF THE
EMERGING CLINICAL SYNDROME
INCLUDES RESPIRATORY SYMPTOMS
SUCH AS COUGH SHORTNESS OF
BREATH CHEST PAIN. ANGIE I SENT
SYMPTOMS INCLUDING ABDOMINAL
PAIN NAUSEA VOMITING DIARRHEA
BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES FEVER
FATIGUE AND WEAKNESS. PATIENTS
PRESENT WITH LOW OXYGEN LEVELS
WHICH IS WHY MANY OF THEM NEED
TO BE IN THE INTENSIVE CARE
UNIT WITH SUPPLEMENTAL OXYGEN
THEY HAVE AN ABNORMAL CHEST X.
RAY MANY HAVE AN ABNORMAL CT
SCAN AS WELL SHOWING BILATERAL
INFILTRATES ON BOTH SIDES OF
THEIR LINES NOT JUST ONE. THE
UNKNOWN I'M SORRY THE LONG TERM
HEALTH EFFECTS ARE UNKNOWN
BECAUSE THIS IS AN EMERGING
CLINICAL SYNDROME WE'RE LOOKING
VERY CAREFULLY AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. BUT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THESE PATIENTS
LEAVE THE HOSPITAL HOW QUICK IS
THEIR RECOVERY WILL THEY HAVE
LIFELONG ADVERSE HEALTHEFFECTS
ON THEIR LUNGS. WE DON'T KNOW
THAT YET. ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
IS THIS IS A DIAGNOSIS OF
EXCLUSION WHICH IS WHY I
MENTIONED THE SYMPTOMS. IN
ORDER TO MAKE THE DIAGNOSIS OF
A BABY CASE YOU HAVE TO FIRST
RULE OUT INFECTIOUS CAUSES OR
OTHER POSSIBLE CAUSES. THIS
WILL BE A CHALLENGE DURING
UPCOMING INFLUENZA SEASON. SO
HOW DO WE FIND THE CAUSE. THE
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH TO THIS
AS IT IS TO MANY OTHER
OUTBREAKS IS A COMBINATION OF
EXAMINING THE EPIDEMIOLOGY
DATA. THE CLINICAL SYNDROME THE
COURSE OF ILLNESS IN THE
PATIENT. THE PATIENT'S CLINICAL
SPECIMENS AND OF COURSE A
LABORATORY ANALYSIS OF THE
VAPING PRODUCTS THEMSELVES. AND
IT WILL BE THAT INFORMATION
DOVE TAILING TOGETHER THAT WILL
GET US CLOSER TO AN ANSWER. IT
COULD TAKE YEARS FOR THE
MEDICAL AND SCIENTIFIC
COMMUNITY TO DEFINITIVELY
DETERMINE WHAT THE CAUSES ARE.
PUBLIC HEALTH RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR THE PUBLIC ARE IMPORTANT
AND WE'VE BEEN SHARING THEM IN
OUR PUBLICLY SHARED A PRESS
RELEASE AND HEALTH ALERTS
NUMBER ONE. WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE PUBLIC REFRAIN FROM VAPING
NO MATTER THE SOURCE THERE IS
ALWAYS A RISK WHEN YOU INHALE A
FOREIGN SUBSTANCE INTO YOUR
LUNGS AND THE RISK OF VAPING
NOW INCLUDES DEATH. IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT FOR CONSUMERS TO
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN REGULATED
AND UNREGULATED PRODUCTS
CONSIDERING THERE ARE
COUNTERFEIT LABELS THAT CAN BE
VERY DECEPTIVE. NUMBER TWO FOR
THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO VAPE ONLY
PURCHASE FROM A VERIFIED
LICENSED RETAILER. NUMBER THREE
FOR SOMEONE WHO HAS RECENTLY
VAPE AND IS EXPERIENCING SOME
OF THESE SYMPTOMS THEY SHOULD
SEEK CARE IMMEDIATELY AND THEY
NEED TO SHARE THEIR HONEST AND
THOROUGH VAPING HISTORY AND
PRODUCTS USED WITH THAT
PROVIDER. AND NUMBER FOUR IF
YOU STOP VAPING DO NOT SWITCH
TO CIGARETTES INSTEAD PLEASE
CONSIDER USING AN FDA APPROVED
QUITTING TREATMENT. THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO COME TODAY
AND I'LL TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU DOCTOR
THIS TIME WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. YES FIRST OFF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I'VE BEEN
I'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES AS WE DO IN OUR COLD
AND FLU SEASON AND HOW HOW YOU
DISTINGUISH THAT AND THE
COMPLICATIONS THAT MAY ARISE
FROM PERSON WHO HAD DOES HAVE
THE- HAVE A COLD OR THE FLU.
AND HOW MUCH OF ONE PLUS ONE
MIGHT EQUAL THREE AND THAT'S
NOT A GOOD THING IN THIS CASE
SO APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS AROUND THAT PEOPLE
THAT ARE SUFFER PORTING. ANY
RESIDUAL LEFT FOR TESTING HAS
THAT IS THAT AND HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY DOING THAT
OR IS PRESENT CONSUMED IN ALL
GONE BEFORE THEY GET TO YOU.
SURE SOME PATIENTS ARE
VOLUNTARILY TURNING OVER THE
PRODUCT AND THEIR VAPING DEVICE
AND THOSE ARE SENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO CONDUCT TESTING. AND
SO ALL THE RESULT THE RESULTS
ARE STE IT TAKES A WHILE TO DO
THAT OBVIOUSLY SO. IT'S BEEN A
VERY COMPLEX ANALYSIS AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT SOME OF THOSE
RESULTS BUT IT REALLY IS IN THE
BEGINNING STAGES OF A
COMPREHENSIVE LABORATORY
ANALYSIS. CONSIDERING HOW MANY
CHEMICALS HAVE TO BE TESTED
FOR. THANK YOU. FIRST OFF THE
FREE TEST MY WERE WE ARE. FIRST
CONTACT THE DEPARTMENT AND
LOOKED INTO AT THAT TIME THE
REPORTED CASES MY RECOLLECTION.
WAS SIXTY TWO AT A SIXTY THREE
CASES WERE REPORTED THC WITH
ONE. CASE I KNOW AND I HEARD
YOU SAY EARLIER 81% THC AS HAVE
THERE BEEN MORE CASES HAS THAT
HAS THAT INFORMATION CHANGED.
SINCE I LAST SPOKE WITH. SURE I
CAN'T REMEMBER THAT EXACT WEEK
BECAUSE THE DATA IS CHANGING SO
RAPIDLY BUT YES YOU ARE CORRECT
RIGHT NOW 81% OF THE CASES SELF
REPORT USING THC. THE NEW ONES
IS THAT MANY OF THE CASES ARE
COMBINING THE THC WITH C. B. D.
AN WITH NICOTINE. AND SO IF
YOU'RE TO ADD UP THE
PERCENTAGES THAT WE THE DATA
THAT WE PUBLISHED ON OUR
WEBSITE TODAY YOU'LL SEE IT
DOESN'T ADD TO A HUNDRED
PERCENT. BECAUSE MANY OF THEM
ARE COMBINING THE SUBSTANCES
TOGETHER. IN THE MEDIA REPORTS
A LONG ILLNESSES HAVE. AT LEAST
IT'S BEEN SUGGESTED LINKED TO
BLACK MARKET. PRODUCTS AND
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF QUESTION
ABOUT THAT TODAY. HAVE THERE
BEEN ANY CASES OF LONG ILLNESS
OR DEATH FOR THAT MATTER. WHO
HAVE USED LEGAL CANNABIS
PRODUCTS EXCLUSIVELY. I CAN
ONLY SPEAK TO THE DATA THAT WE
HAVE FOR CALIFORNIA. OF THE
SEVENTY EIGHT CASES WHO WERE
INTERVIEWED IN CALIFORNIA THERE
WAS ONLY ONE CASE SELF REPORTED
EXCLUSIVELY PURCHASING FROM
LICENSED RETAILERS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WHEN WE
DO THESE EPIDEMIOLOGY
INTERVIEWS FOR ANY OUTBREAK.
WERE ASKING PATIENTS TO USE
THEIR BEST RECOLLECTION AND
SELF REPORT TO THE INTERVIEWER
AND SO WE LOOK AT EVERY ASPECT
OF THAT AND THAT STILL BEING
INVESTIGATED. BUT THERE WAS
ONLY ONE CASE THAT SOFT
REPORTED EXCLUSIVELY LEGAL
RETAILERS EVERYONE ELSE WE CAN
ASSUME BASED ON THEIR SELF
REPORT NON LEGAL PRODUCTS
REALLY SOME NOT LEGAL PRODUCTS.
THAT'S CORRECT THE REST TO SELF
REPORTED EVEN THE ONES WHO MAY
HAVE MENTIONED A BRICK AND
MORTAR LOCATION THOSE WERE NOT
ABLE TO BE FOUND OR NOT ABLE TO
BE VERIFIED IS LICENSED AND HOW
MANY OF THEM REPORT EXCLUSIVELY
USING NICOTINE BABY PRODUCTS
AND KNOW OUR THC OR MARIJUANA
PRODUCTS ONLY TEN PERCENT. OF
THE SEVENTY EIGHT WHO WERE
INTERVIEWED. I ASKED MY STAFF
TO DO A LITTLE RESEARCH. IT
STRUCK ME AS ODD THE THING IS
NOT A ACTIVITY THE ONLY OCCURS
HERE IN UNITED STATES BUT YET
I'VE HEARD NOTHING OR READ
NOTHING. ABOUT DEATH ILLNESS AT
CENTER OF DO TODAY BEING
OUTSIDE UNITED STATES. CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THAT'LL HAVE YOU SEEN
ANY EVIDENCE OR REPORTS
WORLDWIDE. THERE HAVE BEEN A
HANDFUL OF CASES REPORTED IN
CANADA I'M NOT AWARE OF THESE
CLUSTERS OR OUTBREAK EMERGING
IN OTHER COUNTRIES. DOES THAT
STRIKE YOU AS ODD. IT STRIKES
ME AS INTERESTING. AND AS WE
LOOK AT ALL THE POSSIBLE CAUSES
IN THE UNITED STATES INCLUDING
OUR SB DATA OUR PATIENTS THAT
THE CLINICAL LABS. THAT
SOMETHING THAT WERE BEING OUT
WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT CHANGED
AND WHY NOW. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND APPRECIATE THE ANSWERS.
JUST A QUICK FOLLOW UP ON IT I
APPRECIATE YOUR LINE OF
QUESTIONING THERE SO I THINK
IT'S I THINK IS REALLY VALUABLE
SAID SOMEONE REPORTED WE HAD
ONE PERSON REPORT THAT THEY HAD
PURCHASED FROM A LICENSED.
REGULATED CANNABIS FACILITY WAS
AT VERIFIED THAT THAT INDEED
WAS A LICENSED FACILITY OR WAS
THAT THE PATIENTS RECOLLECTION
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT IT WAS A
LICENSED FACILITY. THAT
INVESTIGATION IS STILL ONGOING
ALT ALL TELL YOU THAT WE SHARE
WE AS PUBLIC HEALTH WHEN WE GET
THOSE REPORTS FROM PATIENTS
THAT WERE INTERVIEWED. WE SHARE
THEM WITH BCC SO THAT THEY CAN
BE INVESTIGATED. IN THAT ONE
CASE THE FACILITY THE BRICK AND
MORTAR LOCATION THAT WAS
MENTIONED WAS CONFIRMED TO BE
LICENSED. BUT ASPECTS OF THAT
ARE STILL BEING INVESTIGATED.
THANK YOU. MR Là THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE AND IF I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY YOU HAD
INDICATED THAT OF THE DATA
STILL INCONCLUSIVE BUT THAT YOU
ARE VERY MUCH LOOKING TO THE
DISTINCTION ON. A WHAT IS BEEN
RECENTLY INTRODUCED AND THAT
WHEN THERE'S A CONCLUSION AND
TO HOPEFULLY FINDING THE
CULPRIT THAT THAT INFORMATION
WILL BE READILY AVAILABLE BUT
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHEN
THAT TIME COMES TO WHICH THEN.
A GIVEN YOUR RESEARCH THAT YOU
DO FIND CONCLUSIVE EVIDENCE OF
WHERE THE CULPRIT IS WHAT BEEN
TRANSPIRES SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS WILL BE
PROTECTED DOES THAT COME FROM
EXECUTIVE ORDER DOES THAT COME
FROM. OF ADMINISTRATION AND
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE HOW
DO YOU SEE THAT HAPPENING. I
THINK THAT WOULD DEPEND ON WHAT
THE CULPRIT WAS. IT'S NOT CLEAR
THAT IT'S JUST THE SUBSTANCE OR
JUST THE DEVICE IT COULD EVEN
BE A COMBINATION OF THEM SO IT
SEEMS THAT THE ABILITY TO STOP
THE OUTBREAK ENDS AND REMOVE
THE CULPRIT SUBSTANCE OR DEVICE
WILL DEPEND ON WHAT IT IS RIGHT
NOW AND NUMBER OF HYPOTHESES
ARE BEING LOOKED AT.
EVERYTHING'S ON THE TABLE. AND
COMBINATIONS AND THAT IS TAKES
TO CONCLUSION TO WHICH IS
CAUSING HARM AND DEATH WHAT
THEN TRANSPIRES. THEN DID DO WE
SEE THE ADMINISTRATION AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE YOU COME TO THE
LEGISLATION SAYING OKAY HERE'S
WHAT IT ISPLEASE PASSED
LEGISLATION HOW DO YOU SEE DID
YOU HAVE A SENSE ON HOW THAT
WOULD THAN. BEFORE MY SENSE IS
THAT IF WE KNEW WHAT WAS
CAUSING THIS THAT SWIFT ACTION
WOULD BE TAKEN AND ALL OPTIONS
WOULD BE CONSIDERED. THANK YOU.
THREE OF US. AND SO THAT'S A
YOU KNOW A GREAT QUESTION AND
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW SO BASED ON
ON ON ON WHAT YOU MENTIONED YOU
KNOW I FIND A STARTLING THAT
THIS COULD TAKE YEARS TO FIND
OUT WHAT THE CULPRIT IS A BASED
ON WHERE WE ARE NOW IT SEEMS
LIKE THIS IS OBVIOUS IN
EVOLVING ISSUE AS YOU MENTIONED
THE DATA SEEMS TO BE CHANGING
AND EVERY STATE IS HANDLING
THIS CRISIS AS IT IS FROM DAY
TO DAY IN THEIR OWN WAY. WE AS
A STATE BASED ON THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
IS THAT ENOUGH IS THAT RESPONSE
ENOUGH FOR OUR STATE WITH THIS
CRISIS. MOVING FORWARD. MANY
OPTIONS ARE BEING CONSIDERED TO
RESPOND TO THIS CRISIS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN RESPONSE TO
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER ARE STILL
BEING FINALIZED. BUT MANY
OPTIONS ARE ON THE TABLE
INCLUDING SWIFT ACTIONS
THOROUGH OPTIONS TO ADDRESS THE
OUTBREAK AND THE YOUTH VAPING
EPIDEMIC. EVEN THOUGH THESE ARE
DISTINCT ISSUES THE OUTBREAK OF
VAPING LONG INJURY AND THE
YOUTH VAPING EPIDEMIC THEY ARE
RELATED THERE IS SOME
CROSSOVERS I THINK DOCTOR WOULD
HAVE POINTED OUT AT THE
BEGINNING. AND SO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS BEING
CONSIDERED TAKE A BROAD
APPROACH AND EVERYTHING'S ON
THE TABLE. RESTORED FINAL
FINALLY THANK YOU THANK YOU IS
THE MORE SEVERE THE MORE HERE
THAN WHERE YOU QUESTIONS YOU
COME UP WITH BUT CONSIDERING
THAT ACTUALLY VAPING HAS BEEN
AROUND FOR AWHILE AND NOT JUST
NICOTINE BUT ALSO CANNABIS DOES
IT NOT SURPRISE YOU THAT
SUDDENLY THIS IS HAPPENING THIS
THIS THIS JUST FEELS A LOT LIKE
THIS IS ISOLATE TO SOMETHING
BECAUSE THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER
THINGS YOU YOU KNOW WE GO BACK
TO SEVERAL YEARS AGO. AND THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY THAT'S THEIR
MEETINGS BEEN GOING ON FOR
AWHILE CERTAINLY WITH
NICOTINE'S BEEN GOING ON FOR
AWHILE BUT ALL OF A SUDDEN
WHICH THERE'S SOMETHING
SOMETHING'S NOT RIGHT AND THIS
IS THAT THAT OBVIOUSLY IS
UNUSUAL ON DOES THAT. DOES THAT
SURPRISE YOU IN SOME WAY. YES
AND AS WE DISCUSSED THIS WITH
OTHER STATES WHO WERE FACING A
SIMILAR OUTBREAK SITUATION
SINCE AUGUST THAT QUESTION
EMERGED. THE INCREASING CASES
THAT WE'RE SEEING IS IT AN
ARTIFACT OF US LOOKING FOR THEM
HAD THEY BEEN THERE ALL ALONG I
BELIEVE IN CALIFORNIA THE
ANSWER IS NOW THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING NEW THAT WERE SAYING
THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN BEFORE. WE
DON'T KNOW THE CAUSE YET SO WE
DON'T KNOW WHY BUT WE'RE
LOOKING AT MULTIPLE THEORIES
AND ASKING WHAT CHANGED TO
BECAUSE THIS SPIKING CASES
THERE ARE REPORTS IN THE
LITERATURE REPORTING SIMILAR
ADD VAPING LONG INJURY CASES
FROM BEFORE AUGUST OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. BUT NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO THE NUMBER THAT WE'RE
SEEING NOW. THAT KIND OF BRINGS
ME BACK TO WINE. THE VITAMIN A
ACETATE YOU MENTION THAT. WAS
AN INGREDIENT NOT FOUND IN ALL
CASES BUT WHAT DO WE KNOW.
ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF INHALING
VITAMIN ASKED. I'M SORRY THE
EFFECTS OF WHAT OF INHALING
VITAMIN THE ASKED. DO WE KNOW
ANYTHING NOT A LOT SO ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES OF INVESTIGATING
POSSIBLE CULPRITS LIKE VITAMIN
A ACETATE. I'M IS THAT IT'S NOT
JUST THE SUBSTANCE ITSELF SO IT
MIGHT BE SAFE WHEN INGESTED YOU
CAN EAT IT MAYBE IT'S A VITAMIN
YOU KNOW IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
THINK MAY HAVE HEALTH BENEFITS
WHEN EATEN. BUT WHEN YOU HEAT
IT UP AND YOU VAPORIZE IT AND
YOU INHALE IT INTO THE LONG.
THE EFFECTS IT HAS ON THE LONG
TISSUE ON THE LITTLE AIR SACS
IS UNKNOWN AND SO LOOKING AT
EACH CULPRIT EVEN AS VITAMIN A
ACETATE IS CONSIDERED ISN'T
JUST TESTING THE ACTUAL LIQUID
ITSELF. IT INVOLVES TESTING
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN IT'S
VAPORIZED OUR NEW COMPOUNDS
CREATED AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN IT'S INHALED INTO THE LONG
WHAT DOES THE TISSUE DAMAGE
LOOK LIKE WHAT DO THE CELLS
LOOK LIKE. THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY GETTING TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS COULD TAKE TIME
BECAUSE IT COULD INVOLVE
STUDIES OVER A PERIOD OF TIME
USING ANIMAL MODELS LOOKING AT
OF A- WIDE RANGE OF TOXINS THAT
ARE HEATED TO THE POINT OF
BEING VAPORIZE AND THEN
INHALED. INTO THE LUNGS. SO I
THINK YOU'RE REGIONAL QUESTION
WAS WHAT IS THE EFFECT OF
VITAMIN E. ACETATE. IT WAS AT
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN WHAT WAS
CAUSING THE LIGHT POINT
AMMONIA. THAT IS BEING EXAMINED
AND STUDIED AND- YET UNKNOWN.
IN MY UNDERSTANDING IS IT'S
NOT. IT IS AT THIS TIME A LEGAL
INGREDIENT. FOR ILLEGAL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS IS THE IS THE
IS THAT CORRECT OR IS IT IN
FACT IT BANNED INGREDIENTS WE
TAKE ANY ACTION ON THAT TO YOUR
KNOWLEDGE ON VITAMIN E. ACETATE
IT'S NOT INCLUDED IN THE LIST
OF THINGS THAT MANUFACTURERS
MUST TEST FOR. OKAY. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS BEFORE WE
MAKE HER JUST. I'VE BEEN GOING
BACK AND FORTH WELL AND IT IS
THE BACK AND FORTH AND IT IS IT
IS A IS ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WITH WHEN I'M I'M SICKENED
SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY THINGS ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES WITH THIS
INDUSTRY THERE ARE THINGS IN
THE HISTORY THAT HAVE BEEN USED
IN THE PAST THAT WERE SAFE ON
OTHER THINGS I THINK THERE'S A
THERE'S A THERE'S A PESTICIDE
CALLED EAGLE TWENTY YEARS OR SO
I'M I MAY BE SAYING IT WRONG.
BUT WAS USEFUL USED ON LEAFY
VEGETABLES AND OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS AND IT WAS SAFE BUT WHEN
YOU ACTUALLY BURNED IT INTO
ITALY IT LIBERATED CYANIDE SO
THAT'S OVIOUSLY NOT SAFE AND
IT WAS NOT KNOWN BY A OTHER
PEOPLE SO. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
TESTING FOR IT NOW WELL IF TO
THE BUREAU. THERE MAY BE OTHER
THINGS IT EMERGED HAVE. VITAMIN
THE ACETATE ON ITS OWN MAY BE
PERFECTLY SAFE BUT IN THIS
SETTING MAY MAY NOT. AND SO IT
IS PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING. AS
PEOPLE OR- SOME PROBABLY
EXPERIMENTING QUITE FRANKLY.
AND ADDING THINGS TO THE
PRODUCTS TO ENHANCE THEM IN
SOME WAY BUT- BUT THIS IS THIS
IS NOT AN UNUSUAL. OCCURRENCE
OF THIS THIS IS AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT WITH THIS WITH THE
INDUSTRY AND- PART OF THAT IS
THE CHALLENGE OF DOING RESEARCH
AND BEING ABLE TO SEE WHAT
TRULY A SAFE AND WHICH REALLY
ISN'T. I THINK AFTER. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I THINK AT
THIS TIME WE WILL TAKE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. ONE ANY OF US.
OKAY SEE WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
INTERESTED PUBLIC COMMENT WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU IN LIGHT OF.
THE RIGHT TO THE HEARING HERE
TO TRY TO CONFINE YOUR COMMENTS
TO AROUND ONE MINUTE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
NAY GRAYSON. YOU SO MUCH I
REALLY WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH YOU
TODAY SO THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIRS AND THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS LINDSAY ROBINSON I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE AND ROUGHLY FIFTEEN
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES. THE LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY IS EXTREMELY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CURRENT
BEEPING ISSUES AS WELL AS
COUNTERFEIT PRODUCTS FLOODING
THE ILLICIT MARKET WE'RE
COMMITTED TO BUILDING CONSUMER
SAFETY AND CONFIDENCE AND OUR
FOCUS IS ON PUBLIC SAFETY WE
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE
REGULATORS THE NEWSMEN
MINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE AS YOU ALL KNOW HOW
THE LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY
VIGOROUSLY TESTS ALL OF ITS
PRODUCTS THE FOLKS WHO ARE OUR
MEMBERS YOU SEE SEE I A AND ARE
PART OF THE LEGAL INDUSTRY HAVE
ABSOLUTELY HE JUMPED THROUGH
ALL OF THE HOOPS TO BE
COMPLIANT AND WE'RE ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH ALL
OF YOU. OUR BIGGEST FEAR IS
THAT IF WE CUT OFF ACCESS TO
LEGAL CANNABIS THE ILLICIT
MARKET THRIVES EVEN FURTHER
WHICH CREATES MORE REST OF
PUBLIC HEALTH SO WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH
YOU AND BE A RESOURCE AND THANK
YOU. FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY THANK
YOU. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
NOT. GRAY AND CHAIRMAN WOULD IN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS TIFFANY DEBT THAT I WORK
WITH CANNOT CRAP I HAD A BAR
CONSUMER AND GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS. WHERE ONE OF THE
LARGEST MANUFACTURERS IN THE
STATE WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
RESEARCH ON THIS ISSUE. IT IS
WORTH MENTIONING THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE MOST
RIGOROUS TESTING STANDARDS IN
THE COUNTRY. WE DID SOME A
COMPARATIVE TESTING OF OTHER
PRODUCTS IN CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
WITH REGARD TO PESTICIDES. IS
CLEANER THAN CHOCOLATE MILK
IT'S CLEANER THAN LINE IT'S
CLEANER THAN BABY FOOD. IT
LOOKS AS THOUGH THIS IS THE
VAPING ISSUE IS AN ISSUE WITH
THE AT LISETTE MARKET OUR
MESSAGE TO YOU. IS THAT IT THE
ONLY WAY DOES STOP THE
ILLNESSES AND DEATHS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IS TO HELP CONSUMERS
MIGRATE FROM THE ILLICIT MARKET
TO THE LIST OF MARKET. THERE
ARE THREE REASONS WHY THEY'RE
BUYING IN THE BLACK MARKET THEY
CAN'T TELL THE DIFFERENCE THEY
DON'T WANT TO PAY THREE TIMES
AS MUCH FOR THE REGULATED
PRODUCT. OR THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO REGULATED PRODUCTS SO
ARE WHAT WE TO URGE YOU TO DO
IS TO WORK COME PASSING
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO LEGAL WELL TESTED
WELL REGULATED CANADA. AND LOOK
AT SOME FOR FARM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THIS HEARING MY
NAME'S DALE GEHRINGER WITH OUR
WITH CALIFORNIA NORMAL HI
SPONSORED THE FIRST PUBLISHED
STUDIES ON CANNABIS
VAPORIZATION A BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE AND TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE WHICH
DEMONSTRATED QUITE CLEARLY.
THAT THE PRICES WERE VERY
EFFECTIVE IN REMOVING THE WITH
TOXINS IN MARIJUANA SMOKING
WERE REALLY HELPFUL AS A- SMOKE
HARM REDUCTION DEVICE SINCE
THEN A MARIJUANA VAPORIZERS
HAVE COME TO BE. ACCEPTED AS
THE OUR GOLD STANDARD FOR
ADMINISTRATION IN MEDICAL
STUDIES. HOWEVER THERE ARE
VAPORIZERS AND THERE ARE
VAPORIZERS THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF INNOVATION RECENTLY WITH NEW
KINDS EXTRACTS POSSIBLE NEW
CHEMICALS AND ADDITIVES AND
THERE IS AN ISSUE ABOUT THE
HARDWARE WHICH COMES FROM
CHINA. FROM MANY DIFFERENT
SOURCES ARE SOME OF THEM MORE.
REPUTABLE THAN OTHERS SO I
THINK WE WILL TO INVESTIGATE
THOSE THINGS ARE HOWEVER I HAVE
TO OUR ON OUR- HI. CONSUMERS
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AVAILABILITY OF TESTED HIGH
QUALITY. VAPORIZERS ALL MOVING
OUT MARKET NOW IN CALIFORNIA
OUR HOPE THEY STAY THERE AND
SHOULD A PROBLEM EVER ARISE
WITH ONE OF THOSE AT LEAST
WE'LL BE ABLE TO TRACK IT DOWN
A LOT. BETTER THAN THE STUFF IS
FROM THE OFFICE OF MARK THANK
YOU. RAND MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF
OF CLEAVER IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST VERTICALLY INTEGRATED
OPERATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE APPRECIATE THE
EMPHASIS TODAY ON ENFORCEMENT
WE CAN TELL YOU FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE ON THE GROUND IS
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES MAY BE
SUBSTANTIAL BUT THEY ARE FAR
FROM SUFFICIENT. WE AS A
STAKEHOLDERS IN YOU IS THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE WORK TO PUT
MORE FUNDS INTO THE BUDGET FOR
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS FOR
MORE RESOURCES FOR ENFORCEMENT.
THAT WAS DONE IN THE CONTEXT OF
MAKING IT EASIER FOR LEGAL
OPERATORS TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE SUCCESSFULLY AND ALSO
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR TAX
RESOURCES WERE WERE ROBUST AS
AS PROJECTED BUT NOW IT'S
TAKING A WHOLE NEW COMPLY.
TAKEN ON A WHOLE NEW COMPLEXION
WITH THIS PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE
WE REALLY NEED THIS COMING
BUDGET CYCLE TO AMP UP OUR
EFFORTS TO GET MORE EXCUSE ME
MORE MONEY INTO THE BUDGET FOR
ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES. THANK YOU.
HI AM ELLEN COME WITH
CALIFORNIA NORMALLY HAVE AN
OPPOSITE PERSPECTIVE OF. THE
HUNDRED YEARS OF PUNITIVE
ACTIONS AGAINST MARIJUANA
SELLERS HASN'T MADE OUR STATE
SAFER. THE ONLY THING THAT WILL
EVER WORK IS PROPER REASONABLE
REGULATION. WE THANK LORI A
JETS IN THE BCC FOR AN ACTING
THOSE REGULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
KEEPING US SAFE. WE SUPPORTED
THE BILLS MR LOW MENTION TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF TWO
THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
COUNTIES NOT LICENSING.
CANNABIS RETAILER DELIVERY. TO
LAURIE IN KINGS COUNTY WHERE WE
HAVE SEEN DEATHS DUE TO THIS
CRISIS HAVE NO LEGAL OPTION
AVAILABLE. MR GREY THERE WAS NO
BILL TO ENCOURAGE CANNABIS USE
BY PASSENGERS AND COMMERCIAL
VEHICLES IN CALIFORNIA THAT WAS
ALLOWED FOR IN CAL IN PROP
SIXTY FOUR AS IT IS IN
COLORADO. THERE WAS A BILL TO
REGULATE THOSE VEHICLES WHICH
WAS SENSATIONALIZED IN THE
PRESS AS ALLOWING IT. NOW THE
TRANSPORTATION BILL HAS ENSURED
THAT THE EXEMPTION FOR
PASSENGERS AND SUCH VEHICLES
APPLIES ONLY TO ALCOHOL. NOT
CANNABIS. EXCESSIVE ALCOHOL USE
IN CALIFORNIA IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR TEN THOUSAND DEATHS AND
SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
HOSPITALIZATIONS ANNUALLY. THE
PENALTY IN CALIFORNIA FOR
ILLEGAL SALES OF FIREARMS AS
FAR AS I CAN FIND IS A
MISDEMEANOR. WITH THE ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE THERE ARE
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED DEATHS DUE
TO FIREARMS ANNUALLY IN
CALIFORNIA. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JESSE GROW
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF U. S.
T. W. WESTERN STATES COUNCIL I
USED TO DOUBLE REPRESENTS
THOUSANDS OF CANNABIS WORKERS
WITHIN THE STATE. WE'RE
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THE LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO
PUT CONSUMER SAFETY FIRST
STRONG REGULATIONS AND STRONG
ENFORCEMENT ARE CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING CONSUMERS. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WHILE CAUTIONING AGAINST
VAPING UNTIL MORE IS KNOWN
ABOUT THE RATE OF THESE
ILLNESSES HAS BEEN CLEARED ITS
ADVICE TO CONSUMERS. ILLEGAL
CANNABIS DISPENSARIES SO
UNREGULATED AN UNTESTED CANVAS
PRODUCTS AND SHOULD NOT BE USED
ONE THING WE DO KNOW IS THAT
LICENSE CANNABIS BUSINESSES
CONTINUE TO BE THE SAFEST
OPTION FOR CONSUMERS. NO
CANNABIS WAITING PRODUCTS
PURCHASED AT LEGAL CANNABIS
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED
LINKED TO ANY OF THE RECENT
HEALTH CASES REPORTED. I IN
RESPONSE TO THE OUTBREAKS OF
RESPIRATORY ILLNESS LINKED TO
VACATE VAPING IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT CALIFORNIA FURTHER
STRENGTHEN ITS ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS THE THREAT THE ILLICIT
MARKET BY IDENTIFYING CLOSING
THE ESTIMATED THREE THOUSAND A
LEGAL DISPENSARIES. OPERATING
IN THE STATE AT THE SAME TIME
STATE OFFICIALS AND INDUSTRY
LEADERS MUST REDOUBLE THEIR
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING A LEGAL
MARKET PLACE IN WHICH CONSUMERS
CAN PURCHASE CANNABIS. PRODUCTS
WITH CONFIDENCE ON THEIR SAFETY
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON LYNN
SILVER THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE DOCTOR WOULD YOUR
FORMER COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER
I'M GLAD TO SEE THIS HEARING
TODAY. THIS IS NOT JUST AN
ISSUE OF LEGAL VERSUS ILLEGAL
PRODUCTS THIS IS A MUCH DEEPER
PROBLEM IF THERE IS NO SINGLE
CAUSE WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
FORCES THAT ARE DRIVING
ADDICTION INITIATION AND HEAVY
USE AND THEREBY EXPOSING PEOPLE
TO WHATEVER HAZARDS ON MAYBE
CAUSING THIS EPIDEMIC BUT ALSO
THE MANY OTHER MEN MORE SERIOUS
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES ONE NOT
MORE SERIOUS THAN DEATH
OBVIOUSLY. THIS WEEK FOR
EXAMPLE I PURCHASED STILL Z.
GRANDDADDY PURP A SLING A
SLEEPING VAPING DEVICE WHICH
I'LL GIVE YOU GUYS RESEMBLING A
MEMORY STICK WITH GREAT FLAVOR
78% THC OR THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY THREE MILLIGRAMS FOUR
TIMES THE MAXIMUM T. H. C. DOES
FOR EDIBLE PACKAGES FORTY TIMES
THE MAXIMUM CANADIAN EDIBLE
PACKAGES THE EQUIVALENT OF
THIRTY EIGHT NINETEEN NINETY
JOINTS. FURTHERMORE IN JUST
ZERO POINT ZERO TWO OUNCES IT
IS AN INVITATION TO USE THE
DICTION LEGALLY MARKETED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
MORE RECENT STUDIES DEMONSTRATE
A FIVE FOLD INCREASE AND
PSYCHOSIS RISK WITH THEY'LL USE
OF CANNABIS PRODUCTS OVER 10%
THC WHICH IS ALMOST THE ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA REGULATED IN LEGAL
OR ILLEGAL MARKET. WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES TO
SUCCESSFULLY REVERSE BOTH THIS
EPIDEMIC IN NEGATIVE HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES FROM CANNABIS I
WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE OF A FEW
JUST VERY CONCRETE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I CAN LEAVE
A WRITTEN A SET OF COMMENTS
WITH YOU ONLY CALL FOR URGENT
COMMONSENSE ACTION FROM THE
STATE LEGISLATURE IN STATE
AGENCIES TO PREVENT EVEN MORE
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES. FIRST
CLOSE THE KITTY ON RAMP OF
FLAVORED PRODUCTS AND SOUNDS
LIKE FLAVORED PRODUCTS LIKE THE
ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY CITED
THE BANANA OF THE THIS AND THAT
THAT MAY NOT BE FLAVORED BUT
CERTAINLY SOUND TO A KID LIKE
THEY ARE BOTH FOR NICOTINE IN
FOR CANNABIS. SECOND BUILD ON
SAN FRANCISCO EN ROUTE. MEN'S
COURAGEOUS INITIATIVES AND
SUSPEND SALES OF BEIPING
PRODUCTS. A UNTIL THE E.
CIGARETTE INDUSTRY PROVES THEIR
SAFETY TO THE FTA AND FOR THE
CASE OF CANNABIS UNTIL WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH THE BEIPING EPIDEMIC.
THIRD INTERRUPT THE ADDICTION
GLIDE PATH CREATED BY PRODUCTS
LIKE THIS BY LIMITING THE
POTENCY OF THC PRODUCTS
ALLOWED. THIS WILL REDUCE YOUTH
ADDICTION TO BEIPING LUNG
DISEASE PSYCHOSIS A SECONDARY
DAVE CANNABIS WOULD Y. IN
QUEBEC FOR EXAMPLE HAVE ALREADY
DONE THIS. FOURTH TELL PEOPLE
THE TRUTH WE ONLY HAVE WARNINGS
IN SIX POINT FONT ON PACKAGES
TODAY WE NEED TO HAVE CLEAR
PROMINENT HEALTH WARNINGS TO
CONSUMERS IN STORES ON PRODUCTS
AND ON ADDS. MAKING CLEAR THE
RECOGNIZED HEALTH RISKS FROM
CANNABIS INCLUDING ADDICTION
LOW BIRTH WEIGHT BEEPING. THE
BABY NAPA DIMMICK PSYCHOSIS AND
SO FORTH. FIFTY LIMIT THE
MARKETING THAT KIDS AND TEENS
ARE SEEING EVERY DAY FOR
EXAMPLE EVEN THE RESTRICTION ON
BILLBOARDS THAT WAS PART OF
PROP SIXTY FOUR WAS WEAKENED BY
THE DECEMBER REGULATIONS
ALLOWING SOME OF THE SPATE OF
BILLBOARDS WERE SEEING ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. DO NOT ALLOW
MARKETING IN RESTAURANTS
ALCOHOL STORES AND OTHER PLACES
WHERE KIDS GO WE BOUGHT A
COFFEE CUP IN UP I THINK WAS
PETER STAR BUCKS A WEEK AGO
WITH THE CHILL BANNER. ON THE
COFFEE CUP FOR EXAMPLE. AND
ESTABLISH A SCIENTIFIC ADVISORY
BOARD FOR CANNABIS REGULATION
THAT IS FREE OF CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST. ON THAT IS ESSENTIAL
TO HELP GUIDE THESE PROCESSES
WITH EXEMPTION THE TIME FOR
ACTION IS NOW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS LET ME REMIND
EVERYBODY WE JUST EXPERIENCED
TWO VERY LONG ONE MINUTE
COMMENTS. WE ACTUALLY THE COULD
BE GENERALLY INTERESTED IN WHAT
YOU HAVE SAVED THE DEGREE TO
WHICH YOU COULD CONFINE YOUR
COMMENTS TO A MINUTE AND
PROVIDE ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
QUESTIONS SIR TO THE COMMITTEE
WILL CERTAINLY MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY SEES US. PERCY GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ON DRESS I
MADE AS ON BEHALF OF SELECT
MOXIE IN CROSS GO ONE THANK YOU
FOR CALLING THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING TO DISCUSS IMPORTANT
TOPICS. AND THANK GOD THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE
WORK THROUGH THE LEADERSHIP OF
CAMERON FORNEY THE CEO OF
SELECT WE'VE HELPED BUILD A
LARGE COALITION OF TWENTY FIVE
PLUS CANNABIS INDUSTRY
BUSINESSES. TO COME TOGETHER
AND RECOMMEND FIVE PILLARS NOW
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE WOULD LEAD
TO AN EFFECTIVE AN IMMEDIATE
IMPACT ON A LIST OF VAPING
PRODUCTS WE'VE SHARED OUR
COALITION RECOMMENDATIONS WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE FIVE
PILLARS INCLUDE ADDRESSING THE
ILLICIT MARKET. ENHANCING
TESTING REGULATIONS CERTIFYING
HARDWARE AND FACILITIES. AND I
COUNTERFEITING EFFORTS AND
CERTIFIED SHIPPING. WE'VE HAD
MANY DISCUSSIONS AND MEETINGS
WITH GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS
CANNABIS REGULATORS. AND WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THEIR EFFORT
AND INTEREST TO WORK WITH US
AND DISCUSS OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
WE'RE EXCITED A PARTNER AND
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
SPECIFICALLY YOUR COMMITTEES.
TO ENSURE THAT YOUTH VAPING
EPIDEMIC IS NOT ONLY REDUCED
WITHOUT STRONG EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT IS DIRECTED AT
AROUND A KIDDING ILLEGAL
ENCOUNTER FOR VAPING PRODUCTS
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMUNITY TODAY AND HAVING THIS
HEARING IF THERE'S ONE MESSAGE
I WOULD LIKE THE COMMITTEE TO
TAKE AWAY FROM THIS IS THREE
WORDS BANDS DON'T WORK MY NAME
IS LOUIS HAN I'M A CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AND I HAVE BETTER
THOUSANDS OF CANNABIS COMPANIES
FOR THE RQ GROUP A NINE YEAR
OLD INVESTOR NETWORK THAT HAS
INVESTED MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS. INTO
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY. A
MORATORIUM ON ALL CANNABIS
VAPING IS NOT THE ANSWER.
DESPITE YEARS OF CANNABIS DATA
PRODUCTS THING ON THE MARKET WE
ARE ONLY HEARING ABOUT THESE
ISSUES NOW THIS IS BECAUSE THIS
IS THE DEATH RATTLE OF
ILLEGITIMATE PRODUCERS ARE
USING FAST AND CHEAP METHODS IN
ORDER TO CLING. ON TO THE
MARKET SHARE THAT THEY HAVE
LEFT. A BAN ON CAMPUS BEEPING
IS EXACT RESPONSE THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR. BECAUSE THAT WILL
SHUT DOWN THEIR LEGITIMATE
COMPETITORS WHILE ALLOWING THEM
TO CONTINUE TO THRIVE. BANDS
WILL ONLY PERPETUATE THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS INSTEAD WE
SHOULD INVEST MORE RESOURCES
INTO ENFORCEMENT AND RESEARCH.
SO I ENCOURAGE OUR LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER THESE ALTERNATIVES
BANDS DIDN'T WORK FOR
PROHIBITION IT DIDN'T WORK FOR
THE WAR ON DRUGS AND WON'T WORK
NOW. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS CUT THE MUSTARD
WITH AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
AGAIN LIKE EVERYONE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS HEARING
TODAY ONE UNDERSCORE SOME
COMMENTS FROM THE FIRST PANEL.
AND TALK ABOUT THE EPIDEMIC
WE'RE SEEING IN TEEN VAPING WE
HAVE BEEN THE SPONSORS ALONG
WITH A NUMBER OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES IN ENCOURAGING THIS
LEGISLATURE AND WE HOPE TO WORK
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. IN
BANNING SORRY NOT MY BEST A
FOLLOWING THE LAST ELEMENTS BUT
BANNING THE USE OR THE SALE OF
ALL FLAVORED E. CIGS ENDS AND
COMBUSTIBLE TOBACCO PRODUCTS WE
THINK THIS IS THE WAY TO GO
CERTAINLY WE HEARD THE
TESTIMONY. THAT UP INTO A POINT
THAT THE BAND HAS WORKED WE
HAVE SEEN A DECREASE IN TEEN
AND USE USE BUT THAT WERE. LEFT
OUT MENTAL SO WE DO THINK THAT
MENTAL IMAGE NEED TO BE A PART
OF THIS BAND SO WE ENCOURAGE
WANT TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THESE COMMITTEES
AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU. TO WORK
ON THAT THIS AT SOME COMING
SESSION. JUST LARIFY YOUR
COMMENTS THERE. DID YOU INCLUDE
HE SAID A BAN ON THE H. C. AND
TOBACCO WE HAVE A LOT WE DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON CAMPUS AT
THIS POINT WE ARE LOOKING INTO
THAT BUT THAT IS AN AREA THAT
WE HAVEN'T LOOKED OUT BEFORE WE
HAVE BEEN FOCUSED ON ON BEEPING
EIGHTY SIX AS WELL AS OUR- MEN.
A COMBUSTIBLES OKAY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DARIA MCGREW ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR. AND
THE ATTENTION THERE'S CLEARLY
SEVERAL COMPLEX ISSUES AT PLAY
HERE. SEPARATING OUT THE
DISCUSSION OF FLAVORS AND THE
DISCUSSION OF. CANNABIS AND THE-
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT COULD
BE USED TO ADDRESS THE VAPING
RELATED ILLNESS CDA IS
SUPPORTIVE OF. MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH IS THAT ADDRESS ALL OF
THESE THROUGH SEPARATE. POLICY
ISSUES INCLUDING A BAN ON
FLAVORS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LARA DOCKS DEAL
WITH EVEN ENTERPRISES WHICH AS
A FULLY LICENSED VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED CANNABIS COMPANY
THAT INCLUDES MANUFACTURING
VAPE PRODUCTS WHICH ARE
RIGOROUSLY TESTED AS YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
I'VE BEEN HEARING WHICH IS THAT
YES THE PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE IS
VERY IMPORTANT AND SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED IN A SMART AND
AFFECTIVE WAY. NOT WITH
REACTIONARY BANDS BUT WITH
THOROUGH RESEARCH PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND REALLY GETTING TO
THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM WHICH
WE'VE HEARD IS DIRECTLY
CONNECTED TO THE ILLICIT MARKET
CREATED THROUGH PROHIBITION AND
LACK OF ENFORCEMENT THAT BEING
SAID AND I AGREE WITH OTHERS
THAT THIS ISSUE IS BEING
SOMEWHAT COMPLETED WITH THE
YOUTH OF BEEPING AND THE
TRACTOR FLAVORS BUT IF THE
STATE. IN OTHER LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES ARE CONSIDERING
A FLAVOR BàN I WOULD THAT
WOULD EXTEND TO CANNABIS I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CAREFULLY CONSIDER AND MAKE
CLEAR THE DEFINITION OF FLAVOR
WHICH SHOULD FOCUS ON
ARTIFICIAL FLAVORS RATHER THAN
NATURALLY OCCURRING TERPENES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU HELLO
ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION AND
WE ALSO STAND READY TO WORK
WITH AND BE A RESOURCE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE REGULATORY
AGENCIES. AS COVERED
EXHAUSTIVELY TODAY THIS IS A
YOUTH ANALYST AT MARKET ISSUE
AND WE ARE ALSO LOOKING AT BEST
PRACTICES AND HAVE SEEN IN
EUROPE AND THAT THEY HAVE A
VERY VIGOROUS EDUCATION EFFORT
ON THE USE OF A BEING. DEVICES
AND HARDWARE AND ALSO LIMIT
NICOTINE CONTENT AND OTHER
INGREDIENTS INSIDE THE DEVICES
AND NOTABLY DO NOT HAVE THE
SAME ISSUES THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING HERE. I'M AND
LASTLY THE NOTABLE ABSENCE OF
REPORT CITING CASES ARISING
FROM LEGAL REGULATED OUTLET
SPEAK STRONGLY TO THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF CONTROLLED
ACCESS AND REGULATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN GRAY CHAIRMAN WOULD
HAVE IN THE JENKINS HERE ON
BEHALF OF TO YOU I CAMPUS
OPERATORS BLOOM FARMS AND
SUNDAY GOODS. BOTH
MANUFACTURERS OF INHALABLE
PRODUCTS LICENSE COMPLIANCE
ENTITIES THAT ARE SUBJECT TO
ALL THE RIGOROUS TESTING
STANDARDS I'M A ONE ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY KEN A CRAFT
CCA AN ARC VIEW. BANDS JUST
SIMPLY WILL NOT WORK IN THE
SITUATION AND THE LINKAGES WITH
COMPLIANT PRODUCTS IS JUST
SIMPLY NOT THERE AT THIS POINT
IN TIME. BOTH BLOOM FARMS AND
SUNDAY GOODS IS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO PARTNER WITH THIS
LEGISLATURE AND OUR
ASSOCIATIONS I'VE NEVER SEEN SO
MANY GROUPS COALESCING AND
WORKING TOGETHER TO TRY TO
RESOLVE THIS ISSUE WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BE PARTNERS. A
COUPLE LAST MINUTE COMMENTS
ILLICIT MARKET AND WE NEED MORE
ENFORCEMENT DOLLARS AND WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO CHAMPION THAT
I'M ACCESS CONTINUES TO BE AT
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE IS YOU KNOW.
AND THEN ADOPTING SOME ANTI
COUNTERFEITING. MEASURES WOULD
CERTAINLY BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY MICHAEL
WHEELER I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF POLICY WITH FLOW KANA AND
WERE CANNABIS DISTRIBUTOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING TIME
TODAY WITH THIS HEARING
OBVIOUSLY A VERY COMPLICATED
ISSUE I ASK ECHO MANY OF MY
PEERS WITH REGARDS TO THEIR
REMARKS AROUND THE USEFULNESS
EFFECTIVENESS OF BANDS AND
PROHIBITION THEY DON'T WORK I
THINK WE'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF HOW HOW WE
ENCOURAGE USE OF THE REGULATED
MARKET THROUGH REDUCING
TAXATION AND INCREASING ACCESS
TO A LEGAL REGULATED PRODUCT
HOWEVER WHAT I WANTED TO ADD TO
THE COMMENTS TODAY WERE THAT.
I'VE GOT THREE KIDS AT HOME
THEY'RE YOUNG THEY'RE NOT TO
EXPOSE TO THIS YET BUT I MEAN
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT IT I'M
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT TEEN
VAPING AND ABSOLUTELY
POSITIVELY YOU KNOW WE STAND AT
YOUR SIDE IN INCOME WORKING IN
ANY WAY TO STAMP OUT TEAM
VAPING THIS IS A HORRIBLE
EPIDEMIC I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
WHEN I DIDN'T HEAR ANY OF THE
PANELISTS TALK ABOUT TODAY WAS
SOME OF THE FACTORS THAT ADD TO
THE COOLNESS SO WHEN YOU GET A
CHANCE TO TAKE A LOOK AT YOU
TO. GO LOOK AT TEEN THEY ARE
VAPE TRACKS ANYTHING HAVING TO
DO WITH VAPE TRICKS ON YOUTUBE
IT'S AMAZING IT'S REALLY COOL
YOU'LL BE YOUR JOB WILL DROP
AND THIS IS PART OF WHAT MAKES
IT COOL KIDS SIT AROUND ALL DAY
SUCKING ON THEIR ON THEIR THE
PEN DOING THESE TRICKS OVER AND
OVER AGAIN IT'S PRACTICE
PRACTICE MAKES PERFECT BUT IT'S
ADDING TO THE USE OF THESE
PRODUCTS SO. JUST ANOTHER
ANOTHER DATA POINT FOR ALL OF
THIS THANKS. GOOD AFTERNOON
PAMELA LOPEZ WITH CASE STREET
CONSULTING. ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY CANNABIS
ALLIANCE. CANNABIS IS MEDICINE
AND LICENSED AND REGULATED.
FOLKS IN THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ARE ABSOLUTE PARTNERS AND
WORKING WITH YOU TO GET TO THE
HEART OF THIS CRISIS. WE WOULD
URGE YOU TO REMEMBER AT THAT
ACCESS TO CANNABIS IS AN
IMPORTANT WAY. TO HELP
CONSUMERS GET AWAY FROM THE
BLACK MARKET ILLICIT PRODUCTS
THAT ARE MAKING THEM SICK. IF I
RECALL CORRECTLY TO DATE ONLY
SIX HUNDRED LICENSED RETAILERS
EXIST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE LICENSED NON. OUT
STOREFRONT DISTRIBUTORS THAT'S
DOWN FROM THREE THOUSAND
STOREFRONTS THAT WERE OPEN.
BEFORE THE PASSAGE OF PROP
SIXTY FOUR AND BEFORE CANNABIS
WAS LICENSED AND REGULATED. SO
THERE WILL ALWAYS BE BAD GUYS
WHO ARE TRYING TO SELL ILLICIT
STUFF ON THE BLACK MARKET TO
MAKE A QUICK BUCK. BUT IT'S OUR
JOB IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TO MAKE SURE THAT CONSUMERS.
HAVE ACCESS TO PRODUCTS THAT
THEY KNOW ARE LICENSED AND SAFE.
HI SABRINA FANDRICH WITH
BERKELEY PATIENTS GROUP AND
JUST TO REITERATE WHAT SOME OF
THE OTHER PEOPLE OF SAID WE OUR
COUNTRY IN OUR STATE OF GONE
THROUGH MULTIPLE ITERATIONS OF
PROHIBITION. EVERY SINGLE TIME
WE REALIZE THAT IT DOESN'T WORK
OUT THAT WAS THE WHOLE POINT OF
PROP SIXTY FOUR HOWEVER WHEN
YOU HAVE TWO THIRDS OF THE
STATE THAT ARE BANNING RETAIL
SALES IT SHOULDN'T BE A
SURPRISE TO ANYONE. THAT WE'RE
SEEING THE BATHTUB GIN OF
TWENTY NINETEEN HAPPENING OR
THE QUE TO SPICE OF TWENTY
NINETEEN HAPPENING. I WOULD
ALSO NOTE. IT'S IMPORTANT WHEN
TALKING ABOUT FLAVORS TO
CONSIDER THE GENESIS OF THE
FLAVOR IT WAS MENTIONED BEFORE
AND THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
NATURALLY OCCURRING FLAVORS AND
ARTIFICIAL FLAVORS. AND ALSO I
WANTED TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION OF AND NOBODY HAS
MENTIONED TODAY IS LOOKING AT
THE DATA IN THE U. K. AND IN
EUROPE AND- THIS IS A VERY
UNIQUELY AMERICAN CRISIS DOWN.
THE UNITED KINGDOM HAS ONE OF
THE LOWEST YOUTH USE RATES AND
ACTUALLY SUBSIDIZES VAPE
SMOKING AND PROMOTED AS SMOKING
SENSATION POLICY. AND THERE
SHOULD WE SHOULD ASK THE
QUESTION AS TO WHY WHY IS THERE
A DISCONNECT BETWEEN YOU KNOW
EVIDENCE BASED PUBLIC POLICY
AND- EMOTIONALLY DRIVEN
PROHIBITIVE POLICIES THAT ARE.
UNIQUELY AMERICAN THAT WE NEED
TO LOOK AWAY FROM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS ERIC ACOSTA WITH THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION TODAY ON THIS ISSUE
AND WE JUST SIMPLY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
INCLUDING FLAVORS IN THE
CONVERSATION PARTICULARLY MEANT
AND MENTHOL AGAIN VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION FOR
THE FOR THE CONVERSATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
A CHAIRMAN GRAY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALEX
THOMPSON I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
COMPLIANCE FOR PURE EXTRACTS
VAPORIZER CARTRIDGE
MANUFACTURER AND DEL REY OAKS I
WORK ALONGSIDE THREE DOZEN
DILIGENT ETHICAL PEOPLE
PASSIONATELY HOPING MEDICINAL
AND RECREATIONAL CONSUMERS
THROUGH OUR PRODUCTS. AS I HOPE
EACH OF YOU CAN SAY I LOVE MY
WORK I JOIN THE REGULATED
CANNABIS INDUSTRY EIGHT YEARS
AGO AS A CROHN'S DISEASE SUFFER
AND DOCTORAL STUDENT CANNABIS
SAVE MY LIFE THEN AND STILL
PROVIDES ME WITH LIFE CHANGING
SYMPTOM RELIEF PARTICULARLY
WHEN VAPORIZED AS A PATIENT
SCHOLAR IN INDUSTRY MEMBER
PLEASE HEAR ME THAT RASH ACTION
ON THIS TOPIC MAY HAVE
DISASTROUS FALLOUT. SINCE FIRST
HEARING OF RECENT MEDICINAL
CONCERN OVER VAPORIZER PRODUCTS
PURE EXTRACTS BEGIN INTENSIVE
RESEARCH SUPPLEMENTAL
LABORATORY TESTING. AND MADE
POINT REQUESTS ARE CANNABIS
VENDORS TRIPPING SUPPLIERS AND
CARTRIDGE PRODUCT MANUFACTURERS
FOR ALL AVAILABLE RESEARCH AND
SAFETY DATA. WE WELCOME YOUR
FURTHER GUIDANCE IN PROTECTING
OUR CONSUMER SAFETY
PARTICULARLY FOCUSING ON
CUTTING AGENCIES WITHIN THE
ILLICIT MARKET THOUGH.
INCLUDING VITAMIN A ACETAT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
LABORATORY TESTING AND CONSUMER
WARNING REQUIREMENTS. WE'LL
NEVER IGNORE THE WELL BEING OF
OUR CONSUMERS WE ARE ALSO
SINCERELY CONCERNED THOUGH
ABOUT THE LIVELY ARMOR
LIKELIHOODS AND THE MEDICINAL
NEEDS OF OUR THOUSANDS OF
CONSUMERS. PLEASE COLLABORATE
WITH OUR INDUSTRY TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE AND AT WITHIN AN
EVIDENCE BASED MANNER. THAT
PROVIDES AN ONGOING ACCESS TO
AND NINE COMBUSTED IN HELLO
CANNABIS OPTION THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS JOHN WITH LEADERSHIP
I'M SPEAKING ON THE ILLICIT
MARKET. THE LACK OF ENFORCEMENT
A OF THIS MARKET IS NOT REALLY
THE PROBLEM IS A LACK OF
LICENSING IN THE CITY. SO MANY
OF US THAT WERE IN THE ILLICIT
MARKET IN A LOT OF THESE
COMPANIES FORGET THE MAJOR
COMPANIES FORGET THAT THEY WERE
IN A LISTEN MARKET AT ONE POINT
IN TIME AND HOW DID THEY GET
THE MONEY IN ORDER TO GET THE
LICENSE THAT THEY DO HAVE NOW.
I'VE BEEN STRUGGLING FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS IN ORDER TO
GET LICENSING IN THE INDUSTRY
AND NOBODY HAS BEEN ABLE TO
GIVE IT TO ME SO I'VE BEEN
DOING THE BEST THAT I CAN IN
ORDER TO TRY TO YOU KNOW GET
THE CORRECT INFORMATION TO GET
IN THE INDUSTRY. SO FOR A LOT
OF US IN THE ILLICIT MARKET WE
ARE DEFINITELY TRYING TO BEST
WE HAVE FAMILIES WE TAKE CARE
OF BUSINESS AND SO FORTH. BUT
IT'S KIND OF HARD WHEN YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN POWER THEY
CONTROL THE NARRATIVE. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
AND ALCOR I CHAIR THE ANTI
VAPING ALLIANCE AT RIO
AMERICANO HIGH SCHOOL TODAY I
BROUGHT PROPS THIS IS MONTHS
WORTH OF CONFISCATED DEVICES
FROM THE HIGH SCHOOL. I'D TAKE
THEM JUST ABOUT EVERYWHERE I GO
BECAUSE I FIND THAT THEY ARE
THE BEST EDUCATIONAL TOOL THAT
WE HAVE IN THIS FIGHT SO IT'S A
VARIETY OF NICOTINE AND
MARIJUANA DEVICES AND AS WE
HEARD TODAY THE STUDENTS ARE.
VAPING THESE DEVICES
INTERCHANGEABLY. I. I AM ASKING
THAT WE DO SOMETHING URGENTLY I
THINK WAITING UNTIL THE NEXT
LEGISLATIVE SESSION DELAYS THIS
AND WE ARE CEDING STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES TRULY SUFFERING WITH
ADDICTION ALREADY THEY'RE
SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY ON
ADDICTION COUNSELORS. TEACHERS
AND ADMINISTRATORS ARE HAVING A
VERY DIFFICULT TIME EDUCATING
OUR KIDS BECAUSE OF THIS
DISTRACTION. THE SCHOOLS NEED
MORE HELP SO I ASK YOU FOR
ATTENTION TO THE SCHOOLS EITHER
ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL OR
ADDITIONAL HELP AT THE STATE
LEVEL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LAURIE BREMNER WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT WE CAN DO
TO TACKLE THE TEEN E. CIGARETTE
EPIDEMIC IS TO PASS A POLICY
THAT PROHIBITS THE SALE OF ALL
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
SINGLE FLAVOR POLICY WITH NO
EXEMPTIONS ENSURES THAT YOUTH
DON'T GO FROM ONE TYPE OF
TOBACCO PRODUCTS TO ANOTHER. TO
CHASE THE CANDY FLAVOR THAT GOT
THEM HOOKED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
MINTON MENTHOL ARE EXTREMELY
POPULAR AMONG YOUTH. AND
EXEMPTING THOSE FLAVORS WOULD
UNDERMINE ALL EFFORTS DESIGNED
TO LIMIT YOUTH INITIATION.
LEGISLATORS INTRODUCED TO BILLS
LAST YEAR THAT WOULD HAVE
PROHIBITED THE SALE OF ALL
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS BUT
THEY DID NOT ADVANCE. JUL
ANOTHER TOBACCO COMPANIES LOBBY
FURIOUSLY AGAINST LABOR
POLICIES BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY
WILL RESULT IN A REDUCTION OF
TOBACCO USE IN OUR STATE. THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK HOPES THAT THE
OUTCOME OF THESE HEARINGS WILL
BE FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT
THE CONSENSUS. ALONG WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH COMMUNITY AND
MORE THAN FORTY CALIFORNIA
CITIES THE PROHIBITING THE SALE
OF ALL FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS WITH NO EXEMPTIONS IS
THE BEST WAY TO COMBAT YOUTH
TOBACCO ADDICTION. WE NEED A
HOLE JEWEL AND THE OTHER
TOBACCO COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE DISASTER THAT THEY'VE
CAUSED BY PASSING A BILL THAT
PROHIBITS THE SALE OF ALL
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS THE
NEED IS URGENT. WE NEED TO GET
THIS DONE. JUST TO CLARIFY
AGAIN FOR THE RECORD. THERE'S A
LOT OF CONFISCATING ON THIS
ISSUE THAT WAS JUST ON TOBACCO
OR ON ALL VAPING. I'M
ADDRESSING ONLY TOBACCO AGE
TOBACCO PRODUCTS BUT ALL
TOBACCO PRODUCTS INCLUDING
MENTHOL AND MEANT. COMBUSTIBLE
CIGARETTES AS WELL. THANK YOU.
HI THANKS EVERYBODY FOR COMING
TOGETHER TODAY MY NAME IS MIKE
CLEMENS ON THE PRESIDENT CO
FOUNDER OF KILLED EXTRACTS WERE
LICENSED MANUFACTURER OPEN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AS HAS BEEN
EXPLORED TODAY CALIFORNIA SPENT
YEARS CAREFULLY CRAFTING A
FRAMEWORK OF REGULATORY
CONTROLS TO ADDRESS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH RISKS WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT TODAY LIKE THE API. I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE'RE SEEING
A FAILURE OF THESE CONTROLS I
THINK THAT WE'RE SEEING THE
RESULT OF A FAILURE TO
ADEQUATELY SUPPORT LEGAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY WITHIN THIS
FRAMEWORK THE ECONOMIC BURDENS
ON THE INDUSTRY FROM THE
REGULATORY LAYER HAS DRIVEN UP
PRICES AND DRIVEN CONSUMERS TO
CONTINUE TO PURCHASE FROM THE
ILLICIT MARKET. TO MISTER
COOPER'S POINT A RECENT AUDIT
FOUND CLOSE TO THREE THOUSAND
ILLEGAL RETAILERS IN CALIFORNIA
VERSES THE EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE THAT MS A TAXES
TEAM AT THE BCC HAS LICENSE A
LACK OF ENFORCEMENT AGAINST THE
BAD ACTORS ACROSS THE STATE HAS
RESULTED IN A BLACK MARKET
THAT'S NOT ONLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
REGULATED. THIS IS. BUT IT
ALSO. OPERATES OUTSIDE OF THE
OVERSIGHT THAT SUPPOSED TO
INSURE PRODUCTS CONFORM TO A
SAFE STANDARD. FURTHER MORE ANY
MOVE TO JUST COMPLETELY BAN ANY
PRODUCT ALTOGETHER WILL ONLY
EXACERBATE A DANGEROUS
SITUATION BY DRIVING MORE
CONSUMERS. AWAY FROM A
REGULATED BUSINESSES TO THE
ILLICIT SOURCES. AND IS STILL
FAILS TO ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEM OF CONTAMINATION IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN. IT WOULD BE
DISASTROUS TO THE INDUSTRY AND
TO THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT IF IS ENTRUSTED THEIR
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO WORK
TOGETHER. TO MAKE THIS INDUSTRY
WORK WOULD ALSO THREATEN THE
ENTIRE STATE PROGRAM THAT WE'VE
ALL WORKED REALLY HARD TO
CREATE SO WE JUST NEED TO
ENFORCE THE LAW. AND WE NEED TO
MAKE COMPLIANCE LESS COSTLY FOR
THE GOOD ACTORS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MARIN BE NOW ON THE HAVE
THE NAY CAN I WAS VINCE ASSIST
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION WE FIVE
WE'VE ACTIVELY HAVE WORKED AT
TO PUSH. FOR PENALTIES UNDER
PROPS. AS PROP SIXTY FOUR WAS
DRAFTED ONLY TO ALLOW FOR
PENALTIES FOR LEGAL. OPERATORS
SO FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
YOU HAD STATE AGENCIES. AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT NOT HAVING THE
TOOLS NECESSARY TO SHUT DOWN
THE LEGAL MARKET. AB NINETY
SEVEN IS THE FIRST STEP THAT WE
WORKED ON AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN
WHICH- ALLOW THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. I DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
IN CITY ATTORNEYS TO IMPOSE
PENALTIES WAS HELD IN THE
SENATE. APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WE'VE THAT. THERE'S A
CRISIS WE ARE LEGAL WE HAVE
ENSURE THAT OUR PRODUCTS ARE
SAFE.  A BAN ON ALL BEEPING
PRODUCTS WILL ONLY PUSH PEOPLE
TO THE LEGAL MARKET. WE WANTED
THE RIGHT THING AND WE'VE BEEN
ADVOCATING THIS FOR YEARS. AND
NOW THERE'S A CRISIS. NOW
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT THEY
LEGAL MARK AND. USED TO BE SHUT
DOWN THAT WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATING
THAT FOR YEARS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN TIM AND
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF CARDIOLOGY AND SINCE I'M THE
LAST PERSON I WILL GO TOO MUCH
LONGER BUT CONSISTENT WITH WITH
SOME OTHER FOLKS THAT FIVE
MENTIONED WE BELIEVE IS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT A BAN ON ALL
VAPING PRODUCTS IS THE WAY TO
GO AND LISTENING TO DR DEAN'S
TESTIMONY WAR THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS SAYING. PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT BE VAPING AT ALL ON
WE THINK IS THE PRUDENT
APPROACH SO WE WANT TO GET TO
THE NEXT LEVEL ON THE AND WE
ARE ASKING FOR BAND SIMILAR TO
WHAT WAS DONE IN MASSACHUSETTS
ALTHOUGH THEY DID ON A FOUR
MONTH TIME FRAME ON ALL VAPING
PRODUCTS. THANK THANK YOU.
HELLO DEAR GEILO PRESIDENT THE
UNITED CAN AS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION GONNA KEEP IT SHORT
REGULATIONS ARE JUST
SUGGESTIONS. WITHOUT
ENFORCEMENT. THAT IS WHAT WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON WE ARE TRYING
TO BUILD AN INDUSTRY OR TRYING
TO KEEP SAFETY AND SECURITY
MONTHS ARE CONSUMERS. AND WE
DON'T HAVE A GOOD ENFORCEMENT
BRANCH WE ARE JUST ALLOWING
THESE REGULATIONS TO JUST KIND
OF GO. PASSES BY WE'RE NOT
REALLY FOCUSING ON WHAT THE
EFFECTS ARE NOT ONLY FOR THE
INDUSTRY IS ITS GROWTH BUT ALSO
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF ITS
CONSUMERS THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. THAT BRINGS US
TO THE CONCLUSION OF PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL LIVE BRING IT BACK
HERE. TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
CLOSING COMMENTS I'D LIKE TO.
THANK CHAIRMAN WOULD CHAIRMAN
LOW I THINK THIS IS BEEN. VERY
INFORMATIVE HEARING I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A LONG. AFTERNOON BUT THIS
IS A TREMENDOUSLY MPORTANT
SUBJECT I KNOW WE ALL SHARE. A
DESIRE TO MOVE FORWARD. WITH
SOME SOLUTIONS IN CONCRETE.
ACTIVITY VIA EARLY IN THE
LEGISLATIVE YOUR NEXT YEAR SO.
THANK YOU AGAIN GERMAN
KNOWLEDGE YOU MAKES CLOSING
REMARKS. I JUST THINK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR WORKING WITH US
TO PUT THIS TOGETHER OBVIOUSLY.
WHEN YOU FILL THE ROOM AND NOT
LET IN A AND I'M NOT
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. YOU
CLEARLY HAVE A TOPIC OF
INTEREST AND- APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION WE LEARN TODAY WE
WILL USE THIS TO. CRAFT A AN
ADDITIONAL HEARING. TO EXPLORE
THIS ISSUE FURTHER. AND JUST SO
PEOPLE KNOW WE ARE NOT IN
SESSION. WE CANNOT TAKE ANY
SORT OF LEGISLATIVE ACTION NOW.
UNTIL WE RECONVENE IN JANUARY
THAT'S JUST THE WAY THE- IT
WORKS SO. WE APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S ATTENDS HERE ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS EVERYBODY WHO
CAME AND MANY PEOPLE CAME FROM
A LONG DISTANCE TO. PARTICIPATE
TODAY I THINK IT'S BEEN REALLY
VALUABLE INFORMATION AND- LOOK
FORWARD. TO EVERY CONVENE AND
ASK US IN THIS PROJECT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WITH THAT WORD
WITH THAT WERE INJURED